BILLS IN EDUCATION AND GOT IT
ALL DONE IN HALF AN HOUR SO I'M
I'M.
VERY PLEASED WITH THE THAT -- IT
LET'S NOW CALL TO ORDER THE
MEETING HEARING HERE TODAY OF
THE SENATE BERMAN A QUALITY
COMMITTEE -- FOR APRIL THIRD
WE'VE GOT A ROBUST AND EXCITING
AGENDA LOTS OF INTERESTING BILLS.
AND I SEE CENTER WIENER IS HERE
TO PRESENT ITEM THREE IN YOUR
PACKETS MEMBERS THAT IS SB.
ONE SIXTY SIX RELATING TO
BREWERIES AND WINERIES.
LET'S CALL THE ROLL FIRST
[inaudible]
ALLEN HERE [inaudible]
PRESENTS.
EIGHT IT DOESN'T HELP
[inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
THEN PRESENT.
HERE.
OKAY SO I BELIEVE WE JUST BARELY
HAVE A QUORUM THAT'S FANTASTIC
SO WE CAN CAST VOTES I CENTER WE
PROCEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M
INSTAGRAM AND THANK YOU TO YOU
INNER SELF WITH US ON AS TO ONE
SIXTY SIX WHICH IS A HOT WATER
REVIEW STILL -- COURSE KNOW THAT
WE HAVE A LONG TERM STRUCTURAL
WATER SHORTAGE IN CALIFORNIA AND
EVEN THOUGH -- DROUGHT IS NOT
TECHNICALLY OVER I THINK
STATEWIDE NOW -- IT'S GOING TO
COME BACK AND WE HAVE TO MAKE
BETTER USE OF THE WATER.
I THAT WE HAVE I WANT TO THANK
THIS COMMITTEE -- FOR LAST YEAR
WORKING WITH US ON SB NINE OH
FIVE TO TRY TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR A CITIES TO IMPLEMENT ON
SITE WATER RELEASE PROGRAMS.
SB ONE SIXTY SIX HOUSES A GOAL
TO MAKE IT EASIER -- FOR
BREWERIES AND WINERIES -- TO
ENGAGE IN WATER.
RE USE AND SO THE BILL.
WHICH IS RIGHT NOW IF I SENSE A
PLACE HOLDER BILL WE'RE WORKING
WITH -- STAKEHOLDERS TO CRAFT A
DETAILS AND WE WILL OF COURSE BE --
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THIS
COMMITTEE AS WE DO THAT AND AS
IT MOVES TO THE PROCESS.
BUT IF YOU WANT SIXTY SIX IS A
CURRENTLY STANDS WILL DIRECT THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD TO CAMINO WORKING GROUP
AIMED ADVISING THE LEGISLATURE
IN CLEAR.
AND CONSISTENT WATER QUALITY
STANDARDS -- FOR THE RESEARCH
PROCESS WATER.
ON SITE APPROVED WINERIES WHICH
IS THE WATER THAT CLEANS THE
SYSTEMS AND THOSE ARE.
WE COULD DRAMATICALLY REDUCE --
THAT WATER -- THROUGH USE --
RIGHTNOW IT TAKES ON AVERAGE
FIVE TO SEVEN GALLONS OF WATER
TO PRODUCE ONE GALLON OF BEER
BURKE SOME WINERIES -- AND WHAT
THAT MEANS IS THAT EACH OF THESE
ARE BROUGH RISEN WINERIES AS
THEY PURSUE A PERMIT HAVE TO
RECREATE THE WHEEL ON OF COURSE.
ALL OF THOSE PERMITS HAVE HEALTH
AND SAFETY PROVISIONS AND AND I
THINK THE INDUSTRY OF THE WHAT
THE THE BUSINESSES THAT ARE
ENGAGED IN WATER WE USE A DOING
A GREAT JOB AND I REALLY ADMIRE
WHAT THEY'RE DOING BUT WE SHOULD
MAKE IT EASIER. TO HAVE THIS
HAPPEN MORE BROADLY -- WITHIN
THE INDUSTRY ALSO WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING THE INDUSTRY -- AND
THEY ARE ENGAGING WITH US AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT.
ALSO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE I WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
IS TAYLOR TRYING OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION OUR SPONSOR.
I WHICH IS.
GRANT PROGRAM I IN SAN FRANCISCO
AIMED AT HELPING BREWERIES SAFE
WATER THROUGH REVIEWS.
THANK YOU SENATOR A GOOD MORNING
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION HAS A NUMBER OF
INNOVATIVE WATER.
CONSERVATION AND WATER RECYCLING
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS IN PLACE.
TODAY SAN FRANCISCO WATER USE
RANKS AMONG THE LOWEST IN THE
STATE.
RECOGNIZING WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO USE WATER MORE
EFFICIENTLY AT BREWERIES AND
WINERIES WE RECENTLY EXPANDED
OUR WATER RECYCLING GRANT
PROGRAM FOR BREEZE TO TREAT AND
REVIEWS PROCESS WATER ON SITE.
IN CALIFORNIA TO ENABLE OTHER
BREWERIES AND WINERIES TO
RECYCLE PROCESS WATER WE NEED
STRAIGHT FORWARD AND CONSISTENT
STANDARDS FOR INSTALLING WATER
RECYCLING SYSTEM STATEWIDE.
SENATE BILL ONE SIX SIX SUPPORTS
THE SCHOOL IT DIRECTS THE WATER
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD TO STUDY THE APPROPRIATE
WATER QUALITY STANDARDS. FOR
TREATING PROCESS WATER IN
BREWERIES AND WINERIES.
THIS LATEST LEGISLATION BUILDS
ON SAN FRANCISCO'S PROGRAM BY
MAKING IT EASIER FOR BREWERIES
AND WINERIES ACROSS THE STATE TO
CONSERVE WATER
WE COMMEND SENATOR WINNER FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF SB.
ONE SIX SIX SIX THANK YOU I LIVE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NOW ALL RIGHT THEY'RE JUST READY
YEAH WITNESSES THERE IS CONCERN.
OKAY.
NO WE DIDN'T HAVE REYES
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO OFFICES
YOU'RE OKAY OKAY THAT'S NOT
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS
WALKER BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
CRAFT BREWERS ASSOCIATION --
CERTAINLY WE PROMOTE
CONSERVATION AND REDUCE AND
ANYTHING WE CAN DO ARE AT ARBOR
RES AND OTHER BEVERAGE AND FOOD
FACILITIES TO INCREASE ONSITE
REVIEWS WERE VERY MUCH IN FAVOR
OF WE APPRECIATE THE CENTER'S
COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH US TO
FIGURE OUT WAYS THAT.
WE CAN ACTUALLY DECREASE ANY
BARRIERS -- OR COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH INCREASED RE USE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AGAIN WE LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH THE SENATOR AND HIS
OFFICE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR TERM MEMBERS
MOST ANALYSTS IN WITH ANHEUSER
BUSCH WHERE WERE AT A TWEENER
BUT WE'RE REALLY INTERESTED
POSITIVELY AND HOW THIS BILL'S
GOING TO LOOK.
JUST AS AN EXAMPLE ARE ELLIE
BREWERY WE WE RECYCLE ONE
HUNDRED MILLION GALLONS A DAY OF
WATER WE CAN ONLY USE TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND OF THAT TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND GALLONS OF THAT
WATER DUE.
TO CURRENT STATE RESTRICTIONS SO
IF THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO
LOOK AT OTHER WAYS TO USE THIS
WATER THAN WERE INTERESTED WE
JUST WANT TO BE A PART OF THE
PROCESS AND THE SENATOR HAS.
AGREED -- TO ALLOWING OUR
ENGINEERS WHO ARE EXPERTS ON
WATER RE USED TO BE PART OF THE
PROCESS AND AND WE'RE HAPPY WITH
THAT TO LOOK FORWARD TO THIS
BILL MOVING FORWARD THANKS.
A GOOD MANAGER MEMBERS TYLER
BLACKETT WINE INSTITUTE SIMILAR
TO OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE BEER
INDUSTRY WE DO NOT HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BILL AS AMENDED.
BUT WE DO APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS --
TENSIONS MATTER AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HIM TO
FIND CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO
POTTERY SOMEONE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MORE SO ORDER OF
THE FAMILY MY MAKERS OF
CALIFORNIA -- NO POSITION ON THE
BILL WE LIKED AMERICANA ENDS
WITH THE WINE INSTITUTE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OKAY THE ITEM IS NOW BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS.
THEIR STUFF THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF PROUD TO BE A CO
AUTHOR WITH MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
SAN FRANCISCO -- COMING FROM A
HAWAIIAN REGIONALLY GROWING
BREWERY REGION THAT HAS ITS --
WATER ISSUES.
AND SO THIS IS GOING TO COME IN
VERY HANDY FOR OUR ENTREPRENEURS
AS OUR COUNTRY IS GOING FROM
SIXTY ONE AREAS TO IT BUILD OUT
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND TEN AND
WE'VE GOT SOME GREAT BREWERIES
AND TO MACULA MERRY AT AREA.
AND SO -- I WOULD.
HARDLY -- ENCOURAGE EVERYONE
SUPPORT IN HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL THIS TIME SEN.
OUR BREWERIES AND WINERIES TO
MOVE BEYOND IT BEING -- STUDY
BILL -- AND SO -- THAT THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE THAT'S ALWAYS CAN BE
CONVENE STAKEHOLDERS -- WE WERE
ABLE TO GET IT DONE WITH THIS --
COMMITTEE.
BUT WE HAVE COMMITTED TO WE WILL
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH A
SEVENTY TWO COMMITTEE AND THE
STAFF.
ARE BECAUSE WE KNOW THE ANYTHING
THAT HAPPENS WILL ULTIMATELY
HAVE TO COME BACK ON CURRENTS
AND SO IT IS MY PRACTICE TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE IS INVOLVED
IN CRAFTING THE BILL.
THANK YOU CHAIR THE CLERK.
THANK YOU CENTERS OKAY SO THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
STONE -- CENTER IF YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
FAST RELIABLE.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH SO BILL
MOVE BY CENTER STONE -- SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
A ITEM NUMBER THREE SB ONE SIX
SIX THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE BATES RIGHT
BATES AYE HILL.
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
STONE.
STONE I LIKE HOUSE.
THE CASKET.
THANK YOU WILL HOLD THE ROLE OF
AN FOR ADS MEMBERS TO ADD ON
THANK YOU I I SEE AS CENTER
GALGIANI HERE.
I'VE TO PRESENT I AM TOO IN YOUR
PACKET THAT SB SIXTY EIGHT
RELATING TO TREATED WOOD WASTE.
YOU'RE MOST WELCOME.
THE STEAM SENATOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU AND
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SB SIXTY
EIGHT TODAY SB SIXTY EIGHT WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCE CONTROL TO INCLUDE A
CURRENT AND UPDATED LIST.
OF APPROVED LANDFILLS THAT
EXCEPT TREATED WOOD WASTE ON
THEIR WEBSITE.
DID WOOD IS A COMMONLY USED
MATERIAL IN CONSTRUCTION AND
INFRASTRUCTURE WERE EXPOSURE TO
MOISTURE INSECTS OR OTHER
ELEMENTS COMPROMISED THE WOULD
STRENGTH AND USEFUL LIFE.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIVE
DISPOSING TREATED WOOD WASTE
ANYWHERE OTHER THAN A COMPOSITE
LINED LANDFILL OR CLASS ONE
HAZARDOUS WASTE LANDFILL HAS
BEEN PROHIBITED BY LAW.
THIS BILL WOULD ENSURE THAT AN
UPDATED LIST OF APPROVED
LANDFILLS IS READILY ACCESSIBLE
TO THE PUBLIC.
WITH ME TODAY IS CATHERINE LYNCH
REPRESENTING THE WESTERN WOULD
INSTITUTE AND SHE WILL BE ABLE
TO ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I'VE WORKED ON THE PROPER
DISPOSAL WOULD WAY SINCE THE
INCEPTION OF THE PROGRAM AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AS THE BILL MOVES
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
SB SIXTY EIGHT ENJOYS BROAD
SUPPORT AND HAS NO OPPOSITION I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR HARD
WORK AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YEAH I'VE.
DID YOU CENTER AND I'M NOW
RECEIVE THIS DGSE REPORTS PASSED --
TO I GUESS EXPECTED LATER THIS
SESSION I'M.
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY WITH YOU
THAT YOU YOUR OFFICES PROMISED
TO BRING THE BILL BACK TO OUR
COMMITTEE IF THE BILL IS
SUBSTANTIALLY AMENDED TO REFLECT
ANY OF THE THE PENDING REPORT
YES THAT IS ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
OKAY THANK YOU SEN THANK YOU.
MORNING SENATOR ALLEN KATHY
LYNCH REPRESENTING THE WESTERN
WOULD PRESERVERS INSTITUTE --
REPRESENTING OVER.
TO MANUFACTURING FACILITY IN
FOUR THOUSAND EMPLOYEES IN
CALIFORNIA -- I THINK CENTER
GALGIANI AYE BOTH HAD THE
PLEASURE OF WORKING ON THIS
SINCE THE INCEPTION OF THE
PROGRAM THIS DOES CREATE.
A VERY GOOD PATHWAY FOR THE
DISPOSAL OF TREATED WOOD WASTE
INTO A COMPOSITE LINE LAND FILL
WITH MANAGED A SPECIAL
MANAGEMENT -- STANDARDS WE ARE
AWAITING THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
STUDY ON WHICH THE LEGISLATURE
FUNDED -- AND THE LAST GO AROUND
ON THE PROGRAM.
AND WE ANTICIPATE THAT STUDY
SHORTLY AND WE DID WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SOME.
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE STUDY
AND PROVIDED ALL -- INPUT TO
THEM ON TREATED WITH WASTE AND I
KNOW THE STUDY HAD SPECIFIC
FOCUSES SO WE'LL BE HAPPY.
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS AND WE APPRECIATE
THE STAFF'S WORK WITH US ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SO MUCH.
OKAY FOLKS HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
OF A GIVEN THE CALIFORNIA
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE YOUR CHRISTMAS KAYLEE ON
BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT MENDOCINO
REDWOOD COMPANIES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING I'M CAN DONE WITH
THE WEST COAST LUMBER BUILDING
MATERIAL ASSOCIATION WHERE THE
INDEPENDENT RETAIL DEALERS AND
WE SUPPORT THE BILL AS WELL.
AT WRIGLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
IF.
MAY BE AS REPRESENT CALIFORNIA
WROTE IN SUPPORT.
IN A SEVEN U. B. THANK YOU.
COM JACOB FOR THE CHEMICAL
INDUSTRY COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT THIS SAYS SENATE SIMPLY --
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY I ANYONE ELSE ANYONE WANTS
TO RAISE CONCERNS OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ISSUES OKAY.
SO THAT IS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE --
QUESTIONS THOUGHT.
I'M TO THE BILL'S REMOVE WITH
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT IF
THERE SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES TO
REFLECT THE OF THE DID YOU SEE
REPORT IT WILL COST TO COMMITTEE.
ISSUED THAT A GREAT DEAL SENATOR
AND IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
I'M THANK YOU MY FORMER BOSS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BARBER MATTHEWS
INTRODUCED THE FIRST LEGISLATION
ON THIS IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR AB.
THIRTEEN FIFTY THREE AND IT
REQUIRED THE STATE TO START --
SEPARATING TREATED WOOD FROM
UNTREATED WOULD SELL I'M PLEASED
TO BE ABLE -- TO CONTINUE AND
FURTHER THIS POLICY THAT WAS
INITIATED IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE IDOLS THANK
YOU CENTER THANK YOU.
AS EXCERPTED CORAL.
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB SIXTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE.
RIGHT BATES I KNOW.
I SKINNER.
STERN.
STONE STONE I LIKE HOUSE.
SK I THANK YOU CENTER.
SO YOU ACTUALLY HAVE A BILL ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR THAT SINCE
NO ONE ELSE IS HERE TO PRESENT
YET LET'S WHEN WE ENTERTAIN A
MOTION TO APPROVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THAT INCLUDES SB TWO
SIXTEEN OTHER BILLS.
I THINK I'M SUPPOSED TO ANNOUNCE
LONG AS IRAN.
ITEM THE ITEM NUMBERS NUMBER
FIVE EIGHT ELEVEN THIRTEEN AND
FIFTEEN IT'S REMOVED BECAUSE I
COUNT AS THE MOVE BY CENTER
STONE SECT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE ABATE RIGHT
BATES AYE HILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
STONE STONE I WHITE HOUSE.
RIGHT NOW IT IS ON A ROLL TODAY
SENATOR.
OUR CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR TO
SMASHING VICTORY HERE THE VERBAL
CALL THE COMMITTEE.
I SEEING THEIR WE DON'T HAVE IN
THE CENTERS WHEN I I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD AND TURN THE GAVEL OVER TO
THE VICE CHAIR AND PRESENT SB
.
FORTY FIVE PLEASE PROCEED WITH
THANK YOU MADAM I SHARE NUMBERS
HI I WANNA OBVIOUSLY A START BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS -- THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS.
LISTED IN COMMON FIVE THIS
COMMITTEE -- AND ALSO THE SAID
THERE WAS AGREED TO IN THE
NATURAL SCIENCES COMMITTEE.
LAST WEEK WHEN THE BILL WAS HER
THERE.
I ALSO I KNOW THAT TOWN SOME OF
JERRY.
AT HEALTH CENTER HELD SOME OF
OUR VERY MEMBERS HAVE EXPRESSED
CONCERN WITH THE DEFINITION OF
THIS ADVANCED COMMUNITY SINCE IT
POINTS TO A STATEWIDE INSTEAD OF
AN AVERAGE.
AREA -- IN THE AREA I INCOME
AVERAGING WHAT WHAT WE'RE GONNA
FIX THAT.
WE HAD A ROBUST DISCUSSION IN
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE IN
AS THIS ANALYSIS POINTS OUT SB
FORTY FIVE IS VERY MUCH A WORK
IN PROGRESS AND OTHER WE'VE
STILL GOT A WAYS TO GO TO FLESH
OUT THE DETAILS.
HI BUT ULTIMATELY IF THIS BILL
IS IS PASS AND THEN HOUSE NOT BY-THE VOTERS.
SB FORTY FIVE WILL FIND ON THE
GROUND PROJECTS DESIGNED TO HELP
US PREPARE FOR THE EXTREME
WEATHER EVENTS ANOTHER IMPACTS
THAT WE'RE ALREADY SEEING AS A
RESULT OF CLIMATE CHANGE SEVERE
WILDFIRES.
PRIMARILY -- BUT ALSO
CATASTROPHIC FLOODS AND
MUDSLIDES.
A PROLONGED DROUGHTS EXTREME
HEAT AND MORE.
NO REPORT THAT WAS PRESENTED TO
NOT TO RESOURCES COMMITTEE LAST
WEEK SOME OF YOU WERE THERE.
THE LA -- ESTIMATE THE POTENTIAL
COSTS OF THESE IMPACTS IN THE
ORDER OF TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. TO THE STATE BY THE END
OF THE CENTURY IN A NOTED A ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY BILLION DOLLAR
RISK TO PRIVATE. TO PROPERTY
VALUE RESULTING FROM MODEST
SEALEVEL RISE ALONE.
DURING INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
THE NEW ABNORMAL I IN FIRE PRONE
REGIONS ROBERT FENTON THE REGION
NINE ADMINISTRATOR FOR FEMA.
SAID THAT FOR EVERY DOLLAR
INVESTED IN ACTIVITIES TO
PREVENT FIRES OR MITIGATE THEIR
SEVERITY WE CAN SAVE SIX DOLLARS.
IN RESPONSE TO THIS BILL THIS
BOND AS EXACTLY THAT BY SETTING
A COURSE TO REDUCE THE IMPACTS
OF RISING GLOBAL TEMPERATURES.
BY INVESTING IN NECESSARY
MEASURES TO PROTECT COMMUNITIES
IN OUR VITAL NATURAL RESOURCES
AND ENSURE THAT WERE ABLE TO
ADAPT TO A CHANGING CLIMATE
DEDICATES FUNDING TO PROJECTS.
THAT WILL REDUCE PIRACY YOUR
COMMUNITIES AND INSURE OUR
FORESTS ARE HEALTHY ENOUGH TO
WITHSTAND MORE INTENSE.
WILDFIRES REDUCE THE RISK OF
CATASTROPHIC FLOOD EVENTS BY
SLOWING RUNOFF.
IMPROVING BROWN WATER
INFILTRATION PROTECT COASTAL
COMMUNITIES FROM SEA LEVEL RISE
HELP URBAN COMMUNITIES ADOPTED
THE RISING TEMPERATURES.
I REDUCING HEAT ISLAND EFFECT
YOUR GREETING PROJECTS IN
CAPTURING STORM WATER. TO
STABILIZE DRINKING WATER
SUPPLIES IT'S OUR VERY STRONG
FEELING THAT WE MUST.
TAKE AGGRESSIVE PROACTIVE STEPS
TO ADDRESS THE IMPACT THAT WE
KNOW THAT ARE COMING THIS IS ONE
STEP IN THAT EFFORT AND I HAVE
WITH ME.
TODAY I LEAN TO ADD.
WHO IS THE EAST BAY REGIONAL
PARK?
DISTRICTS FIRE CHIEF.
I ALSO BELIEVE THAT I'M BUT WE
HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS WHO MAY BE
COMING AS WELL BUT I'D LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER WITH THE COMMISSION
TO THE FIRE CHIEF.
YEAH MORNING.
SO JUST A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
PARK DISTRICT WAS FOUNDED IN --
NINETEEN THIRTY FOUR IT'S THE
LARGEST LOCAL PARK AGENCY IN THE
NATION.
SERVES OVER TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION PEOPLE IN -- ALAMEDA
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND WE ENJOY
A TWENTY FIVE MILLION VISITORS A
YEAR [inaudible]
I'M.
THE EAST PARK DISTRICTS FIRE
DEPARTMENT WERE FIRST RESPONDERS
TO THE CATASTROPHIC NINETEEN
NINETY ONE OAKLAND HILLS FIRE.
I AM THE NINETY ONE FIRE WAS A
CALL TO FOCUSED ON RESILIENT
FIRE PROTECTION.
AS A MORAL MANDATE.
AT THE TIME IT TOOK A TWENTY SIX
LIVES IT BURNED OVER THREE
THOUSAND HOMES AND THAT'S ONLY
THREE THOUSAND HOMES COMPARED TO
THE FIRES THAT WE HAVE NOW.
I'M A COST ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS.
A TO RECOVER FROM AND THAT WAS
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS AGO.
SO IS A LAND MANAGEMENT AGENCY
THE PARK DISTRICT IS KEENLY
AWARE.
UNDERSTANDING OF THE NECESSARY
BALANCE BETWEEN STEWARDSHIP AND
FORCE MANAGEMENT.
THEY KIND OF CREATES A
RESILIENCY.
AND THE DISTRICT UNDERSTANDS A
LONG TERM COMMITMENT TO SAFE AND
HEALTHY FORESTS SO WE SPEND. ONE
MILLION APPROXIMATELY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN FORCE
MANAGEMENT.
AND THAT IS FAR FAR LESS THAN
THE ONE POINT FIVE BILLION IT
COST RECOVER FROM THE OAKLAND
HILLS FIRE.
IN A TWO THOUSAND FOUR WE WENT
TO THE VOTERS -- FOR THEM TO
APPROVE A TWENTY TEN WHILE FIRE
HAZARD REDUCTION RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT PLAN -- THAT IN IT'S
BEEN GIVEN ENVIRONMENTAL
CLEARANCE WE STARTED THAT.
TWENTY TEN IT TOOK EIGHT YEARS
TO GET THE ENVIRONMENT A
CLEARANCE TO DO THAT WORK.
THE CLOCK IS TICKING.
AND DEMAND WILL INCREASE M. AND
ACCELERATE AS THE CLIMB IT
CONTINUE TO CHANGE IN THE NEED
IS REALLY URGENT.
A BOND INFUSION OF THIS KIND
WOULD ACCELERATE THE WORK AND
LEVERAGE DIGITAL RESOURCES FROM
FEMA HELLFIRE.
I KNOW YES WE'RE REALLY AT THIS
POINT IN A RACE.
AGAINST A CATASTROPHIC FIRES AS
THEY RELEASE MORE AND MORE
CARBON.
INTO THE AIR EXACERBATING THE
PACE OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND INCREASING HEALTH IMPACTS --
TO OUR COMMUNITIES AS AN ANNUAL
BAD AIR QUALITY DAYS INCREASE
THE ANNUAL BAD AIR.
AIR QUALITY DAYS INCREASE AND AS
AN EXAMPLE OF THAT DURING THE
CAMPFIRE LAST YEAR.
AS THE TWO COUNTIES WHICH WE
SERVE ALONG WITH ALL THE THE
REST COUNTIES -- IN THE EAST BAY
EXPERIENCE THE WORST AIR ON THE
PLANET FOR THIRTEEN DAYS -- EVEN
WORSE THAN BEIJING.
AND THAT'S EXAMPLE OF THAT
CATASTROPHIC.
AND RELEASE OF CARBON INTO THE
AIR IS AS A RESULT OF THE
CAMPFIRE.
SO THIS BOND WE SEE AS A FIRST
RESPONDER TOOL -- TO AN URGENT
ACCELERATING READ THAT WILL
REQUIRE MANY TOOLS THE TOOLBOX.
BUT THE TIME FOR THAT TOOL IS
REALLY NOW.
pNEEDS -- REQUIRE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES RECALL.
COMMITMENT AND SENATOR ALLEN'S
BOND MEASURE REALLY STARTS A
CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU.
MORE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL I THINK THEY'RE ON THEIR
WAY BUT IT'S A SINCE OF COURSE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JOE CAVES ON
BEHALF OF THE MOUNTAINS
RECREATION CONSERVATION
AUTHORITY -- THIS LAST YEAR WE
HAD A MAJOR FIRE IN MALIBU IT
WIPED OUT ABOUT IT.
DAMAGE THE HABITAT IN ABOUT HALF
OF THE LANDS WE MANAGE.
THOSE LANDS ARE GOING TO REGROW.
GIVEN ALL THE RAIN WE'VE HAD
MOSTLY WITH INVASIVE SPECIES
THAT WILL POSE AN EVEN MORE
SIGNIFICANT FIRE HAZARD IN THE
FUTURE.
WE HAVE TO HAVE SOME SORT OF
RESOURCES SO THAT WE CAN GO
THROUGH ELIMINATE THOSE INVASIVE
SPECIES RESTORED THOSE AREAS
INTO A HABITAT FORM THAT IS LESS
COMBUSTIBLE.
AND TO PROTECT THE COMMUNITIES
AROUND THERE AS WELL OF THE
HABITAT AND NATURAL RESOURCE
VALUES WE URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THERE'S A SUPPORT [inaudible]
THE MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MATTHEW BAKER ANY
CONSERVATION LEAGUE IN SUPPORT.
A GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S THIS
MENACE OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS HAN ARAMBULA LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION -- WHICH
STATEWIDE NONPROFIT DEDICATED TO
BUILDING PRIVATE COMMUNITIES AND
A GREAT CIVIC ENGAGEMENT WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC PARTIES FOR OVER THIRTY
FIVE YEARS.
NUMBER SUPPORTIVE OF SB FORTY
FIVE POSSIBLE GOVERNMENTS WHO
ARE CRITICAL TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF COMPREHENSIVE
ADAPTATION WILDFIRE AND HAZARD
MITIGATION -- AND HAZARD
MITIGATION EFFORTS HE THIS WAS
OUR GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT AND WE
DO ONE OFFER THREE SUGGESTIONS
AND IT'S TO ENHANCE THE ****
THIS AND REACH -- WE SUGGEST
MORE DIRECTLY RESOURCE IN
CLIMATE COLLABORATIVE'S WHO ARE
ALREADY PLAYING A KEY
INTERMEDIARY ROLE BETWEEN
STAPLES AND LOCAL ACTIONS BUT
NEED ASSISTANCE BUILT TO BUILD
GREATER LONG TERM ADAPTIVE
CAPACITY.
WE RECOMMEND EXPANDING THE
WORKFORCE FUNDING TO INCLUDE
INNOVATIVE AND DIVERSE CLIMATE
WORKS FOR WORKFORCE PROGRAMS
THAT BECAUSE OF THE SEAS SIX OUR
COMMERICAL PROGRAM.
WHICH PROVIDES AN ON RAMP TO THE
INTO THE FIELD WHILE BUILDING
WILL ASK YOU TO ADDRESS CLIMATE.
RISKS AND FINALLY IN ORDER TO
MITIGATE RISK AND REDUCE
POTENTIAL DAMAGE WE RECOMMEND
GREATER EMPHASIS ON LAND USE AS
A COULD GLANCE USE WHEN
ADDRESSING LOVE PARENTS.
GOOD MORNING BRIAN MEDINA ON
BEHALF OF COMMUNITY NATURE
CONNECTION ON THE PENINSULA
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT --
LOS ANGELES NEIGHBORHOOD LAND
TRUSTS AND FRIENDS OF THE LA
RIVER IN SUPPORT OF THIS BEFORE
IF I THINK.
MORNING DANIEL LYNCH OFFERING
STRONG SUPPORTER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS.
ESCONDIDO CREEK CONSERVANCY LAND
TRUST OF SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
SEMPERVIRENS FUND AND SEE IF THE
RED LOOK WHAT SLEEP.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANALYST'S AMONG
THE WATER QUALITY SCIENTISTS BUT
HE'LL THE BAY IN SANTA MONICA
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BEFORE.
SO HE IS A LEASH ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
STRONG SUPPORTER AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE ALL STATE
INSURANCE COMPANY THANK YOU.
THERESA BURKE WHICH ON BEHALF
THE SEVENTH GENERATION ADVISORS
SURFRIDER AND THE OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE CLEAN SEIZE LOVING
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
NATALIE MAX ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HABITAT CONSERVATION
PLANNING COALITION WAS GONNA
GREEN ABOUT ENDANGERED HABITATS
LIKE IN OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
WEATHER ORDER WORKING GROUP.
BUSH CONSERVANCY IN CALIFORNIA
TROUT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MORNING JOHN BOTHWELL ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE KEEPER
ALLIANCE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
VVC LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ON BEHALF OF PORT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING.
WE REALLY BILL CLIMATE RESILIENT
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
JONATHAN NELSON WITH A COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER AND IN STRONG
SUPPORT LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON THE DRINKING WATER
LANGUAGE.
GOOD MORNING AYE JAY ZIEGLER
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN STRONG
SUPPORT IN LIGHT OF THE
TREMENDOUS CLIMATE LOCUST RISKS
BASED IN CALIFORNIA WE REALLY
NEED THE SORT OF INNOVATIVE
FINANCING MEASURE THANK YOU.
MASON PACIFIC FOREST TRUST ALSO
ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT WE
DEFINITELY NEED TO JUMP STARTER
ADAPTATION EFFORTS THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MERION WARMER DAM ON
BEHALF OF RURAL COUNTIES WE DO
NOT HAVE AN APPROVED POSITION
BUT I DID WANT EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO THE AUTHOR. FOR
THAT RESOURCES DIRECTED TOWARD
FORCED RESILIENCY THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
NO OPPOSITION THEN WILL TAKE
THAT.
BACK TO COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE YES GOING OUT
AND ENJOYING.
I SEE THAT YOU HAVE A FIFTY
MILLION. FOR ENHANCING WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT WITH THIS BE
INCLUSIVE OF THE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS ASKED OF THE NEXT FOUR YEARS
IN HIS BUDGET OR IS THIS IN
ADDITION. TO TO HAVING THESE TO
CLIMB IT.
FUNDED ACTIVITIES.
I PAY FOR OUR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT THE STATE.
IT'S IN ADDITION ISSHIN.
I'M IN CAN I GET A LITTLE BIT
IT'S HAVE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES SOME WATER OVERLAPS
WHETHER IT'S AGRICULTURE WATER
WATER.
WATER GIVE ME SOME IDEA OF YOUR
THINKING ON THE BREAKDOWN.
BUT YOU HAVE OF THE FOR BILLION
DOLLARS FOUR POINT THREE BILLION.
YEAH YOU KNOW I JUST.
KNOW WE'RE BROWN HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS -- FIGURE I KNOW I'M A
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IN.
IN THE LANDS OF ADAPTATION WHERE
ARE YOU SEEING THE FOCUS BECAUSE
THIS IS JUST A PAWN SO IT'S FOUR
BILLION AND IT'S DONE WE HAVE A
HUNDRED FIFTY BILLION TO SPEND
SO.
WHERE DO YOU THINK THE MOST NEED
IS OR THE GREATEST NEED IS GOOD
RECORD WITH THE DIVISION THAT WE
HAVE IN THESE NUMBERS?
YEAH.
I MEAN LOOK THE THE BIGGEST OF
THE BIGGEST FOCUS HERE IS ON
FIRES.
YEAH THAT'S THAT'S THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT BUT THERE'S NO
QUESTION THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION THAT HAS TO DO WITH
WATER THERE'S INTERPLAY WITH.
WITH FIRE TO SOME EXTENT THIS
BOND COMES OUT OF THE YOU KNOW
WHAT HAPPENED LAST YEAR WITH
PROP THREE RIGHT WHERE WAY
BECAME THIS KIND OF
ENTREPRENEURIAL -- CHRISTMAS
TREE OF OF OF OF PROPOSITION.
I THAT YOU KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE
FELT THE NEED TO SUPPORT JUST
BECAUSE IT GAVE MONEY TO VARIOUS
CONSERVANCY IS IN GOOD CAUSES.
RELATED TO WATER AND OTHER.
OTHER THINGS BUT BUT THE BUT THE
EDITORIAL BOARD SAID OVER AND
OVER AGAIN THAT IT WASN'T.
IT REALLY WASN'T A WELL CRAFTED --
BOND MEASURE AND SO THERE WAS A
SENSE THAT WE COULD DO A BETTER
JOB HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE
WORKING WITH EVERYBODY. TO CRAFT
SOMETHING THAT WOULD -- THAT
WOULD REALLY MAKE MORE SENSE AND
WORK WITH MORE COHERENCE.
HI BUT DID THAT THE TRUE THE
MATTER CENTER IS THAT THE YOU
KNOW IF THIS IS STILL VERY MUCH
A WORK IN PROGRESS AND AND DONE.
YEAH WE GOT LOTS OF DIFFERENT
KINDS OF PROJECTS IN THE WATER
SPACE THAT WE WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN HELPING. TO FIND
THROUGH THIS BUT THàNH BUT YOU
KNOW THE THE THE THE VARIOUS.
AMOUNT LEVELS ARE.
ARE SUBJECT TO NEGOTIATION AND
DISCUSSION.
AND I A HAS A LOT OF PEOPLE AT
THE TABLE AND YES AND NO I KNOW.
I KNOW YOU WHEN YOU PUT FOUR
MILLION I GUESS THAT IS THE
CHALLENGE THAT.
I SEE HERE IS TO HAVE THAT THE
HOLISTIC DISCUSSION OF IF WE
LOOK AT A WATERSHED.
YOU KNOW BY THE TIME IT GETS THE
EAST BAY PARKS THEY'VE GOT.
THEY'VE GOT THEIR THEIR BY ON
THE BOTTOM VERSUS THE TOP OF THE
WATERSHED AND HOW DO YOU HOW DO
YOU GO ABOUT IN AN ADAPTATION.
TEMPLATE OF DEALING WITH THESE
PROJECTS.
AND HOLISTIC DRIVE THERE'S A
REGIONAL PLANNING POT THAT THEY
CAN HELP.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
COHERENCE AND AND AND ENDED
DECENT LEVEL PRIORITIZATION
[inaudible]
YEAH.
YOU KNOW DOES IT DOES ULTIMATELY
GIVE A GOOD DEGREE OF DISCRETION --
TO YOU KNOW TO THE
ADMINISTRATION -- BUT TIME IN
AND INTO THOSE THOSE REGIONAL
PLANNING POTS.
THAT ALL IS SUBJECT.
TO YOU KNOW IF YOU IF YOU WANT
TO WEIGH IN AND KIND OF GIVE US
YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON ON ON THE ON
THE ON THE WAY.
TO HONE THE CRAFTING OF THAT
MECHANISM I I'M I'M VERY HAPPY.
TO YOU TALK ABOUT THAT AND
ENGAGE IN THAT QUESTION.
THAT SAID JUST YEAH I WANT TO
JUST GET NO IT'S ALL THE FUTURE
THE SECOND HEARING AND WE HAD WE
READ THROUGH THE REPORT THEY HAD
AT THE ON THE BONDS AND IS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
YOU WERE KICK STARTING AND I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE
KICK START AND WE WE SEND THE
RIGHT MESSAGE.
YEAH OKAY.
BUT DID LOVES ITALIAN TALK ABOUT
THAT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OFTEN YOUR ALLEN JUST A QUICK
COMMENT -- PRIDE LIKE THE
DIRECTION YOU'RE GOING IN
ACTUALLY I LIKE THE IDEA THAT
YOU HAVE CALLED OUT DIFFERENT
AREAS THAT WOULD BE HARD TO FOR
COMPREHENSIVE.
OF COMPREHENSIVE SPENDING OF
MONEY IN DIFFERENT AND IN OUR
RISK AREAS.
THAT ARE ANALYSIS BRINGS UP A
FEW POINTS AND WE CAN SHARE THAT
WITH YOU LATER RATHER THAN
TAKING TIME SO I'M GONNA LAY OFF
TODAY.
BUT THE FACT THAT IT'S WORK IN
PROGRESS AND WOULD BE PUT BEFORE
THE VOTERS AND TWENTY TWENTY
THAT'S RIGHT NOW A LOT OF WORK
BETWEEN NOW AND THEN SO WE WILL
ENGAGE.
I I TRULY BELIEVE IT FIGHT IN
CONCEPT IS REALLY IMPORTANT
MEASURE YEAH SO WITHOUT TIME
WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO KNOW APPRECIATE THOSE
COMMENTS A GREAT DEAL AND I
THINK I ALWAYS AT THE TENSION
HERE'S HOW DO YOU.
LAY OUT ENOUGH SPECIFICITY SO
THAT PEOPLE CAN FEEL CONFIDENT
THAT THE KINDS OF THINGS THEY
WANT TO SEE FUNDED ARE GONNA BE
FUNDED WHILE ALSO PROVIDING
ADEQUATE FLEXIBILITY TO MEET
YOUR OB SEE RIGHT THERE ARE.
SO MANY DIFFERENT WORTHY
PROJECTS AND THAT'S ALWAYS
ATTENTION IN IN IN IN BONDS LIKE
THIS.
HI BUT I I REMAIN VERY COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH -- WITH WITH ALL
OF THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
TO AYE AYES WE HUNG THIS INTO
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN BE PROUD
OF WELL CONSIDERING HOUSE BONDS
AND I'D.
THE LAG IN AND ACTUALLY
RELEASING FUN.
THIS ONE IS VERY URGENT RIGHT
EVEN THOUGH IT'S TWENTY TWENTY
BUT AFTER -- IT'S PASSED BY THE
VOTERS IF THAT HAPPENS I'D LIKE
TO SEE SOMETHING IN AND ENSURES
THAT THE MONEY IS GOING TO BE
KIND OF PRIORITIZE STUFF.
YEAH AS WE'VE SEEN THAT WITH THE
WATER BOND IN THE SCHOOL BOND
YET ALL OF THOSE HAVE BEEN
PROBLEMATIC PRESS REPUBLICANS
YEAH OF THE MANY FINE OUT THERE.
FOR ALL OF US.
SO.
GREAT.
WITHOUT SOME.
CULTURAL -- WE HAVE ANOTHER I'M
SORRY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE YOU
MOVE DEBT.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB.
FORTY FIVE THE MOTION IS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTS AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE.
ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE BATES.
NOT VOTING HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
STERN AYE STONE.
NO.
NO NO I CASKEY.
CASKEY AYE.
WHAT ARE?
THE ROLE.
WITH [inaudible]
WE JUST.
FIND CAR THANK YOU MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR COMING.
I NOTICED THAT -- CENTER NUMBER
STUCK IN WAS IN AND GOT TO HEAR
ALL ABOUT THE BOND.
I SO WANT WE ASK YOU TO COME TO
THE DíAS AND AND N. PRESENT
ITEM TEN YOUR PACKETS MEMBERS
THAT'S SB.
FOUR HUNDRED REALLY THE MOBILITY
OPTIONS AND WE'RE YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS OF HIS VERY SIMPLE
BILL [inaudible]
THE IN CARS FOR ALL.
PROGRAM PROVIDES THAT IF YOU
TURN A CLUNKER HIGH POLLUTING
VEHICLE.
THEN YOU CAN GET.
A VOUCHER OR CREDIT THE VOUCHER
CAN BE USED FOR PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION.
WHAT THIS BILL OR OUR CAR
SHARING?
SO WITH THIS BILL DOES IS IT
SIMPLY ALLOWS THAT VOUCHER TO BE
USED FOR EXAMPLE FOR THE BIKES
OR BIKE SHARING.
THE CONCEPT BEHIND THE PROGRAM
IS THE TAKE HIGH POLLUTING
VEHICLES OFF THE ROAD.
AND SUBSTITUTE OTHER MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION ORDER TO REDUCE
THE CARBON FOOTPRINT.
THE SIMPLY EXPANSIVE
[inaudible]
IT'S A I DON'T BELIEVE WE'RE
GONNA SAY SOME GOOD I DON'T WANT
TO KNOW IF YOU TESTING AND I'M
VERY SUPPORTIVE ALL RIGHT ALL
RIGHT -- WITH ME HERE IS THE
CALIFORNIA BICYCLE COALITION.
IN SUPPORT.
THE BICYCLE COALITION INCARNATE.
WE ARE JUST ONE OF US WANT ONE
OF THE THIRTY THOUSAND DUES
PAYING MEMBERS OF BICYCLING
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS AROUND
THE STATE I'M DAVE SNYDER I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL.
TO THAT SENATOR FOR INCLUDING.
THE BIKES AND BIKE SHARE AS A
MOBILITY OPTION HE BIKES.
BIKES HAVE ALWAYS BEEN A
MOBILITY OPTION FOR A LOT OF US
BUT HE BANKS CHANGE THE EQUATION
AND MAKE BICYCLING VIABLE FOR
ORDERS OF MAGNITUDE MORE PEOPLE.
YOU CAN IMAGINE A FLATTENED
HILLS -- IT ALLOWS YOU TO TAKE
CHILDREN TO SCHOOL UNLIKE A
REGULAR BIKE YOU CAN TAKE KIDS
ON A CARGO BIKE IT ALLOWS
ELDERLY FOLKS.
AND EVEN ALLOWS PEOPLE WITH
CERTAIN DISABILITIES I GOT A
CALL FROM SOMEONE WITH AN ****
WHO SAID SHE CAN'T WALK BUT YOU
CAN RIDE A BIKE.
BECAUSE OF THE BALANCE EQUATION
IS DIFFERENT SO IS HER HER.
LIFE IS TRANSFORMED.
THANKS TO THE HER EBAY.
AS A MATTER PUBLIC POLICYIT'S
APPROPRIATE WE KNOW THAT ABOUT A
THIRD TO A HALF OF THE BIKE
TRIPS ACCORDING [inaudible]
TO AMERICA REPLACED.
WE KNOW THOSE MILE THOSE TRIPS
ARE ABOUT NINE MILES LONG.
AND WE KNOW THAT OF ALL THE
MOBILITY OPTIONS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO YOU IN THIS PROGRAM
THIS IS THE ONLY ONE THAT THAT
GIVES YOU HEALTHCARE BENEFITS.
THE PEOPLE WHO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
IT ARE HEALTHIER SO.
WITH THAT WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
I LET'S OPEN UP TO ANY OTHER
FOLKS WANT TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
JOSH WAS STARK ON BEHALF
TRANSFORM IN SUPPORT THANK.
YOU.
MATTHEW BAKER PLANNING
CONSERVATION AGAIN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ANYONE WANT TO RAISE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL OPPOSITION ISSUES.
OKAY THAT IS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE -- CENTER STERN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
COMMEND YOU SAM NUMBER FOR
DIGGING IN ON THIS PROGRAM I
MEAN WE'VE BEEN.
WE TRY TO SOLVE.
BASS HE WAS A GIANT ENERGY TRACK
FOR THE MIDDLE CLASS IN THIS
STATE WHO ARE DRIVING NOT JUST
HIGH POLLUTING VEHICLES BUT
YOU'RE VERY EXPENSIVE VEHICLES
THEY OWN.
YEAH AND THEY CAN BREAK A FAMILY
BUDGET.
BUT THE MAINTENANCE COSTS THEN.
IT MAKES SOME OF OUR MIDDLE
POLICY ACTUALLY REAL THIS
PROGRAM WHERE AVERAGE FOLKS CAN
HOPEFULLY.
YEAH MOVE FROM LIKE YOU GOT A
NINETY SEVEN PONTIAC.
IF YOU GET AN ELEVEN MILES A
GALLON ON PAYING HAVE TO
FAMILIES BUDGET ON MAINTAINING
THE CART INTO SOME OTHER OPTIONS
TO LIVE YOUR LIFE.
MY MY THE PERFORMERS THE PROGRAM
IS NOT BEEN.
ACES IN MY VIEW I THINK WE COULD
DO A HECK OF A LOT MORE.
ESPECIALLY THE SOUTH COAST
REGION SAN JOAQUIN IS SORT OF
WHERE IT GOT ITS START BUT IT.
YOU KNOW WE STILL DON'T HAVE THE
THROUGH PUT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
I'M HOPING THIS MEASURE KINDA.
KEEP STIMULATING THAT BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW.
THIS WOULD ONLY APPLY TO THE
INCENTIVE PART OF THE F. M. P.
RIGHT IT'S IT'S NOT THE SCRAP IT
BECAUSE THERE'S A SCRAP AND
THERE'S A SCRAP AND REPLACE.
ASSEMBLY GOES TO THE VOUCHER THE
FOR MOBILITY OPTIONS IT DOESN'T
GO TO THE SCRAP AND REPLACE.
YOUR REFERRING WITH OR IT GOES
TO THE REPLACEMENT AT THE SCRAP
THOSE TO THE REPORT.
CORRECT.
BECAUSE I THINK YOU CAN DO TWO
THOUSAND FIRST STREET SCRAPPER
FIFTEEN ANNIVERSARY SCRAP WHICH
DOES GET THESE GHOST ALLUDING
VEHICLES OFF THE ROAD
[inaudible]
BUT THEN.
I THINK. 11% THE FLEETBECAUSE A
50% AT 25% OF POLLUTION OR
SOMETHING LIKE THIS THIS GOES
FLEET IS LIKE RIDING ALONG
QUIETLY ANYHOW.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE.
EXPANDING OPTIONS ANSWER TO
GETTING THROUGH COULD YOU GOALS
IN MIND FOR THEM OR FOR THE
BICYCLE COALITION TERMS LIKE
WHERE TO TARGET WHERE TO SORT OF
STIMULATE MORE USE OF THIS
PROGRAM I LOVED OF KEEP WAKING
UP TO IN YOUR MIND THAT WHERE
DOES THIS.
WHERE WILL THIS DRIVER WHAT
MARKETS ARE WE LOOKING AT HERE
TO KIND OF -- STOOD UP SO I'LL
I'LL ANSWER FIRST NATIONALLY
OVER THE EXPERT -- IT IS IT IN
AREAS WHERE THERE'S NOT.
ROBUST PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION.
THE VOUCHER FOR PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION DOESN'T.
MEET THE NEEDS OF LOW INCOME
FOLKS LIKE AN E. BIKE FOR BIKE
SHARING WOULD SO.
YOU'LL JUST PARKING BACK TO MY
OWN DISTRICT.
WHERE WE HAVE SOME OF LIMITED
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION THIS
EXPANDS?
IT DRAMATICALLY I HOPE EXPANDS
OPTIONS FOR LOW INCOME DISPENSE.
SO IN TERMS OF YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT TARGETING I THINK THAT
THAT.
IN ADDITION TO ITS ARE YOUR IS
NOT REALLY ANSWER BY PUBLIC
TRANSIT BUT NOT SUPER LONG
COMMUTE SIDE RIGHT LIKE RIGHT
SEMI -- BY YOU'RE NOT GONNA
COMMUTE FROM FOR EXAMPLE LOS
ANGELES TO SAN FRANCISCO.
ON A BIKE -- BUT YOU ARE GOING
TO YOU CAN AND AND FOLKS DO
COMMUTE YOU KNOW TEN MILES ON
THE BIKE HOUSE THE BIKE SHARE
PART WORK LIKE THAT'S THE OTHER
THING IS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IS
SO.
OKAY GET ANY BY HOW MUCH ANYBODY
COST ISSUE WHAT WE TALKING LIKE
A TWO HUNDRED TWO TO FOUR
THOUSAND OKAY SO TO THE BIKE
SHARING IS NOT.
AUTHORIZED OR WHATEVER WHEN I'M
RIGHT AROUND AND A JUMP BY.
SO WE DIDN'T HEAR YOU WOULD LIKE
HAVE AN ACCOUNT THAT YOU WOULD
SORT OF TAKE DOWN OVER TIME A
MOBILITY ACCOUNT OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT.
EXACTLY SO YOU DON'T MISS YOU
USE THAT VOUCHER YOU DON'T FEEL
LIKE A CREDIT ON YOUR JUMPER
LINE OR ANY OF THOSE ACCOUNTS
YES [inaudible]
OKAY COOL.
EXCITING.
HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT THE CARS.
TO RIDE SHARING.
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP I DON'T
EVEN THAT THAT IS PART OF THE
PRESIDING JUSTIN THAT'S PART OF
ALREADY PART IS NOT PART OF THE
BILL OF PART OF PROGRAM BUT LIKE
SO UBER AND LIFT AND ALL THAT
YOU CAN AREN'T.
I BELIEVE SO.
OKAY.
THANKS I'M OF THE BILL.
I'M REALLY SHE TO WORK ON THAT
SIR.
THANK YOU CENTER -- THAT OTHER
QUESTION SPOTS FROM ME.
OKAY SO THE ITEM HAS BEEN MOVED
AS CENTER IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE.
BUT WE ARE GINGIVAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH US
YEAH ABSOLUTELY.
ITEM MOVE BY SOME STERN.
AS EXCERPTED CORAL.
ITEM NUMBER TEN SP FOUR HUNDRED
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
SENATE.
SENATE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION.
ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE BATES
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I CAN LIVE MY CASKEY I OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THIRTY CENTER.
OKAY I I C. S. AT A COUPLE EURO --
IS HERE.
AND SHE ACTUALLY HAS TWO BILLS
ON OUR DOCKET TODAY THE FIRST
ONE SO PRESENT IS ITEM SIX IN
YOUR PACKETS MEMBERS THAT'S SB.
THREE SEVENTEEN RELATING TO
WASTE FACILITIES AND PROHIBIT
CHEMICALS.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB.
THREE SEVENTEEN WHICH WOULD BAN
THE SALE OF CERTAIN TOXIC
CHEMICALS USED IN RV WASTE WATER
TANKS WHICH CAN CAUSE
GROUNDWATER CONTAMINATION.
MANY RECREATIONAL VEHICLE OWNERS
USE CHEMICAL DEODORANTS TO
REDUCE THE ORDERS FROM THE BLACK
WATER IN GRAY ROCK WATER TANKS
IN THERE.
ARE VIS.
THESE DEODORANTS CONTAIN TOXIC
CHEMICALS LIKE FORMALDEHYDE
WHICH REDUCE ORDERS BY KILLING
THE BACTERIA THAT LIVE IN THE
TANKS AND PRODUCE THE ORDERS IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
WHEN ARE THE OWNERS TOOK UP
THEIR TANKS IN RV PARKS IN ORDER
TO DISCHARGE?
INTO A SEPTIC TANK THE DEPOSIT
THE CONTENTS OF THEIR TANKS
INCLUDING THESE TALK TOXIC
CHEMICALS.
ONCE IN THE PARK'S SEPTIC TANK
THESE CHEMICALS KILL THE
BACTERIA NEEDED TO TREAT THE
PARKS WASTE MOST OF THESE RV
PARKS REQUEST HAVE A SYSTEM.
THAT USES -- THE DECOMPOSITION
OF THE WASTE IN ORDER TO BE ABLE.
TO MAINTAIN THE SYSTEM.
THIS CAN CAUSE A SEPTIC TANKS TO
FAIL WHICH THEN REQUIRES THE RV
OWNERS TO SPEND THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN MAINTENANCE AND
REPAIRS.
MORE IMPORTANTLY THE FAIL SYSTEM
INCREASES THE RISK THAT
UNTREATED WASTE INCLUDING THE
TOXIC CHEMICALS.
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE FAILURE WILL
MAKE ITS WAKE WAY INTO THE
GROUNDWATER WHICH THREATENS THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF PARK
VISITORS THE OWNERS AND
NEIGHBORS NEIGHBORS IN THESE
MOSTLY RURAL COMMUNITIES.
IN AN EFFORT TO PROTECT THE
GROUND WATER ENCOURAGE THE USE
OF SAFE ALTERNATIVES SB THREE
SEVENTEEN BANS THE SALE AND USE
OF CERTAIN TOXIC CHEMICALS.
AS WELL AS REQUIRES THE RV'S TO
IN THE RV OWNERS TO INFORM THE
CUSTOMERS OF THE BAND THE BAND.
WITH THE SIGNAGE REQUIREMENTS.
THIS BILL REPRESENTS A SOLUTION
FORMED WITH INPUT FROM THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
THE REGIONAL WATER BOARD AN RV.
PARK PARK OWNERS TO PREVENT
GROUNDWATER CONTAMINATION WE HAD
AN INSTANCE.
RECENTLY WHERE THERE WAS FROM
ALDEHYDE APPEARED IN -- GROUND
WATER SYSTEM AND SO THIS REALLY
ELEVATED THE ISSUE.
OF CONCERN IN -- IN IN WHEN I'M
AND ONE OF THE RB IN MY DISTRICT.
BY RESTRICTING THE WITHIN THE
IMPORTANT THING ABOUT THIS IS
THAT THE THE MAKERS OF THE
FORMALDEHYDE IN THESE CHEMICALS
ALSO HAS A NON.
TOXIC ALL THAT THEY SELL -- AND
SO IT IT'S VERY EASY TO SHIFT
OVER TO SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY
WILL NOT CONTAMINATE THE
GROUNDWATER AMONG -- BECAUSE THE
THE SYSTEM TO FAIL.
BY RESTRICTING THESE PROJECTS
NOT ONLY IS GROUNDWATER
PROTECTED BUT THE WORRY AND
BURDEN OF SMALL OWNERS.
AS WELL AS THE SURROUNDING
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES RELIEF.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
YOU CENTER YES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS JASON OCCURRED WITH
METAL STING GILBERT ROPES AND
SPENT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF RV
PARKS AND CAMPGROUNDS.
BRIEFLY WHERE PRIVATELY OWNED RV
PARKS AND CAMPGROUNDS ACROSS THE
STATE WE REALLY APPRECIATE
SENATOR CAFIERO BEING WILLING TO
AUTHOR SB THREE SEVENTEEN AND
REALLY IT'S A SHE SAID THE
COMBINATION OF TWO AND A HALF
YEARS OF GOOD WORK ON HER PART.
TO RESOLVE A DECADES LONG ISSUE
THAT'S BEEN PLAGUING THE RV PARK
AND CAMPGROUND INDUSTRY.
I'M GONNA TRY TO BE REALLY BRIEF
BECAUSE THE SENATOR WAS QUITE
ARTICULATE AND THE STAFF
ANALYSIS IS EXCELLENTLY WRITTEN
AND OBVIOUSLY RECOMMEND A
SUPPORT POSITION ON THE BILL --
RIGHT NOW TODAY A AND R. V.
OWNER NOT AN RV PARK OWNER AND
ARMY OWNER CAN PURCHASE
CHEMICALS THAT AS THE SENATOR
SAID ARE TOXIC CARCINOGENS.
AND USE THEM AND THEY END UP AND
MY CLIENTS PARK MEMBERS.
SEPTIC SYSTEMS WHEN THAT HAPPENS
NOT ONLY ARE THE AT RISK OF
GROUNDWATER CONTAMINATION IS A
SENATOR SAID BUT THEY ARE
ULTIMATELY RESPONSIBLE FOR
MANAGING THE END OF LIFE OF
THESE PRODUCTS.
IT JUST DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THE
MOST EFFICIENT AND COST
EFFECTIVE WAY OF ADDRESSING THE
PROBLEM ESPECIALLY AS THE
SENATOR SAID.
SINCE THERE ARE MANY GREEN
ALTERNATIVES SO WITH THAT I WILL
I WILL CONCLUDE IN JUST
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE OUT
AND VERY HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT -- QUESTIONS ARE
WELL AS ART BOOKS ONE IN
[inaudible]
VOICE SUPPORT.
MELISSA ONE OR THE CALIFORNIA
TRAVEL ASSOCIATION APOLOGIES
WOULDN'T GET A LETTER IN TIME
BUT WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OTHER -- VOICE SUPPORT OF
OPPOSITION AND CONCERNS ANYONE
MAKE MY COMMENTS.
OKAY GUIDANCE BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE ETCETERA CASKEY.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THE ANALYSIS
THAT TALKS ABOUT BECAUSE I'VE
BEEN RATHER PROTECTIVE OF THE
GREEN CHEMISTRY PROGRAM FOR SAFE
CONSUMER ITEMS AND ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT THAT IT'S WELL IT'S
READILY AVAILABLE IT'S NOT THE
TYPE OF PRODUCT THAT.
CONSUMERS WILL READILY HAVE IN
CONTACT WITH THEM AND THEREFORE
IT SEEMS APPROPRIATE TO TO LOOK
DIRECTLY TO THE LEGISLATURE.
THE BAND THAT YOU AGREE WITH
THAT ANALYSIS THAT THEY MATCH I
DO I'VE BEEN VERY.
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GREEN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL.
I I DON'T THINK IT MAKES ANY
SENSE FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO BE
DOING BANDS WHEN WE HAVE AN
ORGANISATION INSTITUTION FRANKLY
I SUPPORTED IT WHEN -- WHEN IT
WAS CREATED?
BUT THIS IS A UNIQUE SITUATION
SO I DO AGREE WITH THAT ANALYSIS
THANK YOU.
YEAH I KNOW HAS BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER STERN.
I IF YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU SO MUCH OKAY SO
SIGNIFICANT.
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB THREE ONE
SEVEN THE MOTION IS DO YOU
PASSED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE BATES.
BATES AYE HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER.
STERN STERN AYE STONE STONE I
WAKE HOUSE.
SB I OKAY SO WE'LL LEAVE THAT
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS AND ON
BUT I DO APPRECIATE THAT AND
THANK YOU JASON -- THE SNOW TURN
YOUR NEXT BILL.
SENATE CAREER THAT'S AS BEFORE
FOURTEEN AS ITEM TWELVE IN YOUR
POCKETS MEMBERS.
SMALL SYSTEM WATER THREE ACTIVE
[inaudible]
TWENTY NINETEEN WHEN READY
FUTURE ON PLEASED TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL FOUR FOURTEEN THE
SMALL SYSTEMS WATER THIRTY
ACTIVE.
TWENTY NINETEEN THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD HAS
IDENTIFIED NEARLY THREE HUNDRED
COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEM STATEWIDE
THE CHRONICALLY FAILED TO SERVE
SAFE DRINKING WATER.
THE SYSTEMS ARE IDENTIFIED BY
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION ON THE WATER
BOARD HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER
WEBSITE.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE SYSTEMS
ARE SMALL REVERSE RURAL SYSTEMS
SERVING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES TOO MANY OF WHICH
ARE IN MY DISTRICT.
TYPICALLY THE SYSTEMS LIKE THE
FINANCIAL MANAGERIAL AND
TECHNICAL RESOURCES NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS THE ONGOING
CONTAMINATION AND INFRASTRUCTURE
ISSUES NECESSARY TO OPERATE A
HIGH FUNCTIONING WATER SYSTEM.
THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT THIS IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AND A
SUSTAINABLE SOLUTION IS LONG
OVERDUE. ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS TURN ON THE TAP AND
CANNOT DRINK THE WATER.
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED MANY
LAWS TO ADDRESS SOME ELEMENTS OF
THE WATER ACCESSIBILITY ISSUE
INCLUDING CAPITAL FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CONSOLIDATION
WHEN AN ANCHOR TENANT AGENCY IS
NEARBY.
WE MOVED IN THE DIVISION OF
DRINKING WATER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
THE WATER BOARD TO SPEED UP THE
STATE'S RESPONSE TO FAILING
STATE REGULATED SYSTEMS.
ALLOWING FOR RESTRUCTURING OF
THE UNDERLYING GOVERNANCE OF
FEELING COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS
WILL CREATE AN ALTERNATIVE
PATHWAY WHEN NEARBY ANCHOR
AGENCIES ARE NOT SUITABLE FOR
CONSOLIDATION.
AND WE'RE ECONOMIC SCALE IS
REQUIRED FOR A SUSTAINABLE
SYSTEM.
SB FOR FOURTEEN PROPOSES TO
ADDRESS MANY OF THE SYSTEMS
AGAIN A FIGHT BY THE WATER BOARD
BY MERGING SMALL NOT COMPLIANT
WATER SYSTEMS INTO A LARGER MORE
ROBUST PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM THAT
CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
IMPROVED ECONOMIES OF SCALE.
ACCESS TO STATE BACK CAPITAL FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ENHANCED FINANCIAL
CAPACITY AND STREAMLINE
MANAGERIAL FUNCTIONS INCLUDING A
LOCALLY ELECTED BOARD OF
DIRECTORS.
AS A NEW AGENT NEW PUBLIC AGENCY
MISS IT HERE TO MANDATED
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
LOS CREATING EFFICIENCIES AND
COST EFFECTIVE REPRESENTATION.
SB FOUR FOURTEEN WOULD
COMPLEMENT EXISTING WATER BOARD
CONSOLIDATION POWER INCLUDING
THOSE PREVIOUSLY IMPLEMENTED.
IT IS A NEW TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX
AND IT'S NOT.
EXPECTED TO WORK IN EVERY SINGLE
INSTANCE.
THE AMENDMENTS I AM TAKING WOULD
IN FACT ACCELERATE FUTURE
CONSOLIDATIONS AS IT WOULD
REQUIRE THE STATE BOARD TO
INITIATE ACTION WITHIN THIRTY
DAYS AFTER FAILING SYSTEM PLAN
IS REJECTED -- NO PLAN IS FILE.
THIS MEANS THAT AS BEFORE
FOURTEEN WILL FACILITATE THE
NOBLE EFFORT TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH.
I REGULATING SAFE DRINKING WATER
BY GIVING REAL TEETH TO THE
WATER BOARD EFFORT TO CLEAR OUT
THESE UNDER PERFORMING WATER
SYSTEMS.
LAST YEAR MY ASSEMBLY BILL.
AT TWENTY FIFTY PASSES COMMITTEE
AND SENSE THEN WE WORKED WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS SUCH AS A WATER
BOARD ENVIRONMENTAL JUST GROUP
AND LAUGH.
THE BILL EVEN STRONGER.
SENATE BILL FOUR FOURTEEN
PROVIDES A CRUCIAL PATH TO
PROVIDE A BASIC HUMAN RIGHT TO
CLEAN AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE
DRINKING WATER.
WITH ME TODAY TO PRY TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT.
OUR DANIEL CO TO THE EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
DANIELLE PLUS SET FROM THIS
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU CHAIR ALLEN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF SB FOUR
FOURTEEN TODAY I'M DANIEL CODE
EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT.
AN AGENCY THAT PROVIDES WATER
WASTEWATER AND RECYCLED WATER TO
EIGHT HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND RIGHT RESIDENT IN
WESTERN RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
AS AN ORGANIZATION EASTERN
MUNICIPAL HAS DIRECT EXPERIENCE
WITH CONSOLIDATING RIPARIAN
SYSTEMS WITH FAILING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND SEVERE CONTAMINATION ISSUES
WITH AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY.
AND EXAMINING THE UNDERLYING
ISSUES THAT OFTEN RESULT IN
SYSTEM FAILURE WE FOUND THAT 81%
OF THE CHRONICALLY NONCOMPLIANT
SYSTEMS IDENTIFIED BY THE STATE
BOARD.
SERVE UNDER FOUR HUNDRED SERVICE
CONNECTIONS THESE ULTRA SMALL
SYSTEMS STRUGGLE THE FINANCIAL
ABILITY AND RATE BASE TO COVER
NORMAL OPERATIONS AND BASS
OVERHEAD EXPENSES.
SO THEN WHEN WATER QUALITY
ISSUES OCCUR OR INFRASTRUCTURE
FAILS SPREADING ANY EXTRA COST
LESS THAN FOUR HUNDRED SERVICE
CONNECTIONS IS SIMPLY NOT LIABLE.
WELL THE STATE BOARD HOUSE OF
POWER TO CONSOLIDATE SYSTEMS
THERE ALREADY IS CONSTRAINED
WHEN THERE IS NO.
VIABLE RECEIVING AGENCY SB FOR
FOURTEEN ADDRESSES THIS BY
ALLOWING HONESTLY
UNDERPERFORMING SYSTEMS TO BE
MERGED.
A STEP BY STEP PROCESS THAT
INCLUDES THE LINE TIMELINE INTO
A MORE ROBUST AND FINANCIALLY
VIABLE SYSTEM.
THE PROCESS USE IT UTILIZES
QUALIFIED APPOINTED
ADMINISTRATORS TO FORM A MORE
CONFIDENT SUCCESSOR WATER AGENCY --
A LOCALLY MANDATED LASKO PUBLIC
PROCESS LASKO WILL CONDITION
EACH SYSTEM TO IMPLEMENT
PRESCRIBED OPERATING AND CAPITAL
PLANS.
THAT WILL RESULT IN WATER
QUALITY COMPLIANCE.
AND SUSTAINABLE OPERATIONS AND
EACH SYSTEM WILL BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
TOWARDS IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE
PLANS AS THEIR REGULAR MANDATED
REPORTING.
IS OUTLINED AND TO TO PROGRESS
TOWARDS WATER QUALITY STANDARDS
IN THE BILL.
IN SUMMARY AS BEFORE FOURTEEN
PROVIDES A TOOL TO THE STATE
BOARD THAT WE BELIEVE ADDRESSES
BOTH.
IN YOUR TOURING NEAR TERM NEED
FOR INTERVENTION.
AND THE LONG TERM OBJECTIVE OF
COMPREHENSIVE REFORM.
AND WE BELIEVE THIS BILL IS A
VITAL TOOL TO ADDRESS THE SAFE
DRINKING WATER CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA AND FOR THESE REASONS
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS DANIEL WITH
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION WE ARE PROUD TO
BECAUSE SPONSORS AND SUPPORTERS
OF SB FOUR FOURTEEN BECAUSE WE
AND OUR MEMBERS BELIEVE THAT
EVERY CALIFORNIANS SHOULD HAVE
SAFE AND RELIABLE DRINKING WATER.
I'M SB FOUR FOURTEEN SIX TO
BRIDGE AN IMPORTANT GAP IN THE
STATE'S CONSOLIDATION AUTHORITY
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW I'M.
THE STATE MUST RELY ON A
RECEIVING AGENCY TO MERGE WITH
THE SYSTEM THAT IS CONSISTENTLY
FAILING TO PROVIDE SAFE DRINKING
WATER.
THE PROCESS IS NOTED BY SENATOR
CAFIERO IN SB FOUR FOURTEEN WHAT
INSTEAD ALLOW THESE CHRONICALLY
NON COMPLIANT WATER SYSTEMS TO
MERGE AS ONE FUNCTIONAL MORE
ROBUST SYSTEM.
IT SETS UP A UNIQUE
CONSOLIDATION PROCESS THAT WHILE
COMPLIMENTARY DOES NOT MERE OR
IMPORTANTLY SUPERSEDE EXISTING
AUTHORITIES PARTICULARLY WITH
THE AMENDMENTS THAT THE AUTHORS
TAKING TODAY.
IF THE STATE BOARD FINDS THAT
THE CREATION OF A SMALL SYSTEM
WATER AUTHORITY IS THE MOST
APPROPRIATE SOLUTION THE
SUBSEQUENT PROCESSES LOCALLY
CONTROLLED AND TRANSPARENT.
WHICH IS ESSENTIAL THE LONG
LASTING GOOD GOVERNMENT.
WE BELIEVE OUR GOVERNANCE WE
BELIEVE THE CUSTOMERS CAN AND
SHOULD FULLY PARTICIPATE IN
DECISIONS RELATED TO THE
DELIVERY OF SAFE DRINKING WATER
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND THE BILL HAS BEEN DRAFTED TO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
THESE FUNDAMENTAL STEPS.
AS NOTED BY OUR CO SPONSOR IN
THE AUTHOR THIS IS A TOOL IN THE
TOOLBOX TO EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS
SYSTEMS THAT CANNOT BE
CONSOLIDATED THROUGH OTHER MEANS.
EVEN WITH THE RECENT EFFORTS BY
THE STATE WATER BOARD ON
MANDATORY INVOLUNTARY
CONSOLIDATIONS USING EXISTING
AUTHORITIES.
THEY'RE STILL OVER TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY SYSTEMS THE WITHOUT THAT --
SERVE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WITHOUT ACCESS TO SAFE
DRINKING WATER AND I REALLY WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT SB.
FOUR EIGHTEEN WILL NOT DELAY
EXISTING CONSOLIDATIONS AND IS
NOT MEANT TO REPLACE OTHER
AUTHORITIES BUT RATHER
COMPLIMENT THEM AND ALLOW THE
WATER BOARD SELECT THE OPTION
THAT IS MOST APPROPRIATE FOR THE
SITUATION.
THE TIME IS NOW TO ADDRESS THESE
CHALLENGES FACING OUR STATE SB
FOUR FOURTEEN PROVIDES A
SUSTAINABLE PATH FORWARD TO
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL AND WISH.
WE ASK DR.
THANK YOU MUCH AND AND NOW AND
YOUR CAN'T TAKE IT FROM YOUR
SPARKLY PINK SASH THAT IT'S YOUR
BIRTHDAY TODAY HE'S JUST LAYING
ON MY BIRTHDAY.
IT IS YES AND I WAS GIVEN THIS
FROM A LOVELY YOUNG LADY WHO'S
SITTING IN THE BACK OF THE ROOM
THE DAUGHTER OF I'VE MISSED
CODES AND SO I FELT COMPELLED TO
WHERE IT IS OKAY NO IT'S IT'S
FANTASTIC.
HAPPY HAPPY BIRTHDAY THANK YOU --
TO YOU GUYS OKAY ALL RIGHT SO --
OKAY YOU WANNA WAIT IN IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MERCED MANNING
WE KP PUBLIC FAIRS ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN.
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT WERE TO
THE WEST OF THE EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
MAKES SENSE WOULD BE REALLY
AWFUL WAS THE OTHER WAY AROUND.
SARS LEVERS ON BEHALF OF THE
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT OF
ORANGE COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MARIAN WARMER DOWN WITH
REPRESENTING RURAL COUNTIES WE
BELIEVE THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX AND IS ONE
OF THE SOLUTIONS TO MEETING OUR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
WATER NEEDS TO KILLIAN RURAL
COUNTIES THANK YOU.
I'LL BE ON A B. HAVE A MESA
WATER AND SANTA CLARA CLARITA
VALLEY WATER AGENCY WE SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HAPPY VIçT TELAH WITH
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JASON
OCCURRED WITH THAT'LL STEAM
GILBERT ROBESON SMITH ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHRIS ANDERSON ON
BEHALF ASSOCIATION A CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES WE HAVE A
POSITION OF SUPPORT AND A MAN
AND I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
IN THE SPONSORS FOR CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH US. TO ADDRESS THIS
ONE MATTER THANK YOU.
MORNING MR CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BALKANS OFFICE HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY WATER DISTRICT AND
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERSE ADAM ROBIN WITH THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MORNING ROUNDS ROSSI WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MELANIE CUEVAS
WITHIN TUNNEL LOTS OF HEART AND
ON BEHALF OF IRVINE RANCH WATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT FOR THE
REASONS OUTLINED BY OFF ONCE
AGAIN YOU I THINK.
GOOD MORNING BATTLE ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE SANTA ANA
WATERSHED PROJECT THIRTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
NO ONE MEDIC ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF RESTAURANTS PART.
THANK YOU OKAY I ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE BILL UP POSITION
.
I ARE NEWMAN FROM THE ROAD
COMMITTEE ASSISTANCE CORPORATION
I'M AND I JUST WANT TO START BY
SAYING WE APPRECIATE IT SENATORS
ATTENTION THE ISSUE.
WE WORK WITH A LOT OF THOSE
CHRONICALLY NON COMPLIANT WATER
SYSTEMS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WERE A TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDER.
IN ELEVEN WESTERN STATES --
HEADQUARTERED HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
YOU KNOW IN RECENT YEARS WE
WORKED ON A LOT OF
REGIONALIZATION WE CALL IT
REGION'S ATION NOT CONSOLIDATION
BECAUSE INSULATION HAS SORT OF
THAT.
REPUTATION AND RURAL COMMUNITIES
IS NOT ALWAYS IDEAL.
WE WORKED A LOT OF
REGIONALIZATION PRODUCTS OUT THE
STATE IN LAKE COUNTY CONTRA
COSTA.
PLASTER TULARE RIVERSIDE -- AND
OTHERS AND YEAH WE ABSOLUTELY
SUPPORT THE IDEA OF BEING.
AND PARTNERSHIPS ARE CONCERNED
WITH THE BILL IS THAT IT.
IT'S STILL FEEL SIZES TOO HEAVY
HANDED IN A TOP DOWN ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH WE APPRECIATE
THE THE MOST RECENT ROUND OF
AMENDMENTS -- UNFORTUNATELY WE
STILL CAN'T SUPPORT BECAUSE OUR
EXPERIENCE HAS SHOWN US THAT
EVERY SINGLE PROJECT IS
DIFFERENT AND THEIR UNIQUE NEEDS
WHETHER YOU'RE IN THE DESERT ON
THE COAST -- IN THIS YEAR AS
EVER ANY PLACE IN THE STATE HAS
UNIQUE NEEDS.
AND AND AND WE FAVOR AN APPROACH
THAT SUPPORTS RIDGE'S NATION BUT
PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY AND
INCENTIVES FOR THE SO THAT THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE LOCAL
LEVEL CAN TAILOR THE RESPONSES
TO THE LOCAL MEATS AND FOR THAT
REASON.
WE WERE WE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
TV SEEN LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND I
I DO WANNA -- APOLOGIZE THAT WE
WEREN'T ABLE TO GET A LETTER AND
I DID JUST THAT THE TIMING OF
THE THE COMMITTEES AND AND WE
WEREN'T AWARE THERE'S GONNA BE
HEARD TODAY AND APOLOGIES -- ON
THAT -- WE ARE I THINK AGAIN
SIMILARLY EXTRAORDINARILY
GRATEFUL TO THE SENATOR. FOR FOR
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE A SAFE
DRINKING WATER I'M AND
GOVERNANCE WERE I THINK I SEE
THAT THE AMENDMENT -- AT HAVE
MOVED US CLOSER -- TO A PLACE
THAT MAKES SENSE IN TERMS OF
LOOKING AT DIFFERENT OPTIONS
EQUALLY STILL FEEL LIKE THERE'S
A LOT OF PROCESS AND COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL.
THAT WE CAN HOPE THAT WE CAN
WORK THROUGH TOO AGAIN MINIMIZE
THE COST MINIMIZE THE DAMAGE TO
DELAY AND MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
GETTING THE BEST SOLUTION TO THE
MOST CALIFORNIANS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU.
YES SIR.
JONATHAN NELSON WITH A COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER I'M ONE ADELINE MY
COMMENTS WITH -- ABC COMMENTS WE
ARE VERY GRATEFUL TO THE SENATOR
I'M AND TO THE LEGISLATURE THIS
YEAR FOR THE ATTENTION BEING
PAID TO SAFE DRINKING WATER.
I'M IT'S IT WAS ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITY THAT
ORIGINALLY PUSHED FOR THE
ORIGINAL CONSOLIDATION
AUTHORITIES.
ALONG WITH THE STATE WATER BOARD
OVER THE OPPOSITION OF THE WATER
AGENCY COMMUNITY SO I THINK
WE'RE ALSO JUST A PREACHER OF
HOW.
FAR THE CONVERSATION HAS SHIFTED
THAT'S A GOOD THING.
BUT WE DO HAVE CONCERNS THAT
THIS IS JUST A LITTLE MORE
CUMBERSOME -- THEN IT COULD BE
AND SHOULD BE ABOUT WHAT WE
THINK WE CAN GET IT RIGHT BY THE
END WE WANT TO KEEP WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR TO DO THAT AGAIN
APPRECIATE.
THE CENTERS ATTENTION TO THIS
ISSUE THANK YOU.
AND I'M ANDREA OF INTER WITH
CLEAN WATER ACTION WE ARE ALSO
IN IN A POSE UNLESS AMENDED
UPPER -- POSITION AT THIS POINT
WE DO THANK THE SENATOR -- AS
HAVE OTHERS -- FOR THIS ISSUE WE
THINK THE CONCEPT OF
CONSOLIDATION IS IMPORTANT BUT
AS WRITTEN RIGHT NOW THE BILL
STILL IS A LITTLE TOO CUMBERSOME
AS YOU HEARD AND TOO EXPENSIVE
TO BE A PRACTICAL SOLUTION. TO
DO THINK IT DOES NEED FOR WORK
AS IT MOVES SO IT THANK YOU CAN
I JUST ASK YOU WHAT WHEN YOU SAY
CUMBERSOME WHAT WHAT CAN YOU
GIVE ME SOME SPECIFIC CONCERNS.
SURE ENOUGH THERE'S A THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT O I MEAN
THERE'S INITIALLY THERE'S
CERTAIN FINDINGS.
THAT THE STATE BOARD WILL HAVE
TO TO MAKE PRIOR TO MOVING
FORWARD WITH A SOLUTION.
THAT -- CURRENTLY CAN AREN'T IN
PLACE SO THAT WERE A BIT
CONCERNED.
THAT THERE'S GONNA BE SOME
PROCESS AHEAD OF SORT OF MOVING
FORWARD ANY SUCH.
KIND OF ANY OF THAT KIND OF
IDENTIFIED AREAS IDENTIFIED
SOLUTIONS AND WANT TO TRY TO
EXPEDITE THAT PROCESS -- THE
OTHER ANOTHER ISSUE IS THAT
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
AND WAS TAKEN GOING BACK AND
FORTH WHERE THERE'S A PROPOSED
PLANNING GOES TO LAUGH GO IT AND
CAN COME.
BACK TO THE ADMINISTRATOR GOES
BACK TO LEFT GO THAT GOES TO THE
BOARD THERE'S A AND IT THEY CAN
TAKE SEVERAL YEARS THERE'S AN
APPEALS PROCESS.
ALL THIS CAN TAKE SEVERAL YEARS
AND IN THE MEANTIME THE
COMMUNITIES AT ISSUE DON'T HAVE
SAFE DRINKING WATER -- AT THE AT
THE END OF THE AT THE END OF THE
PROCESS THAT YOU CAN GO BACK AND
FORTH THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
AND STILL THAT CAN ADMINISTRATOR
CAN DECIDE THIS ISN'T
NECESSARILY FEASIBLE OR IN IN
INCOME WE'RE BACK TO SQUARE.
ONE SO I THINK WE JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE REDUCING AS
MUCH OF THAT BACK AND FORTH AS
POSSIBLE.
MAKING SURE THAT THE STATE BOARD
HAS THE AUTHORITY TO IDENTIFY
CAM AT THE OUTSET WHAT THE BEST
STRATEGY IS. TO CAN KIND OF MOVE
FORWARD EXPEDITIOUSLY TOWARDS
THAT END.
TOTALLY GET THE YOU DON'T THINK
IT.
THIS FAST ENOUGH BUT I BUT
SURELY.
INTO AN CORRECT IF I'M WRONG BUT
BUT THIS IS BE BETTER THAN WHAT
CURRENTLY EXISTS.
THANK YOU KNOW AND I WOULD.
WOULDN'T MIND CAN KICKING THINGS
OVER.
TO MY COLLEAGUE ARI AYE AYE THAT
WE ACTUALLY.
THINK THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
TOOLS CURRENTLY THERE'S A GOOD
SB A CONSOLIDATION LAST YEAR AB --
TWENTY FIVE ON GOING TO EXPAND
AND IMPROVED UPON THAT THERE ARE --
SEVERAL EXAMPLES OF MANAGERIAL
CONSOLIDATION ONE OF THE
COMMUNITIES AREN'T -- CONTINUOUS
AND WHAT I THINK THIS THIS BILL
SEEKS TO PROVIDE IS ANOTHER TOOL
ALSO COMPLEMENTING THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATOR THOR EDDIE.
I THINK TO BE TO BE HONEST I
THINK WE WANT TO REALLY MAKE
SURE THAT WE UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
SPECIFIC GAP.
THIS IS FILLING IS AND HOW IT
FITS INTO THE FRAMEWORK.
RATHER THAN -- RATHER THAN RE
CREATING THE FRAMEWORK.
DO YOU KNOW THE OPPOSITION
LETTER AND CENTER SAYS.
SEEMS TO THINK THAT THIS BILL.
ASSUMES THAT.
D. WE ARE RESULT FOR IS ALWAYS
THE BEST WAY TO ADDRESS PROBLEMS
AND I I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT'S
THAT'S NOT MY READING OF THE
BILL BUT YOU.
DO YOU WANT TO ADDRESS THAT
CONCERN.
THAT THEY RAISE THE STATE YOUR
BILL YOU'RE BASICALLY JUST.
IT'S ALL THAT AT ALL COSTS.
NO MATTER WHAT.
WELL I I THINK WHAT'S WHAT'S --
WAS FALLACIOUS ABOUT THE
ARGUMENT IS THAT THIS IS THIS IS
AN OPTION IT'S A TOOL.
THE STATE WATER BOARD CAN DECIDE
IF THIS IS NOT THE BEST TOOL IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO GET
COMPLIANCE THESE WATER SYSTEMS
HAVE BEEN LIKE THIS FOREVER.
AND WE PASSED RULES ABOUT HOW
YOU CAN CONSOLIDATE.
AND IT HASN'T HELPED THEM I I
WAS GOING TO BRING THE WATER
BOTTLE SO YOU COULD SEE WHAT'S
COMING OUT OF THE TAP BECAUSE
IT'S URGENT.
AND WHAT'S WHAT'S [inaudible]
WHAT?
KIND OF BLOWS MY MIND ABOUT ALL
OF THIS IS THAT.
IS THAT ANY TIME YOU HAVE TO GO
THROUGH A LAUGH CO PROCESS.
IT'S IT'S BURDENSOME BECAUSE
WE'VE WE'VE VESTED IN LASKO THE
AUTHORITY TO TO DO THINGS THAT
NO OTHER.
YEAH ON A REGIONAL BASIS THAT NO
OTHER GOVERNMENT CAN DO SO THEY
HAVE TO BE CAREFUL TO HAVE TO BE
PUBLIC HEARINGS HAVE TO BE
NOTICED.
PEOPLE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE COMMENTS ON WHAT THEY'RE
GONNA DO THAT PROCESS IS
CUMBERSOME AND I WISH WE COULD
JUST DO AWAY WITH IT MAYBE IT'S
A IT'S JUST A TOOL TO SEE IF WE
CAN GET OURSELVES THERE IN PART
OF THE PROBLEM IS IN MANY OF
THESE.
COMMUNITIES THEY'RE ISOLATED
THEY'RE NOT NEXT TO A BIG SYSTEM
AND SO THERE'S NOT A BIG SYSTEM
YOU CAN POINT TO TO SAY WE NEED
FOR YOU TO COME IN AND AND HELP
MAKE THIS.
WATER SYSTEM COMPLIANCE IF
THEY'RE SO WHAT THAT THE CONCEPT
IS IT IS THAT YOU GET A NUMBER
OF NON COMPLIANT SYSTEMS AND TRY
TO BUILD THE OPPORTUNITY TO FIX
THEM UP AND UP AND MAKE IT WORK.
FOR ALL OF THEM RATHER THAN JUST
WAITING AROUND TO FIND A SYSTEM
THAT.
THAT THAT THAT WANTS TO ADOPT A
MINUTE IT THIS WAY.
AT THIS RATE WE WON'T WE WON'T
GET CLEAN WATER FOR PEOPLE FOR
MANY MANY YEARS AND SO THERE'S
THERE'S NOT AND THERE'S NOT AN
ATTEMPT. TO TAKE AWAY THE
AUTHORITY OF LOCAL -- RESIDENTS
TO PARTICIPATE AND BE ACTIVE AND
TO BE AT THE TABLE THAT'S THIS
WHOLE PROCESS THIS BILL AND
ANTICIPATES THAT AND THERE'S A
LOT OF OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO
BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE AND THEN
ULTIMATELY TO HAVE A MEMBER OF
THE BOARD. TO BE TO HAVE A
MEMBER ON THE BOARD THAT
REPRESENTS THEIR THEIR THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD OR THEIR COMMUNITY
AS WELL.
AND WE'VE ALSO -- BOTH THAT THE
SENATOR AND AND AS THE SPONSORS
HAVE WORKED IN COLLABORATION
WITH CAL LAUGHED GO TO DO
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN TO
ACCELERATE THAT PROCESS. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE COMMUNITIES HAVE A
VOICE OF IN THE FUTURE OF THEIR
WATER SUPPLY BUT ALSO TO WEST
STREAMLINED THAT PROCESS AS AS
POSSIBLE.
CENTER IF I COULD JUST QUICKLY
ADDRESS AT THAT CAN AS MENTION A
THAT THERE HAVE BEEN A MEN'S
TAKEN.
THAT PUT THIS TYPE CONSOLIDATION
ON A MORE OF AN EQUAL FOOTING
WITH OTHER SOLUTIONS RATHER THAN
LOOKING AT THIS ONE FIRST AND WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THOSE SO
THOSE WERE OUR COMMENTS GOING
INTO TO GOVERN FINANCE.
AND AND THE AMENDED TAKEN I
THINK THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE WE
I FEEL THAT THAT IS DEFINITELY
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
I MEAN THE TONE I'M GETTING IS
FOR MORE LIKE A SUPPORTIVE.
OF AMENDED.
TONE MATT AND I UNDERSTAND IT'S
ALWAYS A WE'RE ALL THESE THINGS
MEAN ANYWAY.
BUT DONE.
BUT I I YOU KNOW I DO YOU CENTER
GET THE SENSE THAT.
YOU'RE ON A DECENT PATH TO WORK
WITH SOME OF THE ROAD JUSTICE
FOLKS TODAY.
WELL I HOPE.
IT MAKES IT A LOT EASIER IF YOU
HAVE LANGUAGE THAT YOU CAN
RESPOND TO AND LOOK LOOK AT AND
SAY YES THIS IS MIGHT WORK --
DIS THIS DOESN'T WORK OKAY BUT
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE AT REALLY
RIGHT NOW IS.
WE NEED LANGUAGE AND IF.
AND THEN WE CAN WORK THREAD I
WERE TOTALLY OPEN TO MAKING THIS
WORK AND IT'S GOT TO WORK IN IN --
IN MY DISTRICT IN PARTICULAR
SINCE THIS IS AN INTEREST OF
MINE YEAH.
WHICH IS TO SOME EXTENT IS
GROUND ZERO FOR THIS PROBLEM SO
YES I HAVE OKAY WELL SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'VE GOT SOME.
YEAH YEAH MARCHING ORDERS A
STARTS IN TERMS OF PROVIDING
SOME LANGUAGE THE SENATOR.
IS SET TO START.
I THANK THE CHAIR. TO I'M
HEARING FROM YOU SENATOR THE YOU
WANT TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
URGENTLY ABSOLUTELY.
AND I'M HEARING FROM THE
OPPOSITION ABOUT CUMBERSOME NESS.
AND THAT THIS ISN'T THE MOST
EXPEDITIOUS WAY SO IN YOUR MIND
FROM THE OPPOSITION PERSPECTIVE
LIKE WHAT'S WHAT'S THE MOST
EXPEDITIOUS WAY TO ACCOMPLISH.
THIS PROCESS THROUGH LAUGH CO OR
I GUESS I I'M BEHIND HIS IS THIS
THE SAME IS. TWO FIFTY FOUR OR
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIFTEEN YES
IT IS ESSENTIALLY THE REMARKS
AND WE MADE SOME WE GO WE'VE
BEEN THIS IN DISCUSSIONS OVER
THE PAST YEAR OKAY SINCE THAT
WAS PASSED.
AND AND WE'VE MADE SOME
AMENDMENTS TO TO JUST DREAM LIKE
THE PROCESS A LITTLE BIT MORE WE
WORK WITH LAST GOES TO MAKE A
LITTLE BIT EASIER TO TO TO GO TO
THE LEFT OF PROCESS [inaudible]
GOT IT. TO THE CONCERN IS
THERE'S THERE'S EVEN A MORE
EXPEDITIOUS PATH AND THEN YOU'RE
SEEING HERE THERE'S YOU'RE
SAYING THERE'S TOO MANY CHECK
BACK SO YOU YOU ALL IN THE
VITAMIN A JUSTICE WORLD WANT
THIS TO HAPPEN EVEN FASTER THAN
WHAT.
YEAH.
I ALREADY IN THE ROOM WOULD LOVE
TO SEE RIGHT I MEAN YEAH I THINK
I THINK BUT POLICY WITH THAT
THERE'S A UP A PATH TO GET THERE
FASTER.
AND IF WE AGAIN I DON'T I DON'T
KNOW FOR THAT FAR FROM THIS BUT
IF WE CAN CONFIGURE AT THE
OUTSET WHAT THE BEST MECHANISM
IS A FREE SS.
WHAT IS THE BEST MECHANISM TO
GET THE THAT THIS COMMITTEE THAT
CAMINO CAN BE SAFE DRINKING
WATER WHETHER IT'S?
WHETHER IT'S THROUGH THE CURRENT
CONSOLIDATION AUTHORITIES THAT
EXIST WHETHER IT'S THROUGH
ADMINISTRATOR HOW.
ABOUT THAT.
AT THE AT THE OUTSET.
AND THEN NOT HAVE TO HAVE WHICH
IS THE BEST IN YOUR MIND BECAUSE
SHE'S PUT AN IDEA FOR TO LIKE
WHAT WHAT DO YOU WHAT IS WHAT
YOU GUYS HAVE A THOUGHT YET.
YEAH BUT THE ADMINISTRATOR AN
ENTITY I MEAN I THINK WE'VE
WORKED A LOT ON THE
ADMINISTRATOR I THINK WE SEE
THEIR SHARES A REALLY IMPORTANT.
STEP THE ADMINISTRATOR I THINK
WE SEE THE KIND OF THE
ADMINISTRATOR IS PLAYING A ROLE.
IN ASSESSING WHAT THE NEXT BEST.
STEP FORWARD IS.
AND AND JUST. TO HAVE YOUR HAND
THERE IN SOME WAY OKAY.
A SENSE OF WHERE THIS IS HEADED
SO I APPRECIATE AS WHAT I'M
TRYING TO THINK OF TWO THREE
YEARS FROM NOW LIKE WE HAVE
MOVEMENT OR NOT I MEAN THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT.
WE'RE GONNA NEED WE WANT MONEY
TO MOVE.
WE HAVE PLENTY OF BOND FUNDS
WHEN I TRY TO DO WITH -- AN M.
AND AT THE SAME TIME FIX THIS
IT'S A IT'S A VERY CHALLENGING
PROCESS TO DO GOVERNANCE AND
FUNDING RIGHT.
BUT I KNOW YOU'RE UP FOR IT SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORT HERE IN.
I'M OF THE BILL THE PROBABLY
TIME I DO APPRECIATE THE
FEEDBACK TO A LOVED IT PLEASE
KEEP THE COMMITTEE POST IF YOU
CAN JUST IN TERMS OF WHAT YOU'RE
THINKING IS IT GOES FOR WHEN YOU
PUT YOUR NOT COUNTER BUT YOU'RE.
SEVEN YOU KNOW YOUR LANGUAGE
YOUR LANGUAGE BORDERS SHORT OF
WHAT YOU WHAT YOU THINK WE CAN
DO TO TYPE THIS UP BECAUSE WE
WANT TO SEE MOVE QUICK SO LOOK
FOR TO SEE INVOLVED BEFORE THE
FLOOR AT THINGS.
TERM COCKY.
A SENDER WE'VE GIVEN THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES BOARD AUTHORITY
TO CONSOLIDATE THREE YEARS AGO
SO THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME
WOULD YOU AGREE THAT THIS IS NOT
THE FIRST DISCUSSION THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE HAVING.
WITH THESE FEELING WATER SYSTEMS
RIGHT.
NOW THERE ARE A GROUP OF WATER
SYSTEM SERVED IF THE STATE DOES
NOT HAVE A MANDATE TO FORCE
CONSOLIDATION THOSE WOULD BE THE
WATER SYSTEMS WITH FOURTEEN OR
LESS OR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE.
PRACTICALLY ALL FEELING TO
PROVIDE SAFE DRINKING WATER
WHICH IS NOT ON THE BALL ON THIS
ON ON ON THIS BILL BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
MANDATE THEM.
MY QUESTION IS YOU GOT THIS.
ADMINISTRATOR FOR THE LAUGH GOES
IN AND BURDENSOME ENCUMBERED WAY
HAVE THESE MEETINGS DO YOU
ENVISION ANY OF THESE ORPHANS
THESE UNDER FOURTEEN WE DON'T
HAVE A MOCK MANDATE.
VOLUNTARILY COMING TOGETHER TO
MAKE THIS BEAST POTENTIAL NEW
SYSTEMS.
WORKABLE DO YOU SEE DO YOU SEE
IS THERE SOME SPACE IN THERE FOR
THE FOLKS THAT WE CAN'T MANDATE
TO CONSOLIDATION TO PARTICIPATE
AND IMPROVE THE DISCUSSION AND
DELIVERY OF SAFE DRINKING WATER
I THINK THAT'S TOTALLY POSSIBLE.
BECAUSE IF YOU WHAT BASICALLY
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THESE ON A
REGIONAL BASIS AND IT DOESN'T
EVEN NEED TO BE ON A REGIONAL
BASIS.
THE ECONOMY'S.
OF THE TECHNICAL MANAGERIAL AND
THE EXPERTISE WHICH YOU WANT TO
BE ABLE TO DO IS TO SET UP.
AN ENTITY THAT CAN -- CAN.
ACCESS THE FUNDS GET THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND AND SO
IT'S TOTALLY POSSIBLE THAT YOU'D
END UP WITH A SMALL SYSTEM
THAT'S IN.
THE NEIGHBORING THAT SAYS I WANT
TO BE PART OF THIS BECAUSE WE
LIKE WE CAN'T WE'RE NOT
PROVIDING.
CLEAN DRINKING WATER EITHER AND
MISTER CHAIR LAST QUESTIONS.
SINCE THERE HAS BEEN DISCUSSIONS
GOING ON FOR THREE YEARS AND EN
IS IT POSSIBLE THAT YOU KNOW
THAT THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
BOARD HAS HAS.
COME TO THE CONCLUSION THAT IT'S
NOT [inaudible]
PRACTICAL.
FOR FEELING SYSTEM TO BE
CONSOLIDATED WITH THE CITY OF
FRESNO OR CITY OR BAKERSFIELD
WHEREVER.
TULARE WHEREVER IT IS AND THAT
IT WOULD BE MAKE MORE SENSE TO
CONSOLIDATE OR MANAGE OPERATE
TOGETHER WITH AN ADJACENCY
FAMILY SYSTEM TO AUTUMN TWO TO
IMPROVE.
THE DELIVERY WATER IS IT
POSSIBLE.
WELL I'LL GO AHEAD AND ANSWER
THAT -- FOR THE SENATOR I THINK
THERE'S THERE'S TWO THINGS --
TWO POINTS HERE WE'VE ACTUALLY
BEEN WORKING IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE STATE WATER BOARD TO
SEE HOW THIS IT'S AN AND TO THE
OVERALL STRUCTURE.
THEY ACTUALLY REALLY LIKE THIS
IDEA THEY THINK THERE ARE
SITUATIONS WHERE HAVING AN
ADJACENT SYSTEM A YOU KNOW --
ABSORB A A SMALLER STRUGGLING
SYSTEM IS NOT GOING TO BE
FEASIBLE SO HAVING THIS OPTION
IT FEELS REALLY A POSITIVE STEP
FORWARD AND WE CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM ABOUT WAYS.
WE CAN POTENTIALLY STREAMLINED
THE PROCESS S WELL -- YOU KNOW
THE AMENDMENTS THAT I CENTER TO
COVER YOUR I WAS TAKING THAT
REALLY ALLOW THAT CHOICE FOR THE
WATER BOARD TO MAKE IS IS
SOMETHING THAT THERE REALLY --
REALLY APPRECIATIVE OF IN AND WE
TALK TO THEM ABOUT THAT LANGUAGE
AS WELL [inaudible]
OKAY AT COMPLICATED I'M SERVICES
YOU'RE TRYING TO DRESS HERE BUT
I I I I I DO GET THE SENSE THAT --
THIS GOING TO BE CONTINUING
DISCUSSION AND AND I I WOULD
LIKE TO REITERATE CENTER STEARNS
I REQUEST THAT THE COMMITTEE BE
BROUGHT IN THE LOOP AS THAT
DISCUSSION CONTINUES AS YOU
PRESENT YOUR LANGUAGE IS YOU.
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK IT
OVER AND AND AND AND TRY TO WORK
OUT SOME OF THESE CHALLENGES BUT
I THINK GIVE KIND OF THE BIG
PICTURE WORK YOU'RE DOING IS
VERY.
I NEEDED SO.
I WITHOUT UNSERVED HAPPY SUPPORT
TODAY.
AS THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER STERN IF YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE CENTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTERS FOR A ROBUST DISCUSSION
REALLY APPRECIATE THE ATTENTION
TO DETAIL ON THIS SO.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND WE DEFINITELY WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK THIS I APPRECIATE THAT A
GREAT DEAL THANK YOU.
OKAY I WAS HOLLOW.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SP FOUR ONE
FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO THE CITY SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ALLEN
AYE ALLEN AYE DATE.
I HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER.
BY SKINNER AYE STERN STERN AYE
STONE STONE I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I CASKEY I OKAY THANK YOU
EVERYBODY VERY.
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S WORK ON
THIS WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR THE MEMBERS THAT ON AND I
SEE CENTER HERTZBERG IS HERE.
AND WILL BE PRESENTING TO ITEM
STILL START WITH ITEM FOUR IN
YOUR PACKETS MEMBERS AS SB.
TWO OH FIVE THIS LICENSE IS
STORM WATER DISCHARGE COMPLIANCE.
MR MAJORITY LEADER YOU ARE FREE
TO PROCEED -- WHEN READY?
WITH THAT SB TWO ZERO FIVE TWO
ZERO FIVE THANK YOU CHAIRMAN WAS
CAP WE CAL STATE.
A BROTHERHOOD IS BROTHERHOOD.
ONCE THE GERMAN ALL OF THE
GERMAN MISTER SPEAKER.
IT IS [inaudible]
OKAY.
IS MY STORM WATER BILL THE THE
OKAY THIS IS THE ONE OKAY THIS
THIS BILL.
BASICALLY IS THIS AS YOU AS YOU
KNOW MISTER CHAIRMAN BECAUSE YOU
HAVE THIS PROBLEM IN YOUR
COMMITTEE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
REQUIRES THESE NPDES PERMITS.
WHEN YOU HAVE WHEN YOU HAVE
RUNOFF AND THEN THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD SIMPLY
IMPLEMENTS THOSE IN LOTS OF
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND LOCAL
BUSINESSES THAT PROVIDE THAT
THAT ACTUALLY CONTRIBUTE TO THIS
POLLUTANTS?
THESE POLLUTANTS ARE REQUIRED TO
GET PERMITS AND SO THE QUESTION
IS HOW WAS A PRACTICAL MANNER
CAN WE FIGURE OUT A WAY TO GET
GREATER COMPLIANCE BECAUSE THE
TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS.
YOU'VE GOT LIABILITY IN LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS BECAUSE THEY'RE
GETTING HOSED BECAUSE THIS STUFF
FLOWING INTO THE SYSTEM AND YOU
ALSO OF LOCAL.
BUSINESSES THAT DON'T EVEN KNOW
THE NEED TO COMPLY SO WHAT WE'VE
DONE HERE IS TO TO REQUIRE IN
THIS BILL ON WHAT WE ARE.
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES CITY OR
COUNTY HAS A PERMIT TO SIMPLY
HAVE A BOX THAT YOU CAN SAY AND
PROVE THAT YOU HAVE THIS NOW
THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT THAT GOT
TO COMPLIANCE OTHER LOOK ON THE
WEBSITE FOR THE UNDER THE CODE
TO SEE IF YOUR COMPLIANCE IS NOT
A BUNCH OF EXTRA.
WORK AND I WOULD ARGUE THAT FOR
THOSE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BECAUSE
WE ALWAYS SEE THIS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMPLAINING ALL GOD
WERE GIVEN A MORE UNFUNDED
MANDATES.
THE REALITY I WOULD SUGGEST IS
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT. FOR
NOMINAL FOR THEM BECAUSE IT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT WE'RE JUST
ASKING THEM TO DO IT'S ALSO BY
VIRTUE OF GETTING A COMPLIANCE
YOU HAVE.
THIS DIMMITT THIS OF A REDUCTION
OF THEIR OWN RISK IN TERMS OF
THE POLLUTION LOCALLY SO.
WE REQUIRE WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
IN THIS BILL IS THAT THESE ARE
ENTITIES IF YOU HAVE A PERMIT
OTHER SOME COUNTIES THAT DON'T
REQUIRE.
A BUSINESS -- YOU KNOW BUSINESS
LICENSE IS FINE BUT IN THOSE
COUNTIES 80% OF THOSE HAVE
CITIES.
I THE POLLUTION FROM THESE DEALS
AND CITIES AFTER CITIES THE
NUMBERS ARE PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
THERE IN YOUR ANALYSIS I DID YOU
GO TO HIM SPECIFICALLY.
BUT THIS IS JUST A PRACTICAL WAY
TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW IN THIS
VERY SHARED LIABILITY AREA OF
COMPLIANCE THAT WE COME UP WITH
KIND OF A NIFTY IDEA -- THAT
THAT HELPS IT SURE COMPLIANCE ON
SOMETHING THAT HAS SUCH
EXTRAORDINARY.
IMPACT WE JUST SAW ON LOS
ANGELES PASSING A MULTI BILLION
DOLLAR PARTIAL TAX TO TO TO TO
CLEAN UP THE STORM WATER IT'S A
BIG ISSUE WE SEE CITIES HAVE
BEEN BIG PROBLEMS AND CHILLS
STILL CITIES HAVING BIG PROBLEMS
IN THIS REGARD.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND I
DON'T WAS TESTIFYING BECAUSE MY
FIRST TRIP.
MORNING CHECK MANY MEMBERS
MENTIONED BOTTLE AND THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF COMPANY
BECAUSE COMPLIANCE -- HERE TODAY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TO A
FIVE OH ONE MAY TWO TWO QUICK
POINTS OUR FIRST IS TO JUST SOME
OF THE CONCERNS RUN THE WORD
CONCERTS.
CONFIRM IN THE BILL WHAT IT
MEANS FOR THE MUNICIPALITY TO
CONFIRM WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR A
MUNICIPAL UP AND MUNICIPALITY TO
CONFIRM WHETHER.
A BUSINESS ENTITY IS IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE ENTIRE
INDUSTRIAL STORMWATER PERMIT
THAT IS THE ROLE OF THE STATE
AND REGIONAL WATER BOARDS WITH
THIS BILL IS REQUESTING.
OR ASKING THE MUNICIPAL IS TO DO
IS TO CONFIRM THAT THEY NEED TO
IN ROLE OR NOT AND ROLL UNDER
THE INDUSTRIAL STORMWATER PERMIT
AND ALL THAT ENTAILS IS.
AS I SEE CODE AND MATCHING TO
WHAT THE STATE WATER BOARD HAS
ALREADY.
PUT UP ON THE WEBSITE THANKS TO
THIS BILL.
ARE THE SECOND PART IN POINT I
WANT TO MAKE IS.
INDUSTRIAL STORMWATER BUSINESS
LICENSES ITS NOT THE SEXIEST
ISSUE IN THE WORLD BUT IT REALLY
IS AN ELEGANT SOLUTION TO A BIG
PROBLEM WE HAVE ON THE STATE --
IT IS S. ME THAT THERE'S ONLY
ONE OUT OF FIVE OF BUSINESS
FACILITIES THAT HAVE BEEN ROLLED
UNDER THIS INDUSTRIAL PERMIT ONE
OUT OF FIVE AND SO PUT THAT IN
THE CONTEXT VOTES LET'S JUST
TAKE LOS ANGELES.
ARE NGUYEN WATERWAYS IMPAIRED
FOR FOR WHATEVER POLLUTANT THE
REGIONAL BOARD COMES UP WITH A
TOTAL DAILY MAXIMUM LOAD A TMDL --
AND AND THEY CREATE THIS BY
FIGURING OUT HOW MUCH OF THE LA
RIVER CAN TAKE SO MUCH METALS
WITHOUT BEING IMPAIRED.
AND THEN THEY DIVIDE THAT UP.
AMONG THE PERMIT TV'S THAT ARE
DISCHARGING INTO THE RIVER
DESTRUCTION METALS INTO THE
RIVER BUT ONLY ONE OUT OF FIVE
FACILITIES ARE AND ROLLED UNDER
THE PERMIT.
THAT MEANS WE'RE MISSING 80% OF
THE FOLKS THAT SHOULD BE LIABLE
FOR THOSE THE STARS AND SHOULD
BE CONTROLLING IT. TO THE CITY
OF LA THE MUNICIPALITIES ALL THE
INDUSTRIAL FACILITIES THAT ARE
UNDER THE PERMIT.
IN ALL REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH A
TEAM DEAL ARE DOING IT WELL 80%
DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT IT EXISTS
AND SO THIS REALLY.
IS IS AN ATTEMPT.
TO IMPROVE LIABILITY FOR
MUNICIPALITIES AND REALLY LEVEL
THE PLAYING FIELD -- FOR
INDUSTRIAL FACILITIES SO AUSTERE
IP THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
LAURIE CAMERA REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA METALS COALITION
TODAY -- THE CMC IS -- HOME TO
FOUR THOUSAND METAL COALITION
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA THAT
EMPLOY ABOUT THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND WORKERS.
AND THE NON FILER ISSUE -- AS
SEAN WAS INDICATING -- AND
SENATOR WAS INDICATING THIS IS A
A REAL ISSUE FOR THOSE SMALL
BUSINESSES WHO PURCHASED THE
PERMITS AND END UP COMPETING
WITH THOSE WHO DO NOT.
HAVE A PERMIT -- IF YOU'RE
PERMITTED AND THE STORM WATER
RUNS OVER INTO YOUR PROPERTY
THEN U. S. THE PERMIT HOLDER ARE
RESPONSIBLE -- FOR THESE REASONS
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
SB TWO OH FIVE THANK YOU.
THE FOLKS WHO WANT TO SPEAK OUT
IN SUPPORT.
IS THE VISION COUNTIES.
WE HAVE A SUPPORT IF AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL WE WE
APPRECIATE THE SPIRIT OF THE
MEASURE WE WE SUPPORT EFFORTS TO
CLEAN WATER WE DO THINK IT'S A
NIFTY IDEA -- THE ONE PART THAT --
THAT WAS SPOKEN.
TO EARLIER IS OUR IS OUR ONE
CONCERN WHICH WHICH IS JUST THAT --
A LOT OF COUNTIES THAT HAVE A
BUSINESS LICENSE SYSTEM WHICH
WHICH AS IT WAS HAD NOT ALL OF
THEM DO.
IT'S SIMPLY A IN A LOT OF HIS IS
SIMPLY A MINISTERIAL SYSTEM AND
SO HAVING TO CHECK.
ANYTHING ACTUALLY COULD CREATE
SOME AT SOME TROUBLE WITH JUST
CHANGING THE WHOLE PROCESS BUT
THE BUSINESS BROUGHT THAT SO
INSTEAD.
I WHAT WE THINK WOULD BE AN EVEN
IF YOUR IDEA IS IF THE WATER
BOARD WHICH IS ALREADY.
WHICH IS ALREADY RESPONSIBLE FOR
CHECKING COMPLIANCE AFTER THESE
BUSINESS WE JUST PASSED THE
DOCUMENTS ALL I WOULD COLLECT
THEM AS PART OF A BUSINESS
LICENSE PROCESS AND PASS THEM
ALONG. TO THE WATER BOARD THEN
THEY CAN CHECK THE COMPLIANCE
WHICH THEY ARE UNIQUELY.
POSITIONED TO DO SO AGAIN
SUPPORT THE CONCEPT OF A SB TOOL
FIVE WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME
MINOR AMENDMENTS TO IT AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON ON THIS
BILL [inaudible]
YES.
LOW ENTRY OF INTER WITH CLEAN
WATER ACTION SPORTS THANK YOU.
MORNING AGAIN MATTHEW BAKER WITH
PAYING CONSERVATION THEY CAN
SUPPORT.
YOU HAVE MAKE YOU ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA POLITICS
MEMBERS ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL IT'S GOOD FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT AND ENVIRONMENT AND
GOOD FOR BUSINESS.
READY WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
BRENNAN DAWSON WAS HERE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
WELL SOME OF THE FRIENDS THEY
ARE VERY SMART.
HILL THE BAY AND WHISPERED AS
WELL.
THANK YOU.
I'M.
ALWAYS CONCERNED ABOUT THE BILL
OR OPPOSITION.
YOU CAN ONE CHAIR NEVER SAID
THERE DAHLE HM TO HAVE TO LEAVE
CALIFORNIA CITIES SO WE DON'T
HAVE A FORMAL POSITION ON THE
BILL AS OF RIGHT NOW BUT WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE AUTHOR'S
EFFORTS TO HELP WITH STORM WATER
AND HAVE BEEN SUPPORTIVE.
OF HIS OF HIS -- EFFORTS ON THIS
ISSUE IN THE PAST -- WE SHARE
SOME OF THE SAME CONCERNS AS THE
US AS C. SACK ON THIS ISSUE --
THE LEAGUE.
YOU KNOW IT IF IF REQUIRING
CITIES TO VERIFY -- BUSINESS
COMPLIANCE WITH STORE MORE
PERMITTING -- COULD POSE A MAJOR
ISSUE FOR SOME OF OUR CITIES BUT
LIKE I SAID WE'RE GENERALLY
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE AND WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR TO STAFF AND HOPEFULLY WE
LUCIEN ARE CONCERNED SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SO YOU'RE YOU'RE
WHERE YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT. TO
SORT OF THE JUST COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH HAVING AN AND
SOMEONE GO OVER THE YEAH THE WAY
THAT HE MAY NOT SAYS YES THANK
YOU MAY THE WAY MANY.
CITIES ISSUE THE BUSINESS
LICENSES ARE VERY A MINISTERIAL
YOU KNOW THERE'S NOT A LOT OF
CHECKING OUR OR VERIFYING OF THE
INFORMATION SO -- HAVING THEM
ACTUALLY HAVE TO GO AND CHECK
WOULD BE SETTING UP A NEW
PROCESS AND MANY OF THEM ARE
DOING THAT I'M ON THE THROUGH
THIS ONLINE THROUGH AN ONLINE
PORTAL SET BE.
HAVING TO CHANGE THE SYSTEM IN
WHICH THEY ACTUALLY HAVE TO
ISSUE THESE BUSINESS TAXES.
THIS IS A TRICKY BECAUSE THE
CITIES ARE ALSO CHOMPING AT THE
BIT OVER ALL THE COMPLAINTS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE WITH CLEAN
WATER ACT AND HOW IT TURNS TO
BREAK BUDGETS.
I'M SELF IT WOULD SEEM LIKE A
SMART PLACE TO PUT AN INVESTMENT
BUT I TOTALLY GET YEAH SAYS THE
SMALL CITIES STRAPPED IN YEAH
THAT'S WHY WE'RE CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND WERE
GENERALLY SUPPORT OF THE DUGGAR
WE DON'T HAVE THE FORMAL
POSITION OF GREAT THANK YOU.
TAKE CARE YES.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MONICA
MILLER REPRESENTING THE SANTA
CLARA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT NOW
KNOWN AS VALLEY WATER AND WE
HAVE OPPOSED THE SUBMITTED OUR
POINT JUST TOOK THIS POSITION SO
OUR APOLOGIES. FOR GETTING OUR
LETTER IN LATE I WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH BOTH THE
ON BOTH AUTHORS AS WELL AS YOUR
STAFF ON OUR PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
OTHER CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL OR
ISSUES WOULD YOU WANT A RACE
OKAY -- THE ITEM IS.
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE SO MY MATE
THE BILL THE BILL OFFERS AN
ONLINE PORTAL THAT CITIES CAN
SHACK I'M.
OF COURSE CITIES WOULD STILL
HAVE.
TO SO WHEN WE STILL HAVE TO
EVALUATE THE QUALITY OF THE WELL
THAT'S NOT THE ONLY WAY SOMEONE
COULD BE A LITTLE CREATIVE AND
HIRE SOME STUDENT. TO TAKE THE
PAGE AND A HALF OF COLDS AND PUT
THEM IN ON THE FORMS WHEN YOU
FILL OUT YOUR FORM YOU WOULD
SIMPLY WRITE THE COLD IT WOULD
MATCH OR NOT MATCH.
THERE'S NO VALIDATE IN THAT THE
PERSON SIGNS IN THE PENALTY OF
PERJURY IN YOUR COAT THIS IS ONE
OF THE SITUATIONS WHERE.
IN GOVERNMENT WHAT ARE WE TRYING
TO DO WE'VE GOT A WHOLE BUNCH OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS.
AND THOSE PEOPLE ARE TAKING A
BIG BURDEN FOR THE NON LAW
BLIGHTED CITIZENS WE THEN GOT A
WHOLE BIG GIGANTIC RISK THAT
EVERYBODY HAS BECAUSE OF CRUMMY
WATER THAT RUNS OFF OF WITH THAT
FEDERAL LWS AND BIG.
FINES EVERYBODY'S GOING CRAZY
CAT DO WE HAVE CAN WE HAVE A
LITTLE CREEK IF THE YEAR YOU CAN
SIMPLY EASILY DO WANNA IF YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE AN ONLINE APPLICATION
YOU JUST LIKE.
YOU'RE GOING TO GO ONLINE WE ALL
WANTED WAS ON THESE OTHER
COMPANIES YOU FILL OUT IF YOU
PUT THE WRONG NUMBER IT REJECTS
IT IF YOU PUT A PHONE NUMBER IN
OKAY. FOR AFFORDABLE YOU
SUDDENLY IF THE PENALTY OF
PERJURY FOR PURPOSES OF THE PAGE
AND A HALF OF CODE SECTIONS
RIGHT IT'S NOT HARD TO FIX THIS
IS ONE OF THESE ISSUES WHERE YOU
KNOW I CHAIRED THE EXCEPTIONS
COMMITTEE.
BIGELOW GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
THAT YOU KNOW YOU GUYS TALK
ABOUT LAUGH CO THAT I WROTE THAT
LAW WAY BACK WHEN AND ALL THESE
EXCEPTIONS.
YEAH WE JUST FRICKIN GET
CREATIVE FOR ONCE IN OUR LIFE
AND TRY TO COME UP WITH
SOMETHING BECAUSE THE
DELIVERABLES HERE ARE LAW
ABIDING POKES THAT ARE DOING THE
LAW.
AND EVERY ONE OF THESE COUNTIES
AND CITIES GOT HUGE RISKS THIS
IS NOT A HARD TO FIGURE OUT.
ALL ONE WORD ABOUT RISK ALL MORE
ABOUT MONEY THAT'S THE SAME
EXCUSE EVERYWHERE LET'S GET PAST
IT.
WHAT WHAT IS WHAT ABOUT WOULD BE
THE WORD AT RISK WHAT WITH THE
RESULT BECAUSE THEY'RE SAYING
WELL I'M GONNA HAVE THE RISK IS
I GOT TO GO AND CHECK THIS OUT
AND MY PEOPLE MAKE A MISTAKE
THERE MIGHT BE A RISK IN THERE'S
THIS PROBLEM NOW THE PERSON?
SIGNS LE PEN PERDUE CHECK THE
CODE SECTION YOU COULD LITERALLY
DOWNLOAD THE CODE.
AND SOMEONE HAS TO FILL IN THIS
IS NOT A HARD PROBLEM TO SOLVE.
AND WITH WITH RESPECT TO THE
SPEAKER HE HE THEIR INCOME ON
OPPOSITION NO NO NO I KNOW YOU
KNOW I'M JUST I'M JUST
FRUSTRATED BECAUSE TRYING TO
PUSH THE ENVELOPE WORK
GOVERNMENT IS GETTING SLOWER AND
SLOWER.
AND THE PRIVATE SECTORS GETTING
FASTER AND FASTER AND WE'VE GOT
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO THINK
DIFFERENTLY BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
LOSING CONFIDENCE IN GOVERNMENT.
AND WE JUST GOT TO GET OUT OF
THOSE ALL WHAT'S NOT ONLY THAT'S
RIGHT THERE IS THE THINKING
ABOUT IT IS A HUGE LIABILITY
THAT IS COMING DOWN ON A LOT OF
CITIES I KNOW I WANT I ONE OF MY
CITIES HAS LIKE A TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR ANNUAL BUDGET.
AND A TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR LIABILITY UNDER THE CLEAN
WATER ACT.
AND I'D LIKE TO KNOW HOW MANY
PERMITS IN THAT CITY ARE ARE NOT
ARE NOT.
ENTITIES THAT AREN'T PERMITTED
THAT SHOULD BE ENTITY AND WHY
SHOULD DEEPER PARTICIPATING AND
WOULD THAT HELP YOUR CITY RIGHT.
A LOT YEAH.
YEAH YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH OKAY.
GOOD WELL -- APPRECIATE.
YEAH AS A QUESTION FROM CENTER
STERN YEAH SO JUST TO JUST TO
CONFIRM HERE WE'RE TALKING.
WE'RE WE'RE NOT TAKING MEDI
COMPLIANCE VERIFICATION LIKE
WHETHER THEY'RE WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE IN COMPLIANCE WITH THEIR
MS FOR WHATEVER YOU CALL THEIR
INDUSTRIAL PARK.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A AS UP
HOSTING OUT OF THEIR
CLASSIFICATION.
SO WHETHER THEY'RE SUBJECT TO
COMPLIANCE IS THAT ESSENTIALLY
WITH HIS BILL AS AS AS WE'RE
GONNA BASS HAVE AN ACCURATE
INVENTORY OF ALL THE ENTITIES
THAT.
OUR SUBJECT TO COMPLIANCE YEAH.
WORD ENROLLMENT SO THEY'RE
SUBJECT WHEN ROLLING UNDER THE
INDUSTRIAL PERMIT WE ARE NOT NOT
IN ANY WAY ASKING IS HARD TO
FIGURE OUT IF THEY'RE COMPLYING
WITH THE PERMIT THAT IS THE ROLE
OF THE REGIONAL BOARD.
AND THE STATE BOARD AND HE WOULD
NEVER HAS THE MUSE AND BY
FILLING OUT THAT PERFORM THESE
COMPANIES THAT DON'T EVEN KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE TO COMPLY.
THE PEOPLE IN HER WORLD THAT ARE
NOT COMPLYING 80% RIGHT AT LEAST
IT PUTS A FOR A PLACE ON THE
FORM THIS IS A WAY BETTER THINK
ABOUT THIS WELL THAT'S RIGHT AND
AND AND THAT'S WHAT I MEAN I
WONDER MARK.
I I I DON'T REMEMBER THE LAST
TIME I SAW BILL WHERE THE METALS
COALITION AND COAST PEOPLE RIGHT
NOW DIES OR WHERE THE CRAFT THE
SCRAPPERS OR ENERGY SEE ARE ALSO
RISE WORDS ARE VERY.
I'M CONFUSED AND I AND AND AND
IS STANDING IN ADMIRATION
FRANKLY OF OF FINDING SOME
THROUGH PATH HERE BUT WHO WHO IS
IT WHO IS MISSING RIGHT NOW LIKE.
YOU KNOW FOR FOR ANY FROM AN
INDUSTRY PERSPECTIVE LIKE WHAT
WHAT DO YOU WHAT WILL POP OUT.
FROM THIS WHO WHO WHO DOESN'T
KNOW.
THAT THEIR SUBJECT TO THIS YET
OR WHO MIGHT WE BE MISSING IN
THE FRAME.
FROM OUR EXPERIENCE FROM.
MORE MEDIUM TO SMALLER
BUSINESSES THE AUTO JUST
METALLERS OR ONE THAT POP OUT
THAT AND WE'VE WE'VE DONE BILLS
WITH AUTO DISMANTLING INDUSTRY
BEFORE TO ADDRESS THIS TO THE
DMV SO THERE'S BEEN SOMEONE
LEGISLATION TO THIS -- THE METAL
RECYCLERS THE THE THE LARGER
FOLKS IN THE THE WASTE WALL
WATER FOLKS USUALLY ARE UNDER
THE PERMIT ALREADY.
AGAIN I WOULD AGREE WITH SEAN TO
AYE TO TURN OUT OVER CASEY HAD
SOMETHING ELSE TO SAY BUT YES%
I'M SENATOR WE'RE COMPETING IS
SMALL BUSINESSES WITH THOSE WHO
KNOW THEY SHOULD FILE OR CHOOSE
NOT TO FIGHT RIGHT.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE PAINT WHERE THE LAW
ABIDING EMPLOYEE.
LAWYERS HAVING TO COMPETE YEARS
ABJECT RIGHT YOU'RE YOU'RE
RYING TO COMPLY WITH THE LAW
BUT THAT THEY'RE SORT OF THE FLY
BY NIGHTERS A I SEE.
UNDERSTOOD YEAH HELP THE OTHER
THING I I'M JUST TO TAKE CHARGE
PRIVILEGE YOU KNOW I I HEARD --
ARE CHAIR EMERITUS MENTIONED THE
OTHER FOLKS OUR SCHOOLS RIGHTS
GOT ME COLLEGES.
ON EFFECTIVE YOU LOOK AT PAGE
SEVEN OUNCES IT REFERS A BILL
THAT WE DID I DID A COUPLE YEARS
AGO THAT -- TRIES TO PUSH THAT
ENVELOPE FOR BUT SCHOOLS YOU
KNOW FOR GOOD REASONS ARE GIVEN
AUTONOMY AND INDEPENDENCE AND
FROM A LOT OF THINGS -- BUT THEY
ALSO END UP HAVING A LOT OF
BLACK TOP IN A LOT OF RENT SPACE
AND AND ACTUALLY THERE
OFTENTIMES.
BEHIND WAY BEHIND CITIES IN
TERMS OF USING BEST PRACTICES OF
STRONG WATER CAPTURE AND SWELLS
AND ALL THE THINGS THAT WE KNOW
THAT WE NEED TO DO. TO BE BETTER
ABOUT THIS KIND OF THING AND AND
SO THAT'S ANOTHER.
SO WE WE WE DID A BILL -- THE
COUPLE YEARS AGO.
YOU KNOW ENCOURAGEDTHE
DEVELOPMENT BEST PRACTICES AND
AND REAL COOPERATION BETWEEN THE
DIVISION STATE ARCHITECT AND
INDEPENDENT SERVICES IN SCHOOL
ON THIS BUT THAT'S OF THAT
CONTINUES TO BE STICKING POINT
TWO FOR CITIES.
YEAH OKAY SO I YEAH SO I THINK
CENTERS INNER BY MOVED TO FIRST --
SO -- WITH THAT DIED AT THE
CENTRE YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU I
JUST REMEMBER THINKING WHEN
ACROSS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF A SEARCH OF
HIS CAR.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB.
TWO OH FIVE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALLEN HI ALLEN AYE BATES.
BATES AYE HILL.
I SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN STERN AYE
STONE STONE I Y. CASKEY
[inaudible]
SB I'D.
OKAY SEVEN ZERO AND THAT'S
FANTASTIC I THINK THA.
THAT THAT BILLS OUT WE WILL NOT
HAVE TO OPEN THE ROLE IN THAT I
KNOW SAID IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
YOU WANT TO GO PRESENTED
GOVERNANCE FINANCE.
GOVERNMENT FINANCE CENTER
THEY'LL BE RIGHT BACK IN A
MINUTE OKAY.
FANTASTIC OKAY APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU GOOD DISCUSSION SOME
OF THE PAST OF THE TRAVEL BACK
TO THE VICE CHAIR AND I'M GONNA
PRESENT SB.
THREE NINETY TWO NOW THIS.
NEXT HALF COULD YOU DO THIS
BECAUSE I CAN GO ON EDUCATION
FOR SHOULD I ANSWER [inaudible]
YES.
YEAH TORTURE MURDERS YEAH.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEREDITH
IN FACT IT'S ACTUALLY WRITTEN
HERE JERRY MEREDITH BECAUSE I
THINK WE ANTICIPATED.
TO SOMETHING LIKE THAT SO.
ODD.
MEMBERS ARE YOU MAY RECALL THAT
WE HAD A VERY INTERESTING
HEARING.
NOT TOO LONG AGO ON CALIFORNIA'S
GREEN CHEMISTRY PROGRAM IT WAS
OVER IN THE ASSEMBLY SIDE OF THE
JOINT COMMITTEE HEARING THAT WE
DID WITH.
A SOMBER CORKS COMMITTEE.
AND LEARN ABOUT THESE ISSUES AND
THIS COMES OUT OF THAT HEARING
IN A AN IMPORTANT REPORT THAT'S
HAPPENED -- IN THIS GREEN
CHEMISTRY SPACE SO THIS BILL.
UPDATES AND STRENGTHENS
CALIFORNIA'S GREEN CHEMISTRY
PROGRAM IN ORDER TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS FROM.
HAZARDOUS CHEMICALS IN THEIR
DAILY LIVES.
FOLKS KNOW THAT ON TEN YEARS AGO
CALIFORNIA ESTABLISHED THE GREEN
CHEMISTRY PROGRAM THAT WAS
DISCUSSED AND WITH CENTER CALL
YOUR HOUSE BILL.
I'VE BEEN SELLING MEMBER MIGHT
FEAR IS AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY NINE
AND SENATOR.
SIMIANS ASKED FIVE ON NINE THE
PROGRAM DID CAN I RECOGNIZE
THREE KEY THINGS ONE THAT
CALIFORNIANS ARE SOMETIMES A
KNOWINGLY EXPOSED.
TO HAZARDOUS CHEMICALS IN THE
PRODUCTS THAT THEY USE TO THAT
THE STATE HAS AN IMPORTANT ROLE
IN PROTECTING THEM.
AND THREE THAT USING THE BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENCE IN A CLEAR
TRANSPARENT REGULATORY PROCESS
IS THE BEST WAITED TO DO THIS
AND AND SO THE DEPARTMENT TALKS
UPS CONTROL DGSE TOOK THE
LEGISLATURE'S MANDATE.
AND IT DEVELOPED THE FIRST OF
ITS KIND SEE FOR CONSUMER
PRODUCTS PROGRAM THAT WE TALK A
LITTLE ABOUT EARLIER.
NOW THE ON THE SERVER CONSUMER
PRODUCTS PROGRAM FIRST
IDENTIFIES CHEMICALS OF CONCERN
AND THEN IT FINDS PRODUCTS WHERE
THOSE CHEMICALS.
MAY BE AFFECTING USERS PEOPLE.
I DGSE THEN CALLS UPON
MANUFACTURERS TO PERFORM AN
ALTERNATIVE ANALYSIS. TO FIND
CHEMICALS THAT CAN BE
SUBSTITUTED TO KEEP FOLK SAFE
FOR A WHILE STILL PROVIDING. FOR
THE PRODUCTS THAT THEY WANT AND
NEED.
NOW THE GOALS IN FRAMEWORK OF
THE SEA FOR CONSUMER PRODUCTS
PROGRAM ARE COMMENDABLE BUT WELL
WHAT BRINGS ME HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT THIS BILL SB THREE
TWENTY THREE NINETY TWO TO YOU
IS THE PROGRAM'S.%
TIMELINE.
I TODAY NO CHEMICAL NO CHEMICAL.
I WAS TEN YEARS IT.
HAS HAD AN ALTERNATE ANNOUNCES
COMPLETED UNDER THE CERTIFICATE
SUMA PRODUCTS PROGRAM.
NO REGULATIONS HAVE RESULTED.
HI SO GREAT FRAMEWORK.
VERY LITTLE OF SUBSTANCE TO
CONSUMERS AS ACTUALLY COME OUT
OF THAT LAUDABLE FRAMEWORK AND
AND SYSTEM.
AND IN FACT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HIGHLIGHTED AT OUR
HEARING.
WAS THIS.
REPORT FROM THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE.
A LOOK BACK AT THE FIRST TEN
YEARS THE PROGRAM AND WHAT'S
CAUSING THE SLOWDOWN
CALIFORNIA'S GREEN CHEMISTRY
INITIATIVE AGE.
TEN AND EVALUATION OF ITS
PROGRESS AND PROMISE AT YOU
MEMBERS WILL RECALL DOCTOR
SOLLENTUNA SOLOMON.
PRESENTING.
SO MY BILL TAKES. TO SOME OF THE
KEY RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THIS
REPORT TO STRENGTHEN THE PROGRAM
AND ULTIMATELY ALLOW OUR GREEN
CHEMISTRY PROGRAM TO ACHIEVE ITS
GOALS.
AND HERE'S WHAT IT DOES
SPECIFICALLY BUILDING OFF OF
THIS REPORT.
I A GRANTS DGSE CLEAR AUTHORITY
TO OBTAIN PRODUCT INGREDIENT
DATA FROM MANUFACTURES AND IF
NEEDED FROM THEIR CHEMICAL
SUPPLIERS.
IT ADDS NEW AUTHORITATIVE LIST
OF CHEMICALS OF CONCERN TO FILL
GAPS IN THE CURRENT LIST.
IT REQUIRES THE TSC TO ADOPT A
FIVE YEAR TIMELINE. TO IDENTIFY
AND ASSESS PRIORITY PRODUCTS
INCLUDING DATA COLLECTION A
FUNCTION BASED APPROACH TO AVOID.
REGRETTABLE SUBSTITUTION SO
THAT'S ALWAYS AN ISSUE WHERE YOU
DON'T WANT.
TO JUST REPLACE ONE GUY CHEMICAL
WITH ANOTHER IT'S GOING TO BE
JUST AS DAMAGING.
THAT'S REFERRED IS REGRETTABLE
SUBSTITUTION WONDERFUL TERM OF
ART.
I ND IT FINALLY IT STREAMLINES
THE INFORMAL RESOLUTION AN
APPEALS PROCESS HE'S AN INCREASE
A FAST TRACK. FOR WHEN EXISTING
STUDY SUPPORT REGULATORY
RESPONSES SOMETIMES -- IT
STUDIES OUT THERE.
THAT TRY TO BE A BROUGHT INTO
THE CONVERSATION -- BUT UNDER
THE OLD SYSTEM THERE WERE
DIFFICULTIES IN DOING THAT SO I
HAVE WITH ME HERE TODAY I'LL BE
KERR FROM NOT TO RESOURCE
DEFENSE COUNCIL AND AN INJURY OF
INTER FROM CLEAN WATER ACTION.
HIGHLIGHTS ALSO IN THE BILL ALL
YOU DO IS COMING FROM I AM FROM
A WORKING GROUP.
AND THEY'RE GONNA BE TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF SB.
THREE NINETY TWO FIRST WITNESS.
OKAY MY GUESS.
HELLO I'M ANDREA VENTURE AS YOU
HEARD FROM CLEAN WATER ACTION
AND I JUST WANT TO TAKE A BRIEF
AND IT TO BRING US BACK TO WHY
THIS IS A PROGRAM IS IMPORTANT
AND THEN WHY THE BILL IS
IMPORTANT AND YOU KNOW SOMETIMES
WE CAN GET WRAPPED UP SENIOR
ROOM.
LIKE THIS WITH JUST LEGISLATION
AND REGULATION BUT THIS DOES
AFFECT REAL PEOPLE.
AND THE PROMISE OF THIS PROGRAM
WE'VE SEEN AN INKLING OF IT BUT
WE'RE NOT THERE YET -- THAT WE
SHOULD RE REMEMBER I'M FOR
INSTANCE SYNTHETIC FLAME
RETARDANT SOMETHING THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS LOOKED AT ITSELF --
HAS BEEN ADDRESSED IN CHILDREN'S
NAP MATS BY THIS PROGRA.
THOSE CHEMICALS ACTUALLY ARE
LINKED TO CANCER THEY BECAUSE A
THYROID DESTRUCTION OF MEMORY
AND LEARNING PROBLEMS CAN EVEN
IN FACT IMPACT THE A PERSON'S
DNA.
ARM WRESTLING CHLORIDE SOMETHING
THAT THE SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS
PROGRAM IS LOOKING AT NOW IN
REGULATING IN PAINT STRIPPERS
HAVEN'T SALTED IN AT LEAST SIXTY
FOUR DEATHS THESE ARE THE ONES
WE KNOW ABOUT ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
INCLUDING A FORTY THREE YEAR OLD
INDIVIDUAL IN HUNTINGTON PARK
CALIFORNIA WHO WAS ON THE JOB
AND WAS FOUND DEAD IN A BATHROOM
WHEN HE WAS STRIPPING AT A BATH
TUB.
SO YOU KNOW THIS IS ABOUT REAL
PEOPLE REAL CALIFORNIANS WORKERS
AND CONSUMERS -- AND IT'S REALLY
ABOUT PER ANNUM BUT AS THE
SENATOR HAS SAID.
WOW THIS PROGRAM IS
EXTRAORDINARILY INNOVATIVE IN
THAT IT IS REALLY MEANT NOT TO
JUST DEAL WITH CHEMICALS WITH
THEIR IT'S OBVIOUS WE NEED TO
GET AWAY FROM THEM BUT WHERE WE
DON'T KNOW HOW TO AVOID THE
REGRETTABLE SUBSTITUTIONS.
ARM IT IS NOT MOVING THE DOES
NOT FOR FILLING IN ITS ITS
PROMISE.
AT THE SAME TIME WE'VE BEEN
FACED WITH A SITUATION WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE WITH A FEW
EXCEPTIONS HAS BEEN RELUCTANT TO
ADDRESS CHEMICAL SPECIFICALLY.
FOR FEAR OF BEING US INTO THOSE
REGRETTABLE SUBSTITUTION
SITUATIONS.
AND SO WHAT WE REALLY WANT TO BE
ABLE TO DO IS MAKE THIS PROGRAM.
WORK SO WE REALLY ARE PROTECTING
OUR ENVIRONMENT AND OUR
CALIFORNIANS -- IV IS GOING TO
GO INTO A LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL
AND EXPAND ON WHAT THE SENATORS
SAID ABOUT THE BILL.
I JUST WANT TO END BY SAYING
THAT.
WELL OVER THE TEN YEARS WE
HAVEN'T SEEN MUCH PROGRESS WE
HAVEN'T SEEN THE REGULATORY
PROCESS MOVING.
QUICK ENOUGH AND REALLY AREN'T
MOVING US DOWN.
THE ROAD WHY AND CALIFORNIA IS
FALLING BEHIND IN THAT IN
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC.
I'M WHAT WE ARE.
ARSENE IT WELL WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
IS WHERE THE PROBLEMS ARE WHEREWHERE.
THE BARRIERS ARE FOR THE PROGRAM
TO MOVE FORWARD AND SO REALLY
WITH THIS BILL IS TRYING TO DO
IS TAKE A SURGICAL APROACH. TO
TO THE ISSUES ADDRESSED THE DATA
GAP ADDRESS SOME OF THE OTHER --
INEFFICIENCIES ADMINISTRATIVE
INSUFFICIENCIES THAT ARE
STOPPING THE PROGRAM FROM MOVING
FORWARD IT'S NOT MEANT TO RE
DEFINE IT OR TO RE DEFINE -- ITS
INTENT IT'S REALLY TO MAKE THOSE
FIXES SO THAT WE CAN OPTIMIZE
SUCCESS IN CALIFORNIA AND
PROTECT OUR ENVIRONMENT AND OUR
PEOPLE.
THANK YOU NEXT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS AVINASH
CAR AND I'M WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL.
SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM
IS AN ESSENTIAL COMPONENT OF
ADDRESSING TOXIC CHEMICALS
BEFORE THEY BECOME A PROBLEM
THAT IS FOCUSING ON PREVENTING
TALKS EXPORTERS IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
RATHER THAN CLEANING UP OR
FIXING THE HARMS AFTER THE FACT.
MY COLLEAGUE ENTER VENTURE INTO
SENATOR HAVE OUTLINED BUT THE
IMPORTANT ROLE OF THE SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM IN
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
SLOW PACE OF THE PROGRAM.
AND A RECENT TEN YEAR
RETROSPECTIVE REVIEW BY DR
SOLOMON IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE ALSO OUTLINED BY THE
TREMENDOUS POTENTIAL THE PROGRAM
AND THE STRUCTURAL FACTORS THAT
ARE HOLDING IT BACK.
MAKING A SERIES OF
RECOMMENDATIONS -- TO ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES.
AS BETWEEN NINETY TO ADDRESS IS
A NUMBER OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND WOULD REMOVE
SEVERAL OF THE STRUCTURAL
BARRIERS -- HOLDING THE PROGRAM
BACK. ONE KEY ISSUE IS THE
PROGRAM'S LACK OF ACCESS TO
PRODUCT INGREDIENT DATA.
PROGRAM STAFF HAVE HAD TO RESORT
TO GOOGLE SEARCHES AND
UNSUCCESSFUL VOLUNTARY INDUSTRY
REQUESTS TO GET INFORMATION ON
PRODUCT INGREDIENTS.
THE RESULT HAS BEEN LONG DELAYS
AND HESITATION SIX TO CONSIDER
ALL THE PRINCIPAL INGREDIENTS
MAKING A PRODUCT AND SAFE.
SB THREE NINE TO PROVIDE THE
DEPARTMENT CLEARER STRONGER DATA
COLLECTION AUTHORITY THE STILL
PRESERVES THE TRADE SECRET
PROTECTIONS ALREADY IN THE GREEN
CHEMISTRY.
THE SECOND ISSUE IS A LACK OF
DEADLINES AND CLEAR REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE PROGRAMS OUTLINED
TIMELINES FOR ACTION.
WHICH WOULD PROVIDE BUT
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE CURRENT THREE YEAR WORK
PLANS HAVE BEEN RATHER VAGUE
THEY'RE NOT SPECIFIC ENOUGH TO
BE MEANINGFUL AND THEY
FACILITATE THE LENGTHY DELAYS
THAT I'VE BEEN UNFORTUNATE
FEATURE THE PROGRAM SO FAR.
AND SB THREE NINE TWO WOULD
REQUIRE THE AGENCY TO DEVELOP A
WORK PLAN TO ADDRESS FIVE
PRODUCT CATEGORIES OR SUB
CATEGORIES IN FIVE YEARS.
INCLUDING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
TIMELINES FOR THE VARIOUS STEPS
IN THE PROCESS.
IT WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THE
CONSIDERATION OF ALL CHEMICALS
THAT SERVE THE SAME PURPOSE OR
FUNCTION TO ADDRESS THE
REGRETTABLE SUBSTITUTION.
THAT SENATOR ALLEN ALLUDED.
TO THESE MEASURES WILL PROVIDE
CLEARER PROCESS IN
ACCOUNTABILITY AND WILL ENSURE
THE PROGRAM DOESN'T HAVE TO
REVIEWS REVISIT THE PRODUCT A
FEW YEARS TIME -- THESE
IMPROVEMENTS WILL HELP WITH THE
NEED FOR BETTER PRIORITIZATION
TO THE PH I. REPORT OUTLINES.
A THIRD FACTOR IS THE CURRENT
LONG AND ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH OF EVALUATING
ALTERNATIVES TO THE CHEMICALS
BEING ADDRESSED.
CURRENTLY NEW COMPANY DRIVEN
ANALYSES ARE REQUIRED FOR EVERY
MANUFACTURER THAT PRODUCES A
PRODUCT UNDER CONSIDERATION
BEFORE THE AGENCY CAN ACT.
EVEN WHEN INFORMATION --
ALTERNATIVES AVAILABLE FOR
RELIABLE SOURCES.
INSTEAD FOLLOWING THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE PH I
REPORT.
WHEN SUCH INFORMATION IS
AVAILABLE AND ONLY THEN AS BE
THREE NINE TWO CREATES A FAST
TRACK OPTION THAT ALLOWS THE
AGENCY TO ACT MORE QUICKLY AND
DIRECTLY?
WHILE ENSURING THAT THERE IS
PUBLIC NOTICE AND AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT INCLUDING
FROM THE AFFECTED BUSINESSES.
THIS WILL SPEED UP THE PROCESS
BY TAKING ADVANTAGE OF WORK THAT
HAS ALREADY BEEN DONE.
IT COULD ALSO REDUCE THE BURDEN
ON FROM SMALL COMPANIES THAT --
MAY HAVE DIFFICULTY CONDUCTING
THEIR ALL ATTORNEYS ANALYSES AND
WOULD BE WOULD FACE A DRAIN ON
RESOURCES FROM THAT.
FINALLY SB THREE NINE TWO ALSO
INCLUDES PROVISIONS TO REMOVE
REDUNDANCIES IN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS AND TO
STREAMLINE THE PROGRAMS A
WORKLOAD THAT WILL ALSO HELP
IMPROVE THE PACE OF THE PROGRAM.
FOR ALL THESE REASONS WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB.
THREE NINE TWO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
A BILL ALLEY -- ENVIRONMENT
WORKING GROUP THE THIRD A CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL I JUST
WANNA POINT OUT WERE WORKING --
RAPIDLY WITH THE OPPONENTS TO
THE BILL I TO MAKE SURE THAT --
DETAILS ARE FINE TUNE IN WEEK A
COMPROMISE AS WELL AS WE CAN TO
KEEP THE BILL STRONG. ONE POINT
OUT AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY NINE
WHICH FORM THE PROGRAM IN -- TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT PASSED NEARLY
UNANIMOUSLY WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
IT'S OUR HOPE THAT THIS BILL
ALSO END UP WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT BECAUSE WERE CONSUMERS
COME FIRST YEAR AND WE SUPPORT
THE PROGRAM IS GOING TO SEE IT
THE MORE EFFICIENT THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF A SB.
THREE NINE TWO MELISSA ROMERO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
SUPPORT.
BILL MCGOVERN COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR SUPPORT.
BROWN MEDINA ON BEHALF OF BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS IN
SUPPORT.
MEDI BAKER PLANNING CONSERVATION
THE IN SUPPORT.
PERSONAL GET US ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
IN SUPPORT.
RENDON DOESN'T VEHICLE
CALIFORNIANS OR THREE SEPARATE
VERGE ON BEHALF OF THE LOCAL
DIRECTORS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH IN THE CLEAN SEIZE
LOBBYING COALITION IN SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION IF OPPOSITION TO COME
FORWARD.
THE MACHINE AT THE TABLE
[inaudible]
THIS IS.
GET AFTER A GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- TIM JUST IT WITH
THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL --
SURROUNDS KEEPING BUSY THE
SESSION -- YOU'RE KIDDING ME TO
REACH THE NEW JOB RATINGS I
THINK YOU THANK YOU SO -- WE WE
DO HAVE AN OPPOSED POSITION ON
THE BILL AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED I
I DO WANT TO THANK.
ERIC WALTERS AND SENT AROUND
STAFF OF FOR CAN BEING --
CONVERSATION YESTERDAY WITH THE
OPPONENTS OR THE PROPONENTS OF
THE BILL -- I'VE I WOULD
CHARACTERIZE AS A A VERY --
PRODUCTIVE DISCUSSION AND L. L.
IN IN LIGHTNING US ON SOME SOME
OF THE ISSUES THAT WE GET WE
HAVE RAISED SO. THREE POINT I I
JUST WANNA MAKE BRIEFLY ON THE A
A PROVISION THAT'S CURRENTLY IN
THE BILL -- WE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW THAT MIGHT BE
IMPLEMENTED -- WE'D LIKE TO SEE
SOME ADDITIONAL DETAIL ABOUT HOW.
PTSD WOULD RELY ON THAT
INFORMATION -- THAT MAYBE
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE TO SURE
INSURE THAT IT DOES MEET THE
SAME RIGOROUS CRITERIA THAT AN A
THAT WE WOULD PRODUCE AS A
RESPONSIBLE ENTITY FOR EXAMPLE.
WOULD HAVE TO MEET SO THAT'S ONE
AREA WHERE I THINK -- WE WE'D
LIKE TO WORK WITH -- CENTER
ALLEN ON ON DEVELOPING SOME
ADDITIONAL.
CRITERIA AROUND THAT AROUND HOW
THAT USED A SINGLE SHOE FOR THE
DATA CALLING PROVISION --
FRANKLY I THINK THIS COULD BE
HELPFUL FOR D. T. S. C. -- TO
MAKE MORE INFORMED DECISIONS
ABOUT WHICH PRODUCTS -- CHEMICAL
COMBINATIONS THEY MAY MAKE.
BUT AGAIN WE LIKE TO SEE SOME
CLARITY ON THAT PROCESS MAYBE
SOME TIME LINES OF HOW LONG -- A
RESPONSIBLE AND HE COULD HAVE TO
IN ORDER TO RIP TORESPOND TO
THOSE DATA CALL AND REQUEST MAKE
THEM REASONABLE -- WE YOU KNOW
IT.
SUGGESTIONS THAT WE MAY HAVE YOU
KNOW A WEEK OR TWO TO RESPOND TO
A DATA CALLING REQUIREMENT WE
WOULD PROBABLY FIND THAT
UNREASONABLE BUT SOME SORT OF
REASONABLE TIME FRAME -- WOULD
ALSO ENCOURAGE -- CENTER AROUND
THE SPONSORS TO LOOK AT SOME
EXISTING DATA CALLING AUTHORITY
THAT CALLIE PA HAS OF FOR AS A
POTENTIAL MODEL AT LEAST TO TO
TO TO MAYBE CONSIDER FOR FOR
THIS PARTICULAR BILL -- THE
THIRD POINT FOR TURNED OVER TO A
MISS KEPT HE IS -- THERE'S A
PROVISION EXPAND THE CANADA
CHEMICALS LISTS WERE REALLY SORT
OF UNCLEAR WHY THAT PROVISIONS
IN THERE AND WHETHER IT'S IT'S
EVEN NECESSARY -- THE DEPARTMENT
DOES HAVE EIGHT THE LIST OF
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED PLUS
CHEMICALS ON US CANADA HEMICALS
LIST.
IF THE INTENT IS TO EXPEDITE --
REVIEW AND MOVE THIS PROGRAM
ALONG WE THINK THERE CERTAINLY
UNIVERSE OF OF CHEMICALS TO
CHOOSE FROM -- THERE IS A
PETITION PROCESS AVAILABLE FOR
STAKEHOLDERS IF THEY THINK THE
DEPARTMENT SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
ADDITIONAL -- CANADA CHEMICALS --
THAT WOULD BE AN OPTION THAT --
FOLKS WHO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF SO I
GUESS THAT WE ARE STILL OPPOSE
THE BILL VISUALLY BUT LOOK FOR
THE WORKING ON THESE ISSUES AND
AND HOPEFULLY AT THE END OF THE
DAY.
COME COME SOME SORT OF
RESOLUTION SO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITIES COMMENTS.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS DON KHAKI ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION -- ALSO
SIMILARLY SITUATED ON AS MR
SZOSTAK OPPOSED CURRENTLY TO THE
CURRENT VERSION BILL OF IT
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD WITH
STAFF.
AS WELL AS OTHER PROPONENTS OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS A
SIMILAR -- COMMENTS -- TO TO
MISTER SUSPECTS IN TERMS OF
CONCERNS AROUND KIND OF THE A.
R. PROVISIONS IN THE BILL
CURRENTLY WANTING TO ENSURE THAT --
THAT THE INTENT AS WE'VE CONVEY
CONVERSED AND CHATTED WITH THE
PROPONENTS OF AND THEY'VE
INDICATED IS REALLY WERE MAKING
SURE THAT THIS IS AN APPLES TO
APPLES -- CONSIDERATION WHEN IT
COMES TO LOOKING OUT PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE GOVERNMENT RELATED --
ALTERNATIVES ANALYSIS --
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN KIND
OF BETTER CLARIFICATION AND KIND
OF REFINEMENT TO ENSURE THAT
WHEN WE'RE LOOKING OUT AND
CONSIDERING THOSE TYPES OF A A
SET OR NOT PERHAPS ARE CONDUCTED
BY THE MANUFACTURERS.
I THAT WERE CONSIDERING THE
TRADE OFFS AND AWAITING CRITERIA
THAT WENT INTO COMING TO THE
CONCLUSION OF THAT TO ENSURE
THAT IF YOU KNOW A PARTICULAR
PRODUCT CHEMICAL COMBINATION
THAT'S IN SCOPE UNDER DTS SEES
APPROACH.
I AM IS KIND OF SIMILAR IN
CONCEPT TO THE A A THAT WOULD BE
EVALUATED SO THAT WE'RE MAKING
SURE THAT OUR EVALUATING THE
VARIOUS TRADE OFFS YOU KNOW IF
THE PRODUCT TOXICITY IS THE
ISSUE FORTY TSC.
BUT ALTERNATIVES ON MAY BE KIND
OF FOCUSED MORE KIND OF AND
CONCERNING A RELATIVE TO HUMAN
HEALTH IMPACTS THERE WERE
CONSIDERING THOSE TYPES OF TRADE
OFFS ON AND TO AND WEEDING
FACTORS.
I'M ALSO WITH REGARD TO THE DATA
CALL AND WE WOULD ALSO -- JUST
ECHO AND THAT TOO I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WERE STRENGTHENING DAD
BUILDING UPON SOME AUTHORITIES
DO TO SEE ALREADY HAS.
AND MAKING SURE THAT RELATIVE TO
THAT UT IT'S REALLY CONFINED IN
AND KIND OF FOCUSED ON ON THOSE
PRIORITIES ON THAT PTC IS
FOCUSED ON IN AND AROUND THE
pJUST COME A BROAD FISHING
EXPEDITION A WITHOUT FOCUS AND
TRYING TO MOVE FORWARD ON THE
PRIORITIES AT HAND.
AB AND THEN FINALLY AGE WITH
REGARD TO THE CHEMICALS LIST WE
ALSO HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
EXPANSION OF THAT.
ARE CURRENTLY THE PROGRAM IS
LOOKING OUT TO ANA CHEMICALS
LISTS ARE THAT WILL EXCEED
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED CHEMICALS SO
TODAY NOT CAN EXTEND THAT WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PACE OF THE
PROGRAM.
ADDING ADDITIONAL CHEMICALS TO
THAT MIX TO KIND OF CONSIDER FOR
PRIVATIZATION YOU KNOW
POTENTIALLY COULD HAVE -- AND
EFFECTIVE ACTUALLY SLOWING DOWN
THAT BUT NONE THE LESS -- SEEMS
HE'S DEFINITELY COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS WOULD YOU
FEEL LIKE THAT THERE ARE SOME
OPPORTUNITIES AND A PATH FORWARD
ON A NUMBER OF THESE ISSUES SO
WITH THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER SUPPOSED -- TO
SB.
THREE NINETY GOOD MORNING NICOLE
CAN UNITS ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSEHOLD AND COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION AND THE
FRAGRANCE CREATORS ASSOCIATION
JUST -- ONE ASSOCIATE MY
CONCERNS WITH THOSE -- ALREADY
LISTED AND JUST PUT A FINER
POINT ON THE ADDITIONAL LESS ONE
OF THE ADDITIONAL LIST AS THE E.
U. FRAGRANCE ALLERGEN LESSON
THIS LIST WAS CREATED TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON LABELS FOR
CONSUMERS -- WE WERE CONCERNED
WITH THERMAL ALLERGIES AND THEY
DON'T BELIEVE IT -- RACES TO THE
SAME LEVEL OF HEALTH CONCERNS
THAT THAT THEY FOR CONSUMER
PRODUCTS PROGRAM WAS CREATED TO
ADDRESS SO I WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT LIST IN PARTICULAR BEEN
REMOVED THANK YOU.
TOM JACOB ON BEHALF OF THE
CHEMICAL INDUSTRY COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA -- OPPOSED WHERE --
THE REASONS OUTLINED AND I'D
ALSO I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO
CONVEY -- ON BEHALF OF ADAM
REGULAR OF THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WHO WAS CALLED AWAY --
ON UNEXPECTEDLY A FEW MOMENTS
AGO -- HIS CONCURRENCE WITH THE
OPPOSITION POSITION AS OUTLINED.
AND I'D LIKE TO SAY PERSONALLY --
I TOO WAS ENCOURAGED BY THE
CONVERSATION THAT WE HAD
YESTERDAY -- THAT WE MAY WELL BE
ABLE TO FIND SOME MORE COMMON
GROUND HERE THAN WE HAD FIRST
THOUGHT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ORINDA VALENCIA
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
PAINT COUNCIL IN THE AMERICAN
COATINGS ASSOCIATION WOULD ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS WITH THE C. C. AND
C. MTA -- I THINK OF SPECIFIC
FOR OUR OUR CONCERNS ARE
PROBABLY MORE AROUND THE A
LANGUAGE CURRENTLY BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO ENGAGE IN DISCUSSIONS
AND SEE IF THERE'S WAYS TO
REFINE SOME OF THAT LANGUAGE AND
I'M CONTINUE TO COMMIT TO
WORKING WITH THE OTHER STUFF
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING LARISSA SATURDAYS
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE TôI
ASSOCIATION WE ALIGN OURSELVES
WITH MISTER CYSTIC THAN MS KEPT
KEYS.
ARE COMMENTS REGARDING SB.
THIRTY THREE NINETY TWO ARE WE
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE SAFER
CONSUMER OF PRODUCTS PROGRAM --
BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR TO TRY
AND WORK OUT SOME OF THE DETAILS
AND I'D ALSO ARE HOPEFUL THAT
WE'LL BE ABLE TO DO THAT THANK
YOU.
RESEARCHER IF I COULD ALSO JUST
SAY MY APOLOGIES -- MANDY LIED
ON BEHALF OF THE PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COUNCIL AND WAS ALSO
PULLED AWAY SHE WANTED TO ALIGN
HERSELFAS WELL.
VERY GOOD LET'S RETURN IT BACK
TO THE DAIS -- QUESTION CENTER
STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
CERTAINLY WE WANT TO SEE -- SAFE
CONSUMER PRODUCTS OUT THERE
SENATOR ALLEN -- CUP JUST A
COUPLE QUESTIONS -- THIS WILL
ALLOW -- DTS HE TO USE THE
STUDIES THAT ARE OUT -- IN THE
COMMUNITY IF YOU WILL -- TO
EXPEDITE THE REVIEW -- OF
CHEMICALS -- HOW DO WE ENSURE
THAT -- WE'RE LOOKING AT PEER
REVIEWED NON BIASED STUDIES.
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION I MEAN I
I I I MEAN IT DOES SAY
SPECIFICALLY -- IF YOU LOOK AT
PAGE EIGHT OF THE BILL.
DID ANY ANNOUNCES THE DEPARTURE
LIES ON PRCEED SUBDIVISIONS OF
ISSUE BY GOVERNMENT AGENCY OR
CREDIBLE INSTITUTION WITH
RELEVANT EXPERTISE IN WITHOUT
FINANCIAL CONFLICTS OF INTEREST
OR PUBLISHED IN PEER REVIEWED
SCIENTIFIC LITERATURE SELF -- IT
IT IT LAYS OUT.
THOSE HIGH STANDARDS THAT
CERTAINLY.
IF YOU WANT.
TO STRENGTHEN THEM -- HAPPY TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
[inaudible]
YEAH.
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOUR MENTAL
THING IS ONE OF THE CONCERNS OF
ASSEMBLY MANUFACTURES YEAH --
AND THEN -- I THINK THAT THE
OPPONENTS OF BROUGHT UP A GOOD
POINT -- HERE WE HAD TEN YEARS
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED CHEMICALS
AND WE HAVEN'T HAD -- ONE
SIGNIFICANT REVIEW -- AND YET
YOU WANT NOW ADD MORE --
CHEMICALS TO THAT LIST WHICH IS
GONNA DILUTES THE REVIEW OF THE
EXISTING -- TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
ONE OF THE ONE OF THE UPPER
OPPONENTS MENTIONED THAT -- AN
ALLERGEN LESS FROM THE EUROPEAN
UNION HAS BEEN BEEN ADDED WHICH
MAY NOT RISE TO THE LEVEL THAT
THE TSC SHOULD BE REVIEWING
THOSE AT ALL.
SO THERE IS A CONCERN ABOUT THE
PACE OF THE PROGRAM CAN YOU CAN
YOU.
TALK ABOUT -- Y. EXPANDED THE
LIST AND WHY THESE ALLERGENS YOU
THINK ARE EFFICACIOUS TO BE
ADDED TO THE LIST.
I'LL LET ARMENIAN TO THE BOTH OF
YOU REALIZE THEY DON'T HAVE TO
REVIEW THE CHEMICALS AND THIS IS
JUST THIS YOU KNOW WE WOULD TALK
ABOUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND SO --
SO MIND CHEMICALS OF COMMERCE
ITSELF RIGHT IS A VERY SMALL
ADDITION IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT A
BROADER CONTEXT AND GRANT THEM
IT JUST IT JUST ADDS TO THE IF
YOU GIVE A LITTLE MORE THEY CAN
REVIEW.
BY ADOPTION I WE CAN.
YEAH.
AS A CENTER SAYS IT JUST ALLOWS
AND TO CONSIDER THE CHEMICALS
THAT DOESN'T REQUIRE THEM TO ACT
ON IT AND SO GIVES YOU MORE
CHOICE I THINK ABOUT IT BUT THE
ONLY PRIORITIZE CHEMICALS.
WHICH POSE A HEALTH RISK AND
THAT RISE TO THAT LEVEL SOME OF
THESE ALLERGENS CAN BE A AS A
RISKS AND SO RIGHT HAVING IT IN
THERE ARE LAWS AND TO CONSIDER
THOSE REST IF THEY RISE TO THAT
LEVEL BUT I DON'T HAVE TO DO
THAT.
OKAY BUT YOU'RE STILL EXPANDING
THE THE SCOPE OF WHAT THEY CAN
INVESTIGATE WHICH THEY CAN
CONSIDER TAKE AWAY FROM MAYBE
SOME OF THE MORE DANGEROUS
CHEMICALS WHICH IS A CONCERN.
I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S A RATING
SYSTEM AMONG THE CHEMICALS --
THAT MIGHT GUIDE THE DTS SEE TO
SPEND THE RESOURCES ARE
APPROPRIATELY NESSA'S BILL
CLINTON ANYMORE STAFF WELL I
THINK THAT THE TSC IS A DECK TO
AGENCY WITH EXPERTISE ON THIS
TOPIC AND THEY PRIORITIZE
INTERNALLY LA THAT PRIORITIZE
ASIAN OUT IN THE WORK PLANS THAT
THEY PUT TOGETHER.
AND SO THEY HAVE TO LAY OUT A
RATIONALE FOR WHY THEY'RE
DRESSING THE PARTICULAR SECTOR
CHEMICALS A PRODUCT THAT THEY
ARE AND IT WOULD HAVE TO DO THAT
SO -- WE WE THINK IT'S FAIRLY
UNLIKELY THAT THEY WOULD TAKE
SOMETHING THAT'S A MINOR HEALTH
CONCERN AND PUT IN THE WORK.
WE ALSO -- AND THEN LASTLY --
WHILE HAS BEEN DISCUSSED HERE
WAS DISCUSSING SOME OF THE
MEETINGS THAT HAVE A SOME OF THE
MANUFACTURERS CAN YOU -- TALK
ABOUT -- THE CONFIDENTIALITY OF
SOME OF THOSE INGREDIENTS THAT
ARE PROPRIETARY IN NATURE THAT
OBVIOUSLY THE YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
IF YOU GOT A PRODUCT I'M GONNA
THROW ANOTHER WD FORTY OKAY WELL
YOU KNOW.
I DON'T THINK THE PROPRIETORS OF
MANUFACTURES THAT PRODUCT ONE
OUT THE ACTIVE INGREDIENTS THAT
ARE OF THEIR PUBLICIZING MAYBE
SOMETHING IS VERY SIMPLE MAYBE
SOME A COMPLICATED.
BUT HOW DO WE PROTECT THE
MANUFACTURERS FROM SOME OF THEIR
THERE'S THEIR PROPER I REMEMBER
ONE NIGHT WHEN THIS BILL IS VERY
FIRST PITCH TO ME BY MY BY MY
STAFF MY FANTASTIC STAFFER HERE
TEAM THAT THAT WAS THE FIRST
QUESTION I ASKED HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE WE PROTECT.
ON A TRADE SECRETS AND AND
PREPARE TO INFORMATION AND THEY
HAVE A THEY BASICALLY HAVE A
SYSTEM IN PLACE I'M SURE ONE OF
THE ONE OF YOU GUYS CAN DESCRIBE
IT BUT IT.
GOVERNMENT ASKED.
FOR PROPRIETARY INFORMATION ALL
THE TIME -- AND THERE'S A STRICT
PROCEDURE IN PLACE TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT DOESN'T GET A SHARED AND
AND AND AND AND AND THAT THAT
THAT OF THE DOES TRADE SECRETS
ARE ARE NOT COMPROMISE BUT AND
IF YOU WANNA SPEAK.
YEAH JUST A ONE ONE QUICK
ADDITION THANK YOU SENATOR WHICH
IS THAT THEY'RE ALREADY TRADE
SECRET PROTECTIONS BUILT INTO
THE GREEN CHEMISTRY Là AND THEY
WILL CONTINUE TO APPLY TO THESE
PROVISIONS AND THAT.
WE HAVE BEEN VISION THAT THE
THAT WAY THROUGHOUT AND IF WE
WIN THIS ANY PROBLEMS IN THE
PAST -- ANY TRADE SECRETS BEING
WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING TO THAT
EFFECT AND OF COURSE GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES YOU KNOW THEY THEY
STILL GET INFORMATION AND THE
STILL HAVE TO KEEP THEM SECRET
AND THAT THE AGENT AGENCY WOULD
BE UNDER THAT RESPONSIBILITY --
AND WE THINK THEY'RE CAPABLE OF
MEETING THAT.
YOUR ANSWERS IF.
ETCETERA WE COULD YOU CLARIFY
THERE IS THE AMERICAN COVER
CHEMICALS ASSOCIATION --
TESTIFIED THAT THERE IS A
PROCESS FOR THE CHEMICALS OF
CONCERN ABOUT LIST TO BE
EXPANDED CLEARLY INDUSTRY
DOESN'T WANT TO BE NOBODY WANTS
TO BE ON THE LIST ARE PART.
OF WHATEVER IT IS SENT BACK BUT
CLARIFY WHAT THE IS IT IN
CUMBERSOME THE PROCESS THAT
EXIST RIGHT NOW TO EXPAND THE
LIST -- WITH THE UNDERSTANDING
THAT.
THIS PROGRAM WAS NEVER DESIGNED
FOR ALL TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
CHEMICALS TO GO FOR THE REVIEW
PROCESS SO THAT'S SAID SO THAT'S
THAT BUT THAT BUT GIVEN THE
CURRENT PROCESS THAT THEY HAVE
FOR FOR OPTING IN.
WHAT'S THE SHORTCOMINGS OF THAT
THAT THAT WE WANT TO GIVE THE
DETAILS SEE THE AUTHORITY.
WELL I I I I MEAN I I THINK THAT
THIS THE CURRENT SHORTCOMINGS
ARE THE I WELL I I THINK I WILL
BASICALLY WHAT WE'RE DID YOU SEE
THERE THE SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS
RIGHT.
AND THEY CAN'T POSSIBLY
INVESTIGATE EVERY SINGLE
CHEMICAL WITH THE LEVEL OF
SCRUTINY I THINK THAT.
SOME OF US WOULD -- WOULD HOPE
THAT THEY ARE BUT THEY'RE
THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO THEY'RE NOT GOING TO DO
IT.
BUT WE WANT WE CERTAINLY WANT TO
GIVE THAT THEY NEED TO GO
THROUGH THEIR OWN PRIVATIZATION
INTERNALLY AND THEY DO.
THAT THE THE THE FOCUS ON THE
CHEMICALS THAT ARE MOST
CONCERNED ABOUT BUT WE CERTAINLY
HAVE FELTAS THOUGH THE LIST OF
CHEMICALS THAT WE'VE ADDED THAT
HAVE RAISED CONCERNS OTHER
PLACES -- YOU KNOW ARE ARE
WORTHY OF OF ELIGIBILITY FOR
CONSIDERATION BY THE TNC -- BUT
ONCE AGAIN THAT IT DOES NOT SAY
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH
THE KIND OF ROBUST ANNOUNCES
THAT I THINK A LOT OF CONSUMERS
EXPECTED THEY'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH -- BUT IT DOES IT DOES
GIVE.
ITGIVES IT GIVES THEM THE RIGHT
TO TO DO THE INVESTIGATION --
THAT THEY WOULD FIND A SORRY IF
THEY IF THEY FOUND IT NECESSARY
THAT.
OKAY YES CENTER SKINNER.
OKAY.
THANK YOU -- I APPRECIATE BUT
ADDING TO THE LIST BECAUSE AS
YOU POINTED OUT.
AS THE AUTHOR POINTED OUT IT
DOESN'T REQUIRE THE DTS SEE.
TO BUT IT ALLOWS THEM TO NOT
HAVE TO GO THROUGH ADDITIONAL
PROCESS SEES.
TO ADD AND I THINK THE
IMPORTANCE OF THAT IS THAT NEW
RESEARCH.
COMES FORWARD ALL THE TIME NOW
WHILE -- WHILE OUR GREEN
CHEMISTRY PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE
ROUNDUP WAS CONSIDERED VERY SAFE
UP UNTIL MAYBE TWELVE FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO WHEN RESEARCH BEGAN TO
SHOW -- A GOOD AMOUNT OF
INDICATORS THAT OULD CAUSE
PEOPLE TO REASSESS IT AND
FURTHER MANY MORE STUDIES DUE TO
OCCUR SINCE THAT TIME.
SIMILARLY IF WE TAKE -- BPA
WHILE WE OF WELL THERE'S BEEN A
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF ITS --
PROBLEMS OF LEACHING INTO FOOD
FOR EXAMPLE IN IT AS FOR USE AS
A HAND ALIGNING IN CANS.
AND FOOD CANS AND IN BABY
BOTTLES THERE WAS LITTLE TO NO
CONCERN ABOUT THE FACT THAT.
OUR THE RECEIPTS THAT COME OFF
OF THE HEAT.
BASICALLY WHEN USE YOUR CREDIT
CARD NOW PRETTY MCH ALL
RECEIPTS ARE PRODUCED THROUGH UP
HE PROCESS AND THAT REQUIRES THE
BPA AND WHAT IS NOW RESEARCH IS
NO SHOWN.
THAT THAT IS THEN TRANSFERRED TO
YOUR SKIN THE LARGEST ORGAN OF
YOUR BODY AND YOU CAN'T HAVE
IMPLICATIONS BUT FURTHER.
FURTHER WHICH IS VERY
INTERESTING IS THAT THE BPA OFF
THOSE RECEIPTS COMBINED WITH IF
YOU USE HAND SANITIZER.
EXACERBATES THE THE ARE
HAZARDOUS -- IMPACTS OF THE BPA
ON ON YOUR PHYSIOLOGY ANYWAY SO
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT.
ALRIGHT WE CAN'T EXPECT ONE A
SINGLE STATE AGENCY TO BE ABLE
TO COMPREHENSIVELY STUDY.
BUT IF THERE IS LEGITIMATE
SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH -- THEN IT
ALLOWS DTS SEE TO ELEVATE THAT
PARTICULAR CHEMICAL AND BEGIN TO
GO THROUGH THEIR PROCESS -- AND
ALLOWS THEM TO RELY ON GOOD
SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH SO.
I I THINK THE BILL IS GOING IN A
VERY GOOD DIRECTION.
I DO THINK THAT WE WANT TO MAKE
AS SOLID AS POSSIBLE THE ANY
LANGUAGE THAT REFERENCES THE
STUDIES WOULD RELY ON BECAUSE WE
WANT TO KNOW THAT THOSE STUDIES
ARE VALID.
SO AND I AM GOING TO TRUST THAT
THE AUTHORS HEARD.
BOTH THE COMMITTEE'S CONCERNS
AND THE OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THAT LANGUAGE -- IN WITH THAT I
WILL -- MOVED THE BILL.
MEASURES BEEN MOVED.
YOU MAY CLOSE SENATOR ALAN WHAT
BRUSCHI THE QUESTIONS AND AND
AND I DO APPRECIATE THE THE
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATION THAT.
MY STAFF HAD WITH WITH SOME
FOLKS WHO HAD CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL YESTERDAY AND I ANTICIPATE
THIS IS GOING TO MOVE FORWARD IN
A IN IN THE RENO WHEN THAT
SPIRIT AND I THINK CON THAT THE
REPORT THAT WE ALLUDED TO THE
HEARING THAT WE TALKED.
THAT WE ALL ATTENDED I RAISE
SOME SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT THE
EXTENT TO WHICH OUR CURRENT.
GREEN CHEMISTRY PROGRAM IS
MEETING THE GOALS THAT WERE LAID
OUT TEN YEARS AGO AND IN AB.
EIGHTEEN NINETY SEVEN AND WE
JUST TRY TO MEET THOSE GOALS
WE'RE TRYING WE'RE TRYING TO
WE'RE TRYING.
TO ADDRESS THE THE THE THE THE
REASONS FOR THAT HAVING BEEN
PASSED IN THE FIRST PLACE TO DO
SO IN A WAY THAT.
THAT WORKS FOR CONSUMERS AND AND
AND WHAT WE'RE VERY COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH INDUSTRY TO TO GET
THERE.
AND SO WITH THAT I RESPECT AS
FRONT OF A ASSISTANCE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER NINE SB THREE NINETY
TWO MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BATES.
HILL -- FILL AYE SKINNER HI
SKINNER AYE STERN.
STERN AYE STONE.
NO NO Y. CASKEY HI MY CASKET I
THAT.
FIVE ONE IT IS NOT HERE WILL
KEEP THE MATTER OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND LET'S CALLS.
MAJORITY LEADER HERTZBERG UP
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN SB THREE THREE TWO AND
I'LL RETURN THE GAVEL TO THE
CHAIR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR A ABLE
TEARING MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THIS --
WILL TURN BACK TO OUR MAJORITY
LEADER HOW WOULD HOW IS YOUR
VOTES.
THE GOVERNMENTS OF FINANCE
CENTER DALY.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW ANNOUNCED MY
CANDIDACY FOR PRESIDENCY IN THAT
COMMITTEE BECAUSE THEIR PEAK --
THAT REPRESENTS LESS PEOPLE THAN
VAN NUYS I REPRESENT VAN I SAY
FIGURE WHAT THE HECK YEAH.
THOUGH IN A LOW.
EVERYONE WHO THE BETTER WE WILL
GO OVER THE GASKETS THAT.
WE MAY PERCEIVE THAT ON SB THREE
THIRTY TWO THIS IS A SMALL
SIMPLE BILL.
YES MUCH OF THE BILL.
SO IN YEARS AGO WHEN -- SENATOR
BYRON SHEER WAS STAFFED BY
SENATOR KIP LIPPER.
THAT WE ALL KNOW.
FARM THEY CAME UP WITH THIS IDEA
OF A RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO
STANDARD TO DEAL WITH ENERGY IN
OTHER WORDS AS A POLICY MATTER.
HOW DO WE START MOVING IN THE
ENERGY FIELD WITHOUT PICKING
WINNERS OR LOSERS BUT IS A STATE
POLICY TO ADOPT A RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO STANDARD THAT WAS 20%?
NOW IT'S 2000% BUT THAT'S HOW
POLITICS WORKS.
AND SO IN THE FIELD OF WHAT HER
WHICH IS AS IMPORTANT I WOULD
ARGUE EVEN MORE IMPORTANT.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE IS
INSTEAD OF TREATING WATER AS
WASTE ONE TIME USE?
BUT TO LITERALLY CREATED OUR PS.
FOR WATER IT'S VERY SIMILAR KIND
OF DYNAMIC WE'RE SAYING BY
JANUARY 1203050% OF THIS WATER
GOING ARE THESE WASTE WATER
FACILITIES HAS TO BE RECYCLED.
NOW WHAT DOES THAT EAN WHAT
HAPPENS NOW IS IN THE FEDERAL
LAW.
WE BASICALLY IN LARGE MEASURE IN
THE AREA THAT I'M FROM IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA -- STICK A
STRONG THE CALLER RIVER WE STICK
A STRAW NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WE
USE THE WATER ONCE WE HAVE TO
CLEAN IT UP TO FEDERAL STANDARDS
BEFORE WE PUT IN THE OCEAN.
AND THEN WE PUT IN THE OCEAN.
WE PUT IN THE OCEAN LOS ANGELES.
ALMOST AS MUCH WATER AS WE
IMPORT. FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND ACRE FEET.
WHY CAN'T WE TAKE THAT WATER
THAT GOES TO THOSE FACILITIES IS
ALREADY CLEANED UP AND RECYCLING
THE MAYOR OF LOS ANGELES SAYS
WITH A LARGE FACILITY IN LOS
ANGELES HYPERION?
HE'S GOING TO DO THAT.
OKAY THAT'S GOOD.
THERE'S A STATE POLICY WHY CAN'T
WE BEGIN TO TREAT WATER IS A
PRECIOUS RESOURCE.
SUPPORT AND FIRST BECAUSE IT IS.
IT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL CONTEXT WERE
STEALING WATER FROM THE
ENVIRONMENT IN MANY PLACES AND
JUST DUMP IT IN THE OCEAN -- IN
WE'RE DOING THAT POLITICALLY
WORD THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
PEOPLE ON THIS COMMITTEE OR
PISSED AT US.
OFTEN BECAUSE WE'RE STILL IN
WATER AND DISRESPECTED PEOPLE
FROM IMPERIAL IRRIGATION
DISTRICT ACOSTA COASTAL CENTER
PISSED AT US.
WE NEED TO BE RESPONSIBLE WE
NEED TO TREAT WATER WITH GREAT
RESPECT AND WE CAN DO IT THE
TECHNOLOGY ALLOWS US TO DO IT.
THERE'S A LOT OF MOVEMENT
FORWARD TO IT.
THERE'S OVER A MILLION AND A
HALF ACRE FEET OF WATERTHE GUNS
DUMPED IN THE ALL BILL OCEAN
ANNUAL BASIS FROM THESE VARIOUS
FACILITIES.
AND WE CAN DRAMATICALLY SHIFT
HOW WE DEAL WITH WATER POLICY SO
WHAT WE'VE DONE IN THIS MEASURES
JUST TAKE THAT FIRST STEP LIKE
SENATOR.
SHEERAN SENATOR LIPPER DID BACK
THEN -- YOU KNOW AND SAY WE'RE
GOING TO SET THESE STANDARDS.
A IN IN TERMS OF THAT POCESS
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IN THIS BILL I DID A BILL A FEW
YEARS AGO JUST TO GET READY TO
AREA THAT SAID YOU COULDN'T PUT
WATER IN THE OCEAN.
I JUST DID IT ON PURPOSE TO MAKE
A LOT OF NOISE AND NOW THIS YEAR
IS SEPARATE WHERE I THINK IT
REALLY MAKES SOME SENSE.
AND I KNOW THAT THIS ONE SIZE
FITS ALL THOSE GREAT SOME-PROBLEMS FOR FOLKS.
BUT IT IS VERY SIMILAR TO THE
BATES.
ARTICLE CASKEY SAID IT IS VERY
SIMILAR. TO THE WAY WE HAD MANY
YEARS AGO ON OUR PS AND SO WITH
THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER TO THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERTS ON THIS
SIZE ONE TO FRAME IT OUT FOR
EVERYBODY THAT'S WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IN THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU YES SENATOR HI GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS TRACY
CLAN I AM A LICENSED CIVIL
ENGINEER AND CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR
OF WATER EFFICIENCY FOR THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL.
I AM PLEASED TO BE HERE IS CO
SPONSOR TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION FROM
SENATOR HERTZBERG AND SENATOR
WIENER.
EVERY DAY IN CALIFORNIA WE DUMP
OVER ONE BILLION GALLONS OF
TREATED WASTEWATER INTO OUR
OCEANS AND BASS.
WATER THAT COULD OTHERWISE BE
PUT TO BENEFICIALLY USED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES PROVIDING LOCAL
RELIABILITY AND LOCAL JOBS.
RECYCLING WATER THAT IS
CURRENTLY WASTED COULD ALSO HELP
OFFSET UNSUSTAINABLE DIVERSIONS
FROM OUR RIVERS THAT THREATENED
SALMON RUNS AND THOUSANDS OF
FISHING JOBS.
IT'S CRUCIAL THAT WE HOLD OUR
WATER AND WASTEWATER UTILITIES
TO THE GOALS WE'VE ESTABLISHED
IN THE CALIFORNIA RECYCLED WATER
POLICY.
SO THAT WE CAN SUSTAIN THE
LONGER AND MORE FREQUENT
DROUGHTS WE WILL SEE WITH
CLIMATE CHANGE.
OVER THE FALL AND RTC MET WITH
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING CASA AND
WATER REUSE TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
CONCERNS WITH PREVIOUS EFFORTS
TO SET REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
RECYCLING OF OCEAN DISCHARGE.
MY TO TAKE AWAYS FROM THOSE
CONVERSATIONS.
WHERE THAT ANY FUTURE EFFORT
SHOULD -- PUT RESPONSIBILITY TO
MEET REQUIREMENTS -- ON BOTH
WATER AND WASTE WATER AGENCIES
BECAUSE IMPLEMENTATION WILL
REQUIRE PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
THOSE THOSE FOLKS.
AND SECOND THAT THERE SHOULD BE
CREDITS FOR CONSERVATION AND
EFFICIENCY.
WITH THAT IN MIND WE WORKED WITH
SENATOR HERTZBERG AND HIS STAFF
AND FOCUSED ON AN APPROACH THAT
ADDRESSES THOSE CONCERNS.
SPECIFICALLY TO DO SO THE BILL
WOULD OF BASS COMPLIANCE ON A
REDUCTION OF EFFLUENT DISCHARGED
AS OPPOSED TO A VOLUME OF WATER
RECYCLED TOOK KNOWLEDGE THAT
REDUCTIONS IN AFFLUENT CAN BE
ACHIEVED BY CONSERVATION.
EFFICIENCY ONSITE REDUCE SEWER
SCALPING WHERE YOU DIVERT WASTE
WATER UP FROM A COLLECTION
SYSTEM UPSTREAM OF A CENTRALIZED
PLANT FOR USE AT A DISTRICT OR
NEIGHBORHOODS SCALE.
OR RECYCLING AT THE WASTE WATER
TREATMENT FACILITY.
THIS BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE A
PLANNING REPORTING BY WATER AND
WE START AGENCIES TOGETHER AND
PROVIDE FOR ENFORCEMENT AT ON
BOTH TYPES OF AGENCIES.
WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE BILL IS
INTRODUCED REQUIRE SOME
ADDITIONAL WORK AND HAVE BEEN
ENGAGING WITH STAKEHOLDERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
MANY OF WHOM ARE HERE INCLUDING
CASA AQUA CMU WAY IRVINE RANCH
WATER DISTRICT SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION THE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT THE
CITY OF LA.
AND OTHERS TO IDENTIFY AREAS
THAT REQUIRE FURTHER DISCUSSION.
THREES CONVERSATIONS WE HAVE
FOUND THAT CLARIFICATION OF THE
BILL'S INTENT.
BUT YOU CAN SERVE OR REUSE THE
WASTE WATER FLOWS WHILE ALLOWING
AND PS PERMIT TO USE TO CONTINUE
TO DISCHARGE SUFFICIENT VOLUMES.
TO MEET THE WATER QUALITY
OBJECTIVES IN THEIR PERMITS --
MAY GO A LONG WAY TOWARD EASING
SOME OF THE CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
EXPRESSED.
WE APPRECIATE THE THOUGHTFUL
BILL ANALYSIS FROM THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND ARE COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
ADDRESS CHALLENGES.
WE ASK THAT YOU PASS SB THREE
THIRTY TWO OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
SO WE CONTINUE CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS COMMITTEE
STAFF.
AND THE AUTHORS TO CONFESS TO
ENSURE THAT BILL IS CLEAR ABOUT
OUR INTENTIONS AND SET AMBITIOUS
YET ACHIEVABLE GOALS THAT ALIGN
WITH EXISTING STATE POLICY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YES SIR WHEN CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND SHAUN
BOTTLE IN THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR CALIFORNIA BECAUSE KEEPER
LANCE -- HOURS ASIAN IS A REALLY
LONG HISTORY ABOUT IT OVER
DECADE HISTORY OF WORKING ON
RECYCLED WATER ISSUES -- WE'VE
BEEN ON EVERY ADVISORY PANEL
THAT'S BEEN PUT FORTH BY THE
STATE WATER BOARD ON THE SECOND
WATER POLICY FOR MONITORING FOR
UC CONSTITUENTS EMERGING CONCERN --
WE'VE BEEN AT THE TABLE FOR
EVERY MAJOR ROCK WATER CYCLING
BILL THAT'S BEEN PUT FORWARD IN
THE LAST TEN YEARS AND EVERY
GENERAL PERMIT AT THE STATE
WATER BOARD -- WE'VE BEEN THERE
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
STATE WATER BOARD TO ENSURE A
WATER QUALITY WHILE PROMOTING OF
RECYCLED WATER.
AND SO NGUYEN THE BILL THAT
CENTER HERTZBERG -- I MENTIONED
EARLIER WAS WAS INTRODUCED IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WE WERE
ASKED -- INVITED DOWN IT'S ON
CALIFORNIA TO TO TALK WITH --
FOLKS THAT HAD CONCERNS OVER
WHAT THEIR ISSUES WERE WITH THIS
BILL IT'S VERY SIMILAR -- AND IN
WHAT WE HEARD WAS WE WE WANT TO
GET THERE WE WANNA GET WHERE THE
BILL'S GOING -- BUT WE NEED A
BRIDGE TO GET THERE THAT RIGHT
NOW WE DON'T HAVE THE
REGULATIONS IN PLACE AND THIS
BILL WOULD FORCE PURPLE PIPE
TYPE PROJECTS AND TO BE HONEST
THAT THAT.
DID GIVE OUR ORGANIZATION
CONCERNED WE DON'T WANNA BE
FORCING PURPLE BY TECH PROJECTS.
TO THE FOLLOWING YEAR WE WE
ACTUALLY -- TEAMED UP WITH THE
INDUSTRY WATER WE USE -- TO
INTRODUCE AB FIVE SEVENTY FOUR
BY QUIRK OTHER WAS PASSED
REQUIRES THE WATER BOARD TO DO
DRUG PORTABLE REDUCE REGULATIONS
AND THAT IN OUR MIND IS THE
BRIDGE THAT THE STATE NEEDS TO
BE ABLE. TO TO MAKE THIS BILL
THESE ONES AND SHE THE GOALS
THAT ARE ARE IN SB.
THREE THREE TO US SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE STATE WATER
BOARDS ALSO PASSED THE SURFACE
WATER OR RESERVOIR WATER
AUGMENTATION REGULATIONS TO
ALLOW COMMUNITIES THAT MIGHT NOT
HAVE A GROUNDWATER BASIN SAN
DIEGO FOR EXAMPLE -- TO BE ABLE
TO PUT THAT STORE THAT WATER IN
IN A RESERVOIR RATHER THAN I'M
NOT HAVE AN EXCUSE FOR NOT
HAVING GROUNDWATER BASIN.
I THEN JUST LAST YEAR -- I
ACTUALLY WENT TO A VERY SIMILAR
PROCESS WITH WITH SOME OF THE
CONCERNS -- IS RECYCLED WATER
POLICY WAS BEING REVISED I I I
GOT INTO THE THE POLICY A
STATEWIDE GOAL THAT WE RECYCLE
ALL DRY WEATHER FLOWS.
OF PROMOTION WAS WATER DISCHARGE
IS VERY SIMILAR TO THE LANGUAGE.
HERE IN THIS BILL AND THE
OPPOSITION AND THE CONCERNS THAT --
WE'RE HEARING NOW -- I HEARD
LAST YEAR AND WE FOUND WAYS TO
TO COME TO AGREEMENT AND AND AND
COME NO COMPROMISE LANGUAGE IN
THAT IN THAT POLICY LANGUAGE IT
WAS ADOPTED LAST YEAR AND I'VE
I'VE FAITHFUL THAT WE CAN DO THE
SAME HERE AND WORK WITH -- THE
FOLKS THAT DO HAVE CONCERNS THAT
WE CAN DRESS THE MAKE THIS BILL
FEASIBLE -- AND WE ASKED ABOUT
THANK YOU.
TURKISH OTTOMAN THE THOUGHT
BECAUSE I I JUST WANT THE SPIRIT
OF THIS DISCUSSION WHICH I I
WANT TO BE PART OF THIS BEFORE
THE ARMY PEOPLE COME UP HERE AND
TELL ME.
YOU KNOW SING SWISS CHEESE IS
THAT IS THAT LOOK THIS IS THAT
WE ARE WILLING WE WE GET THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF CHALLENGES WE
GET LIKE SAN DIEGO IN SOME OF
THE ISSUES THE SAN FRANCISCO THE
ONE SIZE.
FITS ALL WE ALSO KNOW THAT THIS
PAST DECEMBER THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD ADOPTED
RECYCLING WATER POLICY WE ARE
MOVING IN THIS DIRECTION THERE
IS COMPLEXITY TO IT WE
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE WHERE WE ARE
AS A POINT OUT THE ANALYSIS.
IS GOING TO BE A LOT OF HOMEWORK
THIS GOING TO BE REQUIRED TO GET
THIS THING RIGHT WE GET IT WE'RE
COMMITTED TO DO WHAT.
AND AS PEOPLE COME IN TO TALK
ABOUT IT -- WE OUGHT WITH A
STANDARD IS GOING TO REQUIRE
THAT THAT HOMEWORK BUT IT REALLY
IS I THINK ABOUT TAKING IN
MAKING A REALLY STRONG STATEMENT
AS A GOVERNMENT IN CALIFORNIA'S
LEGISLATURE.
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT HOMEWORK
ON THE AND AND IT UP THIS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD.
AS WE HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
REINVENT OVER THE LAST NUMBER
YEARS WITH THAT THE TERMINAL
WATER COMMITTEE HERE OUR POLICY
WITH.
RECYCLING CONSERVATION DE SAO
STORM WATER WATER MARKETS WATER
QUALITY REALLY TRYING TO TAKE
THE NEXT STEP IN THIS WHOLE
WATER POLICY PIECE AND SO DO YOU
THINK THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
STEP IN THE LARGER MEASURES
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR INDULGING
ME AYE SUPPLEMENT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YOU.
OKAY I OTHER FOLKS WANT TO WIN
SUPPORT.
OF THE BILL. THREE SEPARATE
VERGE ON HAVE SERIES IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU BIGGER PLAYING
CONSERVATION THE CAN SUPPORT.
ANDREA OF INTER WITH CLEAN WATER
ACTION SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT --
ACOSTA WITH FRIENDS THE RIVER
STRONG SUPPORT.
MIKE MOLLY CAN BE AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BY CHRIS
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
ANALYSTS IMHO WITH KILL THE BAY
AND SUPPORT.
RUNNING ALSO IS HERE CLUB IN
SUPPORT.
NUMBER THE ONLY BOND VOLUNTEER
FOR FRIENDS OF THE RIVER IN
SUPPORT.
THE OBVIOUS SOLUTION ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES I'M
ACTUALLY HERE AT NIGHT WIENER
POSITION SO I HOPE IS THE
APPROPRIATE TIME -- THE CITY
SUPPORTS A STRONG LOCAL RECITE A
RECYCLING GOALS AND WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH CENTER HERTZBERG
AND THE BILL'S SPONSORS AND OUR
DC. TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN FIND A
PATH FORWARD ON THE BILL THAT
WILL LINE AT LEAST COMMITMENT TO
RECYCLE 1100% OF ITS WASTE WATER
BY.
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE WITH THE
GOALS OF THE BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU OF OPPOSITION TRUCKS
ONE RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
GOOD MORNING -- MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS THAN JUST COOK AUGER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SANITATION AGENCY.
AGENCIES HERE TODAY
UNFORTUNATELY IN OPPOSITION. TO
SB THREE THIRTY TWO ALTHOUGH I
DO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT I
APPRECIATE THE ENTHUSIASM THAT
THE SENATOR SHOWING FOR WATER
POLICY TODAY -- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT BEFORE I
GET AT TO STARTED HERE THAT THE
THE BILL WE'RE TALKING A LOT
ABOUT GOALS UP HERE RIGHT NOW
BUT THE BILL THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY IS A MANDATE SO.
THIS IS A MANDATED REDUCTION ON
ALL A WASTE WATER DISCHARGERS BY
A 50% REDUCTION BY TWENTY THIRTY
AND THEN A 95% REDUCTION.
BY TWENTY FORTY SO -- YOU KNOW
WE BELIEVE THAT THE BILLS WELL
INTENDED BUT IN THE CURRENT FORM
IS UNWORKABLE FOR MANY REASONS.
THE VOLUME OF WATER WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS IMMENSE THIS IS
NOT A SCENARIO THAT WOULD ALLOW
AGENCIES TO BUILD OUT A FEW MORE
PURPLE PIPE SYSTEMS. FOR
LANDSCAPE IRRIGATION OR YOU KNOW
OTHER ALLOWABLE USES THE VOLUME
OF WATER WOULD NECESSARILY
REQUIRE LARGE SCALE RECYCLING.
AND MOVING MASS QUANTITIES OF
WATER TO STORAGE FOR RE USE SO
SING EITHER A GROUNDWATER APPLE
FOR A RESERVOIR PIPING IT
DIRECTLY INTO A DRINKING WATER
SYSTEM -- KEY COMPONENTS OF THE
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK FOR
AGENCIES TO BE ABLE TO PURSUE
THOSE TYPES OF STORAGE AND
REDUCE OPTIONS ARE NOT YET IN
PLACE AND THE WATER BOARD'S NOT
REQUIRED TO DEVELOP.
THE RAW WATER AUGMENTATION
REGULATIONS UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
THREE AND AT THIS POINT THERE'S
NO DEADLINE A REQUIREMENT FOR
THEM TO DEVELOP THE TREATED
DRINKING WATER AUGMENTATION RATE
REGULATIONS.
CALIFORNIA WATER AND WASTEWATER
AGENCIES ARE THE FOR FUN OF
WATER RECYCLING ON THE WORLD
WIDE SCALE AND MANY OF OUR
MEMBER AGENCIES ARE VOLUNTARILY
DOING SOME OF THE MOST.
PROGRESSIVE AN AMBITIOUS
PROJECTS AND THE COUNTRY AND
JUST TO PUT THIS PROPOSAL
PROPOSAL IN PERSPECTIVE FOR A
MOMENT.
NONE OF THE PROJECT UNDER WAY IN
CALIFORNIA WHEN AT THEIR FULL
OPERATIONAL CAPACITY -- WOULD BE
ABLE TO MEET THE MANDATED
REDUCTION SET FORTH IN THIS BILL.
I'D ALSO POINT OUT THAT MANY OF
THESE BIG PROJECTS AROUND TWENTY
TO THIRTY YEAR PROJECT SCHEDULES
AND WOULDN'T RECEIVE ANY CREDIT
FOR THE PROGRESS THAT THEY'VE
ALREADY MADE BOTH FOR
CONSERVATION AND FOR RECYCLING.
THERE ARE VAST REGIONAL
VARIATIONS AND HOW WATER IS
MANAGED IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
BILL MAKES NO CONCESSIONS FOR
AGENCIES THAT HAVE LEGITIMATE
LOGISTICAL CHALLENGES. FOR RE
USING THIS VOLUME OF WATER IN
SOME PLACES THERE JUST IS NOT A
STORAGE OPTION AND THE MANDATE
WOULD MEAN.
MOVING LARGE QUANTITIES OF WATER
FOR EXAMPLE OVER A MOUNTAIN
RANGE TO SECURE ADEQUATE STORAGE
THE GHG IMPACTS AND ENERGY
DEMANDS FOR LARGE SCALE
TREATMENT.
AND TRANSPORT OF A WATER PROJECT
LIKE THAT ARE CONSIDERABLE --
WASTEWATER DISCHARGES ARE ALSO
NECESSARY FOR BRIAN MANAGEMENT
IN CALIFORNIA AND A CERTAIN
VOLUME OF AFFLUENT LEVEL OF
DILUTION IS REQUIRED BY THE
WATER BOARD AN EPA. TO MANAGE
THAT WASTE BYPRODUCT OF THE
TREATMENT PROCESS AND IN MANY
PLACES ESPECIALLY WIRE REGION'S
THERE SIMPLY ISN'T THE DEMAND OR
MARKET FOR THIS MUCH ADDITIONAL
WATER.
PARTICULARLY DURING THE RAINY
SEASON.
THESE ARE JUST A SMALL SUBSET OF
TECHNICAL ISSUES RAISED BY OUR
MEMBER AGENCIES AND THERE ARE
MANY MORE THAT VERY BY AGENCY
AND BY REGION -- FINALLY WHAT
THE TECHNICAL ISSUES ASIDE I
WANT TO BRING UP THE ISSUE OF
COST AND AFFORDABILITY OF WATER
SERVICE IN CALIFORNIA.
OUR AGENCIES ARE ESTIMATING THAT
THIS BILL WOULD RESULT IN MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS ON AN AGENCY BY AGENCY
BASIS.
THE RESULTING RATE IMPACTS WOULD
BE STAGGERING AGENCIES ARE
TELLING US THEY BE LOOKING AT
RATE INCREASES OF SEVERAL
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER HOUSEHOLD.
AND BECAUSE WE'RE
CONSTITUTIONALLY REQUIRED TO
ASSESS PROPORTIONAL UNFAIR FEES
THOSE IMPACTS R. COSTA SYSTEM.
AND INCLUDE ALL IMPACTED RATE
PAYERS INCLUDING BUSINESSES AND
DUSTY ON COMMERCIAL CUSTOMERS
AND INCLUDING EVEN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT WE DON'T IS TO DISAGREE
WITH THE INTENT OF THE BILL
WHICH IS I THINK TO FIND A WAY
TO MAXIMIZE THE BENEFITS OVER
USE OF WATER IN CALIFORNIA.
UNFORTUNATELY THE WAY THE BILL
PROPOSES ACHIEVING THAT ANGLE IS
PUNITIVE AND IT DOESN'T
RECOGNIZE THE TECHNICAL
REALITIES AND REGIONAL
DIFFERENCES IN WATER MANAGEMENT.
WE APPRECIATE THE TEARING
COMMITTEE STAFFER HEARING OUR
CONCERNS OVER THE LAST FEW WEEKS
AND ALSO THE RECOMMENDATION AND
THE ANALYSIS.
TO CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS -- MOVING
FORWARD WE THINK IT'S NECESSARY
TO RE FRAME THIS LEGISLATION TO
MOVE AWAY FROM SETTING MANDATED
REDUCTIONS ON WASTEWATER
DISCHARGES AND INSTEAD SHIFTING
THE FOCUS TO MAXIMIZING
BENEFICIAL REUSE.
BY ADDRESSING EXISTING BARRIERS
TO ACHIEVING THAT ANGLE SO FOR
THESE REASONS WERE OPPOSED AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THE CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR
IN COMMITTEE AND HOPEFULLY
FINDING A RESOLUTION FOR OUR
CONCERNS [inaudible]
IN CERTAIN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ASKING US ON BEHALF
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO
THE BILL ALTHOUGH WE DON'T THINK
IT'S SWISS CHEESE NECESSARILY --
WE REPRESENT OVER FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES MANY
OF WHICH HAVE ALREADY MADE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS -- ON ON
PORTABLE AND NON POTABLE REUSE
PROJECTS SO TO BE CLEAR WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF INCENTIVIZING THE
BENEFICIAL USE OF RECYCLED WATER --
WHERE WE OPPOSED TO SB -- THREE
THREE TWO IS DUE TO THE IMMENSE
COMPLIANCE CHALLENGES IT WOULD
CREATE FOR WATER SYSTEMS.
THESE CHALLENGES INCLUDE COST A
LACK OF AN APPROPRIATE
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK TECHNICAL
FEASIBILITY AND A LACK OF
FLEXIBILITY.
AS MS GOVERNOR POINTED OUT THE
CAPITAL INVESTMENTS THAT WOULD
BE REQUIRED BY THE BILL WOULD BE
STAGGERING -- IN ORDER FOR WATER
AGENCIES TO REDUCE DISCHARGES BY
SUCH A SIGNIFICANT DEGREE IN
ALMOST EVERY INSTANCE IT WOULD
REQUIRE THE CONSTRUCTION OF
LARGE SCALE TREATMENT FACILITIES
CONVEYANCE INFRASTRUCTURE.
THIS BAND POTENTIALLY -- MANY
MILES AND COULD TAKE DECADES TO
COMPLETE.
ARE THESE SIGNIFICANT COSTS
WOULD HAVE TO BE SPREAD TO
EXISTING RATE PAYERS PURSUANT TO
PROP TO EIGHTEEN AS WE ARE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
AND THIS WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACT THE AFFORDABILITY OF
WATER AS MISS GOVERNOR POINTED
OUT WHICH AFFORDABILITY WATER WE
KNOW IS A GREAT CONCERN OF OF
THIS BODY -- IN ADDITION IN
ORDER TO MEET THE DISCHARGE
REDUCTION GOALS PROPOSED BY THIS
BILL WATER PROVIDERS WOULD
ALMOST CERTAINLY HAVE TO DEVELOP
LARGE SCALE REVIEWS OF POTABLE
REDUCE PROJECTS.
SOME WATER PROVIDERS -- HAVE
ALREADY TAKEN -- SIGNIFICANT
PROJECTS THAT FOR NON POTABLE
WATER -- AND SO THEY'RE REALLY
LEFT TRYING TO MEET THIS GOAL
I'M USING -- POSSIBLE SOURCES
WERE CREATING PORTABLE SOURCES
SO IN IN ORDER TO MEET THE
MANDATE -- BECAUSE BY THIS THIS
BILL WATER PROVIDERS WOULD
CERTAINLY HAVE TO LOOK TOWARDS --
NEW PORTABLE RE USE PROJECTS
THAT ARE ARE VERY COMPLICATED --
TECHNICALLY VERY DIFFICULT AND
COSTLY TO IMPLEMENT -- IN AGAIN
AS MISS GALLAGHER STATED THE
STATE WATER BOARD WILL NOT ADOPT
REGULATIONS REGARDING WHAT DRAW
WATER AUGMENTATION UNTIL.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE A YEAR AFTER
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE AGENCIES
TO IDENTIFY HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
COMPLY -- AND THEN FINALLY
FLEXIBILITY THIS BILL REALLY
DOESN'T ALLOW FOR FLEXIBILITY --
FOR WATER AGENCIES TO PROPERLY
MANAGE THEIR SYSTEMS -- AS YOU
ALL KNOW EACH COMMUNITY IS
DIFFERENT HAS DIFFERENT WATER
RESOURCES AND NEEDS AND THIS
BILL WOULD EFFECTIVELY
PRIORITIZE WATER REUSE PRODUCE
PROJECTS.
OVER OUR OTHER PROJECTS THAT
BENEFIT THE REGION SUCH AS
ADDITIONAL STORAGE -- SERVICE
FIRST WATER STORAGE --
HYDROELECTRIC PROJECTS -- SO THE
BILL DOESN'T REALLY CONSIDER YOU
KNOW EACH REGION INDEPENDENTLY
OR THE IMPACT ON EACH WATER
AGENCY.
INDEPENDENTLY.
AGAIN WE ARE SUPPORT OF
ENCOURAGING ADDITIONAL RECYCLED
WATER PROJECTS BUT IN A MANNER
THAT -- LOOKS AT MORE REGIONAL
BASIS AND CONSIDERS THE NEEDS OF
EACH COMMUNITY.
WE THINK THE SENATOR AND AND
STAFF -- FOR THEIR TIME AS WELL
AS THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
CONSIDERATION OF OUR CONCERNS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YES OTHER FOLKS ONE OF
HIS CONCERNS.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS BEST A
LOSS ON BEHALF OF WATER WE USE
CALIFORNIA I'M AS WATER REDUCE
WE ARE OBVIOUSLY VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF RECYCLED WATER -- THAT'S OUR
JOB -- WE ARE IN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION RECOGNIZING
THAT -- WE ARE THE WATER
RECYCLERS AND ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
RECYCLING WATER OUR BOARD ISN'T
GOING UNDER A PROCESS TO COME UP
WITH AMENDMENTS -- THEY ARE
GOING TO BE SIGNIFICANT THESE
ARE GOING TO BE AMENDMENTS NOT
WEEKS -- WE WE WANT TO FIND A
WAY TO PROMOTE THE USE OF
RECYCLED WATER AND AS MY
COLLEAGUES NOTED THERE ARE SOME
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO MOVING
FORWARD -- WITH THE ON
DEVELOPMENT OF REGULATIONS I
ALSO WANT TO KNOW SOMETHING NEW
THERE IS.
A LONG LONG WAIT THE WAITING
LIST OF THE STATE BOARD FOR
GRANTS AND LOANS -- I'M NOT JUST
ASKING FOR GRANTS BUT AS OUR OF
LOANS FOR RECYCLED WATER
PROJECTS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS --
SO IT'S NOT THAT THE WILL IS
THERE -- OUR AGENCIES ARE TRYING
TO TAKE PROACTIVE STEPS TO
RECYCLE MORE WATER ANDUSE WATER
BENEFICIALLY -- AND BECOME
INDEPENDENT OF IMPORTED WATER
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
SOUTH -- WE CAN WE CAN GET THERE
WITH.
INCENTIVES AND SUPPORT FROM THE
STATE GETTING REGULATIONS
ADOPTED -- AND FINDING SOME MORE
FUNDING FOR THESE PROJECTS
MOVING FORWARD -- JUST WANT TO
MAKE THOSE TWO QUICK NOTES WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING OUT WITH
THE SENATOR AND THE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL AS WE DEVELOP OUR
AMENDMENTS IN THE FUTURE AND
LOOK FORWARD.
TO CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
THANK YOU.
MORNING ROUNDS ROSSI WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION ALSO RESPECTFULLY.
THANK.
HOW ARE NOT TAKING TIME HERE
TODAY FOR THE NORTH BAY WATER
USE A THIRTY WHICH IS AN INDIE
COMPRISED OF ELEVEN WATER AND
WASTEWATER INTO THESE AND NAPA
CINEMA IN MARIN COUNTIES -- BUT
WE TRACK OUR COMMENTS WITH THOSE
OF CASA AND ALSO WATER REUSE WE
WILL BE PLUGGED INTO THE
DISCUSSIONS WITH RESPECT TO
AMENDMENTS.
BUT I WOULD ALSO SUGGEST WE'RE
PROBABLY ONE OF THE POSTER
CHILDREN FOR REGIONAL
DIFFERENCES GIVEN THE NORTH
COAST -- AREA THAT WE REPRESENTS
AND SO WE WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED
TO YOUR HOMEWORK LIST FOR YOU
AND YOUR STAFF TO COME LEARN
MORE ABOUT MORE ABOUT OUR
PARTICULAR CIRCUMSTANCES.
REMEMBERS THE CENTERS WITH THE
WESTERN FIFTY TRUMP'S
ASSOCIATION ALWAYS APPRECIATE
THE WHOLE VISION OF THE MAJORITY
LEADER -- WE HAVE A SLIGHTLY UP
LATE POSITION LETTER BUT WE LOOK
FOR TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
AS WE ARE WASTE THAT DISTRICT
PERMIT HOLDERS AND COMMERCIAL
REPAIRS AS WELL SO THANK YOU --
MISTER TERRY MEMBERS DON GILBERT
FOR SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION -- WE
OPPOSE THE BILL BUT WE WE
CERTAINLY.
DO NOT OPPOSE THE IDEAS IN THE
BILL WE WE APPRECIATE ORDER THE
HERTZBERG A AN IDEA FORCING US
ALL THE THINK BIG AND AND THAT'S
IMPORTANT.
THAT'S IMPORTANT I GOT A THUMBS
TO HAVE THAT'S AWESOME ANYWAY
THIS -- BUT IT AND WERE
PRACTITIONERS OF WATER RECYCLING
I MEAN ON AS A PC STAFF OUR
WORLD EXPERTS -- AND THAT THAT'S
A COMMITMENT -- BUT WITH WE
THINK TO ACHIEVE WHAT THE CENTER
AND THE PROPONENTS WANT TO
ACHIEVE.
IT REALLY REQUIRES VERY SERIOUS
STUDIES ON FEASIBILITY AD COSTS
IN ORDER TO HAVE.
YOU KNOW -- AT PLANET WHAT CAN
BE DEVELOPED FOR EACH REGION IN
MANY CASES EACH DISTRICT TO COME
ANYWHERE NEAR ACHIEVING THAT SO
WE THINK MAYBE THE BILL WOULD
MAKE MORE SENSE LOOKING LIKE
THAT AND I DON'T MEAN.
A STUDY BILL THAT GOES AWAY I
MEAN A SERIOUS A BILL THAT
REALLY ENABLES US TO DO SERIOUS
STUDIES THAT ARE ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY TO GET ANYWHERE CLOSE
TO ACCOMPLISHING THE GOALS HERE.
SO WE HAVE WORKED WITH THE
CENTER HIS STAFF AND THE
SPONSORS AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO
SO THANK YOU.
STILL FIORINA.
DANIEL LAST WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
A WE ACTUALLY REPRESENT PUBLIC
WATER AGENCIES AND PUBLICLY ON
ELECTRIC UTILITIES SO WE HAVE
SOME CONCERNS REGARDING THAT IF
THE ENERGY IMPACTS AS WELL AS
THE IMPACTS.
TO OUR AGENCIES SUCH AS AS OF PC
AT LIKE TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS
WITH THOSE A CAST THAT AN
AWKWARD REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON NOW
ON THIS MOVING FORWARD BUT WE DO
RESPECTFULLY.
THE BILL AT THIS TIME -- MEMBERS
MONICA MILLER REPRESENTED THE
SANTA CARA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT ALSO KNOWN AS VALLEY
WATER AND WE HAVE A AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE SENATOR YOUR
STAFF AND HIS STAFF TO WORK OUT
THOSE ISSUES I THINK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PLUGINS ALL OF US HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF
CAME REAL AND ROSE WILL WOULD
SIMPLY LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH AUCKLAND SEEM YOU
A AND LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH
THE GOOD SENATOR.
WELL ANYWAY THIS WORKING HAN
AUTUMN HARTMAN ON BEHALF OF
IRVINE RANCH WATER DISTRICT WE
SHARE THE VERY STRONG CONCERNS
OF BOTH COSTS AND WATER RE USE.
WE INTEND TO WORK WITH AUTHOR
AND THE SPONSORS -- AS WELL AS
WATER REVIEWS HOPEFULLY GETTING
SOME WORKABLE AMENDMENTS THAT
WILL REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
THAT IS ALL WE ONLY BE HALF OF
MAY SO -- WATER WE ALSO OPPOSE
LAST MINUTE AND SHARE THE
CONTENT ALSO LIKE SAID THE
RESULT OF OTHER CHALLENGES
INCLUDING THINGS LIKE
ENVIRONMENTAL PERMITTING.
AND EACH.
HAS DIFFERENT CHALLENGES OF
WATER GOES BACK IN THE RIVER NOT
SOME LOSER IS THE NEED TO BE
CONSIDERED ON UP -- DISTRICT BY
DISTRICT BASIS THANK YOU.
OKAY OF THANK YOU.
WELL THERE WE ARE OKAY THE ITEM
IS NOW BEFORE THE THE CAN BE LET
ME ASK YOU THE FIRST QUESTION.
MR MAJORITY LEADER ON REGIONAL
DIFFERENCE ARE YOU HEARD THIS
OVER AND OVER AGAIN -- WE ARE A
DIVERSE STATE FOR THE GEOGRAPHIC
DIFFERENCE [inaudible]
HI MARK.
LOS ANGELES COMMUNITIES VERY
DIFFERENT IN THE NORTH COAST
VERY FROM THE FROM THE DESERT.
WHAT WHAT WHAT IS YOUR?
ARE ARE YOU.
TELL ME TELL ME HOW YOU RESPOND
TO THE CONCERNS OF THIS IS A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL -- YOU KNOW ANSWER
TO A COMPLEX ISSUE THAT INVOLVES
VERY DIFFERENT.
GEOGRAPHIES AND AND WHAT IS THE
GOAL A CHALLENGES IN DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE STATE.
YEAH I THINK IT'S REASONABLE AND
I THINK THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
DEALING WITH IT BUT THE ONLY
HONEST EXPRESS IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT HERE.
IS THE COFFERS COMMON OPPOSITION
WITH THE IS THIS A MASSIVE --
AMOUNT OF WATER THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT A GOES THE OCEAN
YEAH IT'S WE'LL FROM EVERYBODY
ELSE'S DISTRICT WHAT'S THE
IMPACT THERE'S A BUNCH OF
STAKEHOLDERS LEARN HERE LIKE
LET'S THINK ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THAT IN THE
WE HAD WE HAVE ALL THESE ISSUES
OFTEN AND HE ARCHES OF
ENVIRONMENTAL WATER WE ALSO HAVE
IN TERMS OF THE THE BECAUSE THIS
IS BIG PUZZLE WERE ALL KIND OF
FITS TOGETHER BUT BE BE WITH
WITH JUST I GET THE DIFFERENCES
WAS?
BACK LIKE YOU KNOW IF THAT IF
THAT'S IF THAT'S A CONCERN THEN
SHOULD WE HAVE A DIFFERENT
APPROACH TO THOSE AREAS THAT ARE
IMPORTING ALL THAT WATER FROM
OTHER PARTS THE STATE -- WOULD
THAT BE AS OPPOSED TO HAVING THE
SAME.
I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER THAT
QUESTION BUT I DO THINK IT
MERITS MERIT SOME SOME SOME
HOMEWORK MIGHT MIGHT PLAY A
BIGGER PART ABOUT THIS IS IS
THAT WE TALK ABOUT THIS THAT THE
NATURE OF THIS PARTICULARLY IN
HOW MUCH WATER IS WHEELED FROM
ALL OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE.
WHAT YOU'RE MISSING WITH EVERY
IS MISSING IN THE EQUATION THIS?
YOU KEEP WILLING THAT WATER
LEVEL AT ALL AS AN ACRE FOOT FOR
METROPOLITAN WATER LA STEAL IT
FROM THE COLOR RIVER WELL IF YOU
CAN RECYCLE WATER THAT ELEVEN
DOLLARS AN ACRE FOOT THAT WATERS
RESOLD.
IS THAT THERE IS A LOT OF
DIAGNOSTIC IN THAT I DON'T
DISAGREE WITH YOU IN THAT
THOUGHT WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH PEOPLE I WAS IS SUGGEST IN
THE ANALYSIS TO FIGURE THAT OUT.
BUT YOU KNOW I GOTTA TELL YOU
THIS IS LIKE DEJA VU ALL OVER
AGAIN THE SKY IS FALLING NOTHING
WILL EVER BE MET THE ALL THE
IMPOSSIBLE STANDARDS OF WHY YOU
CAN'T DO SOMETHING AND WE HAD
20% OUR PS.
AND THEN BEFORE THE DEADLINE
EVERYBODY WAS BRIGHT AND HOW
THEY EXCEEDED THEIR NUMBERS
RIGHT YES THERE'S DIFFERENCES
YESTERDAY AFFLUENT NUMBERS THAT
YOU NEED TO HAVE.
AND HOW MUCH IS IT'S A 20% BOGEY
RIGHT SO.
I UNDERSTAND AND I DO THINK IT
NEEDS TO BE A MANDATE -- IN
WHATEVER IT IS WHAT WITH THE WE
LOOK AT DIFFERENT FACTORS YOU
COULD PATIENTS AT THIS IS SECOND
IN TERMS THE LARGER ISSUE.
BUT I THINK THAT YOU WOULD WERE
NOT LOOKING AT THE THE LARGER
KIND OF SUSTAINABLE APPROACH
THAT WE NEED TO DEAL WITH.
ARE A IN WATER POLICY AND MAYBE
THERE WILL BE SOME DIFFERENCES
AND IT WAS VERY SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCES NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
I AGREE I DON'T DISAGREE WITH
WHAT.
THE POINTS THAT WERE MADE ABOUT
SAN FRANCISCO IN THE FACT THAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE ORANGE COUNTY'S
THE PLATINUM.
STANDARD IN TERMS OF RECYCLING
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND ACRE
FEET NOW THE RATS PRETTY
INCREDIBLE.
BUT BUT HAT BEING SAID -- I
THINK WE'RE GETTING EVERYBODY'S
ATTENTION IN THIS HERTZBERG AN
APPROACH TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO SET THOSE STANDARDS IN A
WAY THAT THAT IT WORKS.
AND THE IS RESPECTABLE TO
REGIONAL DIFFERENCES AND HAS THE
NECESSARY FLEXIBILITY WITHIN THE
FRAMEWORK OUT OF TREES YOU WOULD
HAVE SOMETHING. TO THIS.
I I WOULD JUST SAY THAT YEAH YOU
KNOW WE AT THE REGIONAL
DIFFERENCES IS AN AREA WHERE WE
ARE LOOKING TO HAVE ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATIONS.
I THINK WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT
YOU KNOW ANYTIME THAT YOU'RE
REMOVING WATER FROM THE
ENVIRONMENT -- YOU KNOW IN SAN
FRANCISCO WE HAVE CHALLENGES
WITH THE AT TAMI THERE YOU KNOW
WANTING MORE MORE WATER FROM
THAT AND I THINK THAT -- YOU
KNOW THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE
HAVE THOSE ISSUES AND WE JUST
WANT TO LOOK A LITTLE BIT
FURTHER INTO THEM -- OBVIOUSLY
IMPORTED WATER IS A MORE OBVIOUS
CASE WHERE RECYCLED WATER AND
IMPORTED OR COST COMPETITIVE AND
YOU KNOW -- AND RECYCLE WATER
HAS THE ADDED BENEFIT OF LOWER
LIABILITY AND NO BUT IF DROUGHT
PROOF -- QUALITY SO -- YOU KNOW
I WOULD SAY THAT I MEAN WE'RE
EXPLORING THOSE AND AND LOOK FOR
TO CONTINUE WORKING ON IT.
WHERE WOULD YOU SAY THIS FITS ON
THE THE BIG THINK SPECTRUM?
I HOW HOW WOULD YOU RATE IT.
AS A HERTZBERG IN THAT I KNOW OF
THE PEOPLE BEHIND ME PROBABLY
STAB ME IN THE BACK OF I
MENTIONED TAX REFORM BUT OR A
FEW OTHER ONES FROM HIM SELECT
YOUR CONTACTS BUT IT'S IT'S
SUPPORT WORK AS WATER STUFF FOR
FORTY SOME YEARS AND IT'S THE
IT'S IMPORTANT.
YOU KNOW WE CAN ALL LIVE WITHOUT
LIKE ELECTRICITY WE CAN LIVE
WITH A LOT OF STUFF.
WE CAN'T LIVE WITHOUT WATER AND
AND WHAT I LEARNED IN THIS
PROCESS IS IN IN ALL OF THIS
WATER WORLD THAT WE WORK IN THE
FOUL THOUSAND PLUS WATER
AGENCIES AND ALL THE POLITICS
AND IT.
IS JUST WATER POLICIES ONE
LOSERS JUST TKES SO MANY
DECADES TO STEP TO MOVE THE SHIP.
AND YOU YOU YOU YOU.
AND GIVEN WHERE WE ARE GIVEN THE
CHALLENGES WITH THAT AT TATIAN
THAT.
THE EMERITUS CHAIRMAN OVER HERE
TALKS ABOUT A LOT AND AND WITH
CLIMATE CHANGE AND YOU SEE THE
SNOW PACK AND ALL THESE THINGS
WE'VE GOT TO SPEED UP THE
PROCESS IN TERMS OF HOW WE
RETHINK THIS STUFF.
AND CERTAINLY JUST THINKING
ABOUT RECYCLING WATER THAT WERE
ALREADY USING AND PAYING TO
PROCESS AND WE HAVE TO CLEAN IT
UP TO GO IN THE OCEAN SEEMS TO
ME TO BE A PRETTY.
THOUGHTFUL STARTING POINT TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT WE SHOULD DO AND
WATER POLICY GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU -- MANAGEMENT CENTER
HELL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
AND THANK YOU SENATORS BURFORD
FOR BRINGING THIS CONVERSATION
THAT I THINK IS IS.
IS TIMELY NECESSARY AND AN
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT FOR
CALIFORNIA -- BUT I YOU KNOW AND
AND THANK YOU FOR THE GREAT
ANALYSIS -- I THINK IT REALLY.
HIGHLIGHTS THE CHALLENGE THAT
WE'RE FACED WITH TODAY IN TRYING.
TO AND THE FACT THAT THE
AMENDMENTS THE THERE AREN'T MANY
AS AMENDMENTS BECAUSE IT'S JUST
NOT POSSIBLE I THINK TO DEAL
WITH SOME OF THE ISSUES RELATED
TO THE OPPOSITION AND HOW WE CAN
KIND OF CRAFT THAT IN A WAY THAT.
THAT THAT WORKS IN AND I DON'T
THINK WE CAN DO THAT TODAY
SITTING HERE BUT I I'M I'M
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO TO TO SUPPORT.
THE IDEA THAT WE KEEP IT MOVING
AND HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS I
I WOULD HOPE THAT IT COULD BE
DONE IN A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME I
DON'T KNOW -- BECAUSE SOME OF
THE MANDATES OF THE I MEAN SOME
OF THESE THINGS ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU LOOK INTO -- THE
REQUIREMENTS BY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO BUT REGULATIONS ARE GOING TO
BE OUT TILL.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE YOU KNOW
THERE THERE ARE JUST A NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT THERE AREN'T --
WORKABLE -- AT THIS POINT AND
HOPEFULLY THAT CAN BE DEVELOPED
AND DESIGNED AND CRAFTED IN A
WAY -- THAT I I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO VOTE FOR TO AND AT THAT THE
NEXT -- OPPORTUNITY BUT I I JUST
THINK IT'S IT'S A TOUGH OF IT'S
A TOUGH ORDER BUT I IF YOU THE
GOALS ARE THERE WE NEED TO MEET
UP AND WE NEED TO GET THEIR TO
HOW WE DO IT.
HOW WE DO IT IN A MANDATED WAY
THAT'S NOT?
GOING TO BE SO ONEROUS AND AND
COSTLY FREIGHT FOR FOR EVERYONE.
THE HAPPY TO HELP THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR I APPRECIATED
NIGHT.
I COMMITTEE UPPER LEVEL GRAYSON
THIS THING TRY TO FIGURE OUT
SOME OF THOSE CHALLENGES THAT WE
FACE BUT WE GOT EVERYBODY IN THE
ROOM NOW AND SO IT'S THE FIRST
STEP -- HOW WE LOOK AT THERE'S
NO QUESTION THAT THERE ARE ALL
SORTS OF EXAMPLES OF OF THE
LEGISLATURE SETTING -- MEMBERS
JUST GOALS -- THERE OF COURSE
HAS TO BE THIS AND IT'S ALWAYS
BEEN A PUSH PULL BETWEEN.
THE POSSIBLE AND THE AND AND AND
THE NECESSARY -- I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE HEARING IS VERY STRONG
PUSH BACK FROM THE AGENCIES THAT
WOULD BE TASKED WITH DOING THIS
I UNDERSTAND THAT'S NATURAL TO
SOME EXTENT BUT THEN BUT THERE
THERE ARE GONNA BE SOME SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT THE LOGISTICS OF
THIS AND AND YOU KNOW.
WHERE THIS AUDIT FIT ON TO THE
LIST OF PRIORITIES OF OF WITH IT
IF IT IS GOING TO INVOLVE A
SIGNIFICANT REPAIR COSTS?
HI AND AND AND YOU KNOW I KNOW
SOMETHING THAT YOU YOU'RE
SENSITIVE TO AS WELL -- SO.
I'M OF THE BILL THAT BEING SAID
I DO THINK IT'S A IT'S A IT YOU
KNOW.
AN IMMENSELY IMPORTANT GOAL AND
AND YOU DO [inaudible]
REYES.
FAIR POINTED I'M WE'RE BOTH
REPRESENT LOS ANGELES AT ABOUT
HOW YOU KNOW WE REALLY OUGHT TO
GET MORE MORE.
SELF SUSTAINING UC SANTA MONICA
I KNOW IS PROUD OF THE FACT THAT
IT'S KIND OF VERY.
VERY WELL ALONG THE WAY TOWARD A
100% SELF SUSTAINING WATER
SYSTEM WHICH IS REALLY PRETTY
EXTRAORDINARY IF YOU THINK ABOUT
HOW.
SMALL IT IS -- SO.
I WILL CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY AND YOU KNOW IN IN IN
IN.
GREAT DIFFERENCE TO YOUR TO YOUR
OF YOUR AMBITIOUS GOALS HERE
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CINEMA CASKEY --
SEE NO OTHER FURTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS YOU MAY CLOSE CENTER
YEAH I JUST ONE OF THE JUST MAKE
THE FINAL POINT ABOUT COST YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS IS
THERE'S PARTICULARLY WHEN YOU
HAVE A REVENUE STREAM I YOU
WATER.
AND YOU CAN RESELL IT.
THEY'RE EITHER WHEN YOU ALREADY
HAVE A PRICE SIGNALS LOVING HER
DOLLARS AN ACRE FOOT.
YOU HAVE GREAT ON THIS THIS THAT
THAT WILL FIGHT I AM TOTALLY
SENSITIVE THE REGIONAL
DIFFERENCES IN SOME OF THE OTHER
CHALLENGES AS WE SHOULD CENTER
HILL RAISED ON TIMING AND THINGS
LIKE THAT.
BUT THE COST THING IS TO ME IS
NOT A GIGANTIC PROB PROBLEM IT
BOTH IN THE RESPECT THAT THERE'S
A REVENUE STREAM NUMBER.
ONE AND TWO WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHEN YOU
WORK ON THESE BIG PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS -- ABOUT SEVENTY FOUR
CENTS OF EVERY DOLLAR COMES BACK
IN THE FORM PAYROLL TAXES SALES
TAX AND ALL THE OTHER THINGS SO.
WHEN YOU REALLY LOOK AT THESE
BIG CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS THAT
ARE NECESSARY? FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE IMPACT ON
THE ACTUAL GOVERNMENT IS IS
REALLY MINIMAL NUMBER ONE AND
TWO IF WE DON'T PASS.
THE TAX REFORM WE HAVE MORE
VOLATILITY GOING FORWARD AND
DURING THE DOWN TERMS OF
VOLATILITY LIKE WHAT WE DID WITH
OUR BIG GIGANTIC HAIRY AUDACIOUS
IDEA ON SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION.
DOES CONSTRUCTION JOBS HAD A
GIGANTIC IMPACT IN MITIGATING
SOME OF THE DOWNTURN IN THE
ECONOMY SO THESE STEPS WHEN YOU
DO THE DIAGNOSTIC IN THE LARGER
THINK ABOUT THIS IS A LOT MORE
ELEMENTS TO IT BUT THE FINANCE
PIECE IN THE CROSSPIECE TO ME.
ARM AS WE FACE THIS GOING
FORWARD DEALING THE ANALYSIS IS
ONE OF THE SMALLEST AREAS THAT
WE HAVE CHALLENGES ARE IF WE
HAVE TO A BOND ISSUE MAYBE IN
LIEU OF THAT.
A HIGHER EDUCATION BOND OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT IT MIGHT NOT
BE A BAD THING JOB JUST JOKING
[inaudible]
OF COURSE.
WAS IT WAS A TOUGH TWISTED IN
THE AMOUNT I THINK I'M A JOINT
AUTHOR THAT.
HIGHER EDUCATION BUT NEVER THE
LESS OUT OF DEFERENCE AND
RESPECT AND COURTESY TO YOU AND
YOUR AT YOUR YOUR YOUR LONG
STANDING EXPERIENCE IN THIS
BUILDING I WILL THAT.
SUPPORT THIS BILL TO MOVE BY
CENTER WOULD CASKEY -- SIX OF
THESE KALRA.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB THREE THREE
TO THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
ALLEN HI ALAN HI BETH.
PHIL.
HILL AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
STONE NO MY CASKEY BY MAKOVSKY
AYE.
OKAY THIRTY WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OF FOR APPS MEMBERS TO ADD ON
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SIR.
JERRY LEADER -- LET'S PASSED THE
THE GAVEL AGAIN TORTURE EMERITUS
IN I WILL NOW PRESENT -- I THINK
THE TWO FINAL ITEMS.
SB FIVE TWENTY SIX SB.
SIX EIGHTY TWO MEMBERS THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN IN TODAY'S
AGENDA THIS IS THE STATE
MOBILITY ACTION PLAN FOR HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES.
THERE.
ARE SUCH AS THIS NUMBER
[inaudible]
WELCOME BACK.
THANK YOU THE CARD -- PRESENTLY
I LET I LET YOU LIKE IT THIS WAY
BECAUSE IT'S NOT -- TO THE MIX
IT UP. THIRTY ONE INTERSPERSED
WITH HERTZ BURKE.
OKAY I HAVE SOME MEMBERS SOME --
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT THIS
COMMITTEE SURELY KNOWS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE THAT WAS.
PRO TEM STEINBERG'S BILL THAT
SOUGHT TO LINK OUR
TRANSPORTATION LAND USE AND
HOUSING EFFORTS.
WITH OUR GOALS OF REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
AND THE STATE OF ALL COMMUNITIES
BILL.
THE LAW REQUIRES THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO SET REGIONAL
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION TARGETS
FOR THE STATE'S EIGHTEEN
METROPOLITAN.
PLANNING ORGANIZATION STUDIES
NPOS THEN CREATE A SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITY STRATEGY AS PART OF
THEIR REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PLAN.
THAT IF IMPLEMENTED WOULD ALLOW
THE REGION TO MEET.
THE REDUCTION TARGETS NOW 201-7
WE PASSED SB.
ONE FIFTY WHICH ASK CARB TWO
WOULD ASSESS THE PROGRESS THAT
WE'VE MADE TOWARD MEETING THE
REDUCTION TARGETS IN AND THE
CARD HAS AS DEAD AN ASSESSMENT.
AND THEY BASICALLY COUNTY CALVIN
IS NOT ON TRACK TO MEET
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS
EXPECTED.
UNDER SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE IN
THE NOTED CONCERNS ALL QUOTE --
THE CONTINUED PERVASIVE AND LONG
STANDING DISCONNECT BETWEEN THE
FACTORS THAT SHAPE REGIONAL
GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT
CALIFORNIA.
SO JUST TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENT REGULATORY HOUSING
MARKET CONDITIONS AT THE LOCAL
REGIONAL STATE LEVELS.
AND THE STATE'S ENVIRONMENTAL
EQUITY CLIMATE HEALTH ECONOMIC
AND HOUSING GOALS THERE IS A
CONTINUING DISCONNECTED.
CERTAINLY SOMETHINGTHAT NOBODY
MEMBER OF THIS LEGISLATURE IS
NOT UNFAMILIAR WITH.
IT IS UNFAMILIAR WITH THEM.
I BASED ON THE RECOMMENDATIONS
IN THE REPORT.
THIS BILL BASICALLY TAKES THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND AND AND AND
TRIES TO IMPLEMENT A NUMBER OF
THE KEY RECOMMENDATIONS ONE
ESTABLISHING A MEDICAL BILL THE
ACTION PLAN FOR HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES.
WHICH IS A TASK FORCES CHARGED
WITH IDENTIFYING STRATEGIES TO
GET A SEAT ON TRACK. TO MEETING
OUR CLIMATE GOALS FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION AND LAND USE
SECTORS.
AND OUR A ES IN SO DOING CREATES
A PROCESS TO COLLECT THE
NECESSARY DATA THAT WE NEED TO
EVALUATE.
THE PROGRESS THAT REGION'S ARE
MAKING.
NOW IF BY TWENTY TWENTY SIX CARB
FINDS THAT OUR REGION IS STILL
NOT MAKING PROGRESS TOWARD
ACHIEVING ITS D. G. A. G. H. T.
TARGETS.
THE STATE TRANSPORTATION
IMPROVEMENT PLAN GUIDELINES
WOULD GIVE HIGHER PRIORITY FOR
STATE FUNDING. TO PROJECTS IN
THAT REGION THAT REDUCE.
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED AND GHG
EMISSIONS.
MEMBERS WITHOUT SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES TO HOW COMMUNITIES AND
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS ARE
PLANNED CALIFORNIA WILL NOT
ACHIEVE THE NECESSARY GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS.
REDUCTIONS TO MEET OUR GOALS FOR
TWENTY THIRTY LET ALONE TWENTY
FORTY TWENTY FORTY FIVE WE
TALKED ABOUT THAT.
DURING A PREVIOUS HEARING -- AND
THIS BILL IS VERY MUCH.
WRITTEN IN THAT AT IN THE SPIRIT
OF THE CONCERNS REYES THAT
HEARING TRANSPORTATION AS WE
KNOW IT COUNTS 440% OF OUR
MISSIONS.
IN THE DECISIONS THAT WE MAKE
TODAY ON WHERE. TO PUT LOCAL NEW
COMMUNITIES AND HOW MUCH SPRAWL --
IS ACCEPTABLE REMAIN WILL REMAIN
WITH US FOR DECADES.
ESPECIALLY NOW WE WORK SO HARD
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO PROVIDE
QUALITY AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE'VE
GOT TO BE DELIBERATE IN ARE
PLANNING TO ENSURE THAT WE BOTH
MEET OUR HOUSING.
IN OUR CLIMATE GOALS WHEN THEY
WERE BUILDING SAFE LIVABLE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE CAN BE PROUD
OF THAT REALLY DO PROMOTE HIGH
QUALITY OF LIFE.
SO SB THREE THIRTY FIVE GAVE US
THE FRAMEWORK MORE THAN A DECADE
AGO NOW WE NEED TO GIVE IT SOME.
SOME SOME TEETH WE NEED TO GIVE
IT SOME STRENGTH WE NEED TO
BUILD UPON THAT FRAMEWORK TO
MAKE IT WORK AND I HAVE WOULD BE.
THE CARD A RIBBON FROM AN RTC
JOSH START FROM TRANSFORM WILL
BEAR IT FROM THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION THERE ARE GOING TO
BE HERE. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
SWEETNESS PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON
MEMBERS CARTER EVEN WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL.
I'M HERE TODAY TO REALLY
REITERATE -- EVERYTHING SENATOR
ALLEN SAID AND EXPRESS ENERGY
SEES STRONG SUPPORT AND URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB.
FIVE TWENTY SIX WHICH WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S EFFORT
TO HALT CLIMATE CHANGE.
EXTENDS TO OUR LARGEST SOURCE OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
AS YOU ALL WELL KNOW
CALIFORNIANS ARE ALREADY
SUFFERING FROM THE DEVASTATING
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE WITH POOR
AIR QUALITY.
AND DESPITE INCREASINGLY
FREQUENT AN UNPRECEDENTED
DISASTERS WE CONTINUE TO INVEST
IN INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT POURS MORE FUEL ON THAT
FIRE.
OUR OWN STATE AGENCIES OF RAISE
THE ALARM THAT OUR CURRENT.
TRANSPORTATION POLICIES AND
PRIORITIES ARE PUSHING MORE
ROADS AND WIDER ROADS.
AND EXPERTS AND OUR LIVED
EXPERIENCE TELL US THAT THAT IS --
SIMPLY ENCOURAGING MORE AND MORE
DRIVING.
SB FIVE TWENTY SIX BUILT ON THE
FOUNDATIONAL WORK OF SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE AND ONE FIFTY TO
RECOGNIZE THE FIGHTING CLIMATE
CHANGE MEANS.
IN CALIFORNIANS MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO GET AROUND
WITHOUT GETTING IN THEIR CAR
SOMETHING THAT THERE ARE ALREADY
SEEKING MORE MORE OPPORTUNITIES
TO DO.
THANKS TO SB ONE FIFTY THE
TERRORIST RESOURCES BOARD
PRODUCED THIS FIRST
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT THE
SIGNIFICANT MISALIGNMENT BETWEEN
OUR TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS
THAT ARE CLIMATE GOALS.
AND PRODUCE SOME PRETTY
STARTLING FINDINGS THAT SB.
FIVE TWENTY SIX SIX TO REDRESS.
WE'RE NOT ON TRACK TO MEET OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS
EXPECTED FROM SB.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE REDUCING
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED.
IS NECESSARY TO HIT OUR CLIMATE
GOALS AND ELECTRIFICATION IT
WILL NOT GET US THERE ALONE.
YET PASSENGER VEHICLE EMISSIONS
ARE CLIMBING.
THE PORTION OF COMMUTERS DRIVING
ALONE TO WORK IS RISING IN
ALMOST EVERY REGION.
AND CALIFORNIA'S STAND TO SPEND
A TRILLION DOLLARS OVER THE LIFE
OF CURRENT TRANSPORTATION PLANS
BUT THESE PROJECTS ARE NOT
ALIGNED WITH OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
OR STATE PRIORITIES ON EQUITABLE
GROWTH AND OPEN SPACE
CONSERVATION. TO SECURE THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EQUITY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND TRANSPORTATION
CHOICES ENVISIONED BY SB.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE AND TO ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA REMAINS ON TRACK
TO MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
WE NEED SB.
FIVE TWENTY SIX HELP US GET
THERE.
LOW REDUCE CLIMATE POLLUTION
FROM THE TRANSPORTATION AND LAND
USE SECTOR.
HELP US ACHIEVE OUR STATEWIDE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION GOALS
THREE THANK SENATOR ALAN FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANKS.
THANK YOU CENTERS JOSH WAS STARK
WITH TRANSFORM -- HERE IN
SUPPORT OF SB -- FIVE TWENTY SIX
SB FIVE TWENTY SIX IS THE NEEDED
AND REASONABLE NEXT STEP IN
CALIFORNIA'S DECADES LONG WORK
TO FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE QUITE
FRANKLY -- THE MEMBERS -- IN ON
THE COMMITTEE HERE THE MEMBER
PRESENT TODAY -- IN PARTICULAR.
THIS ORDER THE GROUPS HAVE TAKEN
A LEADERSHIP ROLE OVER A WIDE
VARIETY OF TOUGH ISSUES AND HAVE
MOVED US IN SUCH A WAY.
THAT WE'RE OFTEN LOOKED AT AS A
WORLD LEADER OR THE WORLD LEADER
IN ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE
BOTH IN ITS IMPACTS AND OUR
CLIMATE POLLUTION.
THAT'S OFTEN PERCEIVE THE CLASS
CALIFORNIA JUST NATURALLY SHOULD
TAKE THAT THAT ROLE AND
LEADERSHIP BUT I THINK WE HEAR
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT CALIFORNIA'S
KINDA LIKE A DUCK ON THE WATER
RIGHT SERENE ON TOP AND PADDLING
LIKE HELL UNDERNEATH. TO TO GET
THINGS DONE RIGHT AND AND IT HAS
REQUIRED SOME REALLY BOLD STEPS --
AND YOU ALL HAVE TAKEN OUT ON
YOU ALL HAVE BEEN SO SUCCESSFUL
IN FACT THAT CALIFORNIA'S MET
ITS TWENTY TWENTY GOALS EARLY
CORRECT -- SO DECADE OR SO INTO
A BILL INTO SB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN YOU
ALL PASSED SENATOR ALLEN SB --
ONE FIFTY TO CHECK IN ON KHN
TO SEE IF CALIFORNIA'S REGIONS
ARE ON TRACK TO MEET THEIR SHARE
OF OF GHG EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS.
WE RELIED UPON SCIENCE TO
CONCLUDE THAT ANTHROPOMORPHIC
CLIMATE CHANGE IS REAL WE RELIED
UPON SCIENCE TO ADDRESS --
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS IN OTHER
PLACES AND WE SHOULD CONTINUE TO
RELY UPON SCIENCE.
HERE AND WHAT THE SCIENCE SAYS
VERY CLEARLY IS THAT THE AMOUNT
OF CAR TRAVEL WE DO IN
CALIFORNIA IS UNSUSTAINABLE TO
OUR CLIMATE INTO THAT THE FUTURE
OF CALIFORNIA FRANKLY -- AND SO
WE NEED TO START MAKING THOSE
CHANGES THE SCIENCE ALSO CLEARLY
SHOWS THAT.
CURRENT EFFORTS HAVE NOT MOVED
THE NEEDLE -- TO ADDRESS THOSE
AND THOSE CHANGES ARE NOT
CHANGES THEIR THEIR CHANGES THAT
ARE ACTUALLY NEEDED AND AND
APPRECIATED AND LOVED AT THE
COMMUNITY LEVEL CHANGES LIKE
IMPROVEMENTS ARE OUR NEW TRANSIT
PROJECTS.
MORE BUS STOPS MORE TRANSIT
SERVICE MORE BIKING AND WALKING
OPPORTUNITIES SO WE'RE JUST
TALKING ABOUT INCREASING THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR FOLKS. TO GET
WHERE THEY NEED TO GO -- SO
TRANSFORM SPORTS THIS THIS BILL
SB FIVE TWENTY SIX AS THIS REAL
REASONABLE EFFORT.
ALSO BECAUSE WE HAVE MAYBE TEN
MORE YEARS RIGHT OUR ELEVEN MORE
YEARS TO MEET OUR NEXT SET OF
GOALS -- IF WE WERE TO WAIT FIVE
MORE YEARS BEFORE WE STARTED
ADDRESSING THIS WE ALL RECOGNIZE
THE NATURE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE IS SUCH THAT YOU
CAN'T MOVE IN FOUR YEARS OR FIVE
YEARS.
YOU HAVE TO START PLANNING AND
MOVING NOW SO WE'RE GIVING A
REASONABLE AMOUNT OF TIME WE'VE
TAKEN A REASONABLE DOUBT ON TIME
A DECADE.
IN ORDER TO DO A REAL REPORT ON
ON A FRONTRUNNER -- ASKING FOR A
REAL REASONABLE AMOUNT OF TIME
ANOTHER DECADE -- IN ORDER TO
BEGIN MAKING THESE CHANGES BUT
WE'VE NOTICED IN THE FIRST
DECADE.
THAT THOSE CHANGES WERE NOT MADE.
THEY JUST WEREN'T MADE SO SB
FIVE TWENTY SIX I THINK BEGINS
IS VERY BOLD AND TOUGH
CONVERSATION OVER REALLY WHAT IS
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE BLIND SPOT.
AND THAT'S ITS TRANSFER STATION
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF THAT SB.
FIVE TWENTY SIX LOW -- WILL BEAR
WITH THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION OF THE THIRD CO
SPONSOR OF THE LEGISLATION OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA IS STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF SB.
FIVE TWENTY SIX OF SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE OFFER SO MANY
PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFITS ON TOP OF
ALL THE STATED BENEFITS -- THAT
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED.
REDUCTIONS IN CHRONIC ILLNESS --
IMPROVEMENTS IN AIR QUALITY.
PRODUCTIONS IN CANCER RATES --
MENTAL ILLNESS -- BENEFITS OF
THERE'S A WIDE RANGE OF HEALTH
BENEFITS TO IMPLEMENTING SB
THREE SEVEN FIVE SUCCESSFULLY
THAT'S WHY WE'RE SO TROUBLED BY
THE FINDINGS IN THE SB ONE FIFTY
REPORT SHOWING THAT WE'RE NOT ON
TRACK.
THIS LEGISLATION REALLY MOVES US
FORWARD TO GET US BACK ON TRACK
MAKE SURE THAT WORD ACHIEVING
THOSE BENEFITS OF SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES.
WERE REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH OUR NPOS IN OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND OTHER
STATE AGENCIES. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT
AND TO MOVE FORWARD AND GET ON
TRACK -- FOR THE INTEREST OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND STABLE CLIMATE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SIR.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF A SB FIVE
TO SIX HI JULIE JORDAN WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
WE WORK WITH MANY RESIDENTS IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN IN EASTERN
COACHELLA VALLEY'S -- PRIMARILY
WHO ARE SOME OF THE MOST
ENVIRONMENTALLY VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE --
INCLUDING WORLD DISADVANTAGE ON
A CORPORATE COMMUNITIES WHO
OFTEN LACK.
ANY TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS --
LET ALONE THOSE THAT ARE
EQUITABLE CLEAN AND AFFORDABLE --
SO WE SEE SB FIVE TWENTY SIX IS
AN OPPORTUNITY -- A DECADE AFTER
THE PASSAGE OF THREE SEVENTY
FIVE TO RAMP UP OUR EFFORTS TO
MAKE SURE THE NPOS ARE DIRECTLY
SUFFICIENTLY -- FUNDING AND
DIRECTING FUNDING TOWARDS --
TRANSIT BIKE AND PEDESTRIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND
NONTRADITIONAL TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS LAKE SAMPUL THAT WORK
FOR LOW INCOME RURAL COMMUNITIES
AS WELL -- AND REDUCE VMT --
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE ALIGN STATE FUNDING AND
INVESTMENTS TO MATCH OUR STATE
CLIMB INEQUITY GOALS -- AND WE
SEE THIS BILL IS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO REALLY STRENGTHEN THE
TRANSPARENCY AND EFFECTIVENESS
OF THE RTP SCS PROCESS -- AND
TRULY MEANINGFUL INCLUDE UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES AND
REGIONAL AND STATEWIDE
TRANSPORTATION AND LAND USE
PLANNING --SIR VERY MUCH
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE SPONSORS ON THIS BILL AND
INSURING THAT -- EQUITY IS
REALLY CENTERED THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE ANIMALS
BECAUSE WITH CALIFORNIA ROOM TO
JUSTICE ALLIANCE AND IS ECHOING
MY OTHER CONCERNS AND THE
CONCERNS THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE -- MENTIONED REGARDING
JUST REALLY BRING IN EQUITY
REALLY THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD GIVEN THAT
WE ARE ACTUALLY HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH CARBON REALLY
TRYING TO ACTUALLY POST THIS UP
AND WORKING WITH THE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL AND REALLY TRYING TO
REALLY.
ESTABLISH -- OF PLAN THAT'S
GOING TO WORK AND ACTUALLY GOING
TO BE -- IT WOULD ACTUALLY BE
EXECUTED EFFECTIVELY WITH ALL
THE COMMUNITIES CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY LOOKING OUR FRONT
FROM THE COMMUNITIES I SOMETHING
THAT WE SHOULD FOCUS FIRST ON
BEFORE WE ACTUALLY START REALLY
LOOKING AT HOW DO WE DEVELOP
THIS DROUGHT ON THE STATE.
GOOD AFTERNOON NOW -- MATTHEW
BAKER PLANNING CONSERVATION THE
AGAIN STRONG SUPPORT ME THANK
YOU.
SENATOR FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
ON THIS MOVE CRUCIAL OF ISSUES
IT'S ONE OF OUR BIGGEST
CHALLENGES AND ENSURING THAT OUR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE IS
REALLY.
AND INVESTMENTS ARE IN ALIGNMENT
WITH OUR CLIMATE IN EQUITY GOALS.
THERE'S A LOT OF COMPLEXITIES
INVOLVED AND HE FEELS.
GREATLY COMMITTED TO TO WORKING
WITH THE SPONSORS AND THE
RELEVANT AGENCIES NAY APPEARS TO
MAKE SURE WE GET THIS RIGHT
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING BILL MCCALLUM WITH
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR IN
SUPPORT.
I IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THE TWO
MOST IMPORTANT OF OUR MODEL
BILLS THAT PASS FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE WERE A. B. EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY NINE AND GREEN CHEMISTRY
AND SB. THREE SEVENTY FIVE
ELEVEN YEARS LATER WE KNOW THAT
NEITHER OF THEM IS WORKING THE
WAY THAT WE HOPE THAT THEY WOULD.
SO APPRECIATE THAT CENTER ALLEN
IS LOOKING TO REALLY IMPROVE AND
STRENGTHEN.
BOTH OF THOSE AND WE THINK THAT
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT.
AIR QUALITY BILLS OF THIS
SESSION IN ADDITION TO ALL THE
OTHER BENEFITS THAT HAVE BEEN
TALKED ABOUT.
HER NUMBER IS THE KEY TO CREDIT
WITH AN RTC BUT REGISTERED
SUPPORT FOR THREE FIFTY BAY AREA
ACTION AND THREE FIFTY SILICON
VALLEY THINK.
AND ALSO SIERRA CLUB IN SUPPORT
OF JIM LIMBURG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
DAVE SNYDER CALIFORNIA BICYCLE
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HELLO WISEMAN CLIMATE PLAN AND
NETWORK OF MORE THAN FIFTY
ORGANIZATIONS STATEWIDE IN
SUPPORT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS STAFF
AND STAKEHOLDERS OF THE BILL
MOVES TOWARD THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE DíAS O'DONNELL OPPOSITION.
IS THERE OPERATE IS REPETITION --
TO FIVE TO SIX WELL I'VE
NOTIFIED STEPPED UP THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION COUNCILS
OF GOVERNMENT IS OPPOSED NOW --
BEFORE I SUBMIT IT BUT I'D HI I
WANNA PUT IT IT'S THIS IS A
THOUGHTFUL COMMITTEE SO I WANT
TO PUT THIS IDEA IN FRONT.
OUR OPPOSITION IS BASED ON THE
FACT THAT SB.
FIVE TWENTY SIX DOES NOT GO FAR
ENOUGH [inaudible]
IT IT [inaudible]
FOCUSES.
ON AT THE REGION'S BUT THE QUOTE
THAT THE SENATOR READ AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS SAID THAT IT
NEEDS TO BE A STATE REGIONAL AND
LOCAL CHANGE.
HERE'S AN EXAMPLE [inaudible]
WHAT IF?
THE HOUSING GOAL OF BUILDING
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION NEW
HOUSING UNITS IN THE NEXT TEN
YEARS MEANS THAT WORKERS HAVE TO
BUILD TOO MANY HOUSING UNITS.
IN PLACES WHERE ARE SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITY STRATEGY SAY THEY
SHOULDN'T GO BECAUSE WE NEED
BIGGER SEWER PIPES IN THE INFILL
AREAS BUT WE NEED TO HOUSE
PEOPLE AST.
AND WHAT IF THE REASON A REGION
DOESN'T MAKE ITS GOAL IS BECAUSE
HOUSING IS LEAKING TOO MUCH TO
THE SUBURBS BECAUSE OF THAT
POLICY PRESSURE.
THAT'S A PROBLEM PHÃN DECK THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY SAN DIEGO
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS
RECENTLY LOOKED AT PRICING AS A
MEANS.
TO CONSOLIDATE AND ACHIEVE THEIR
GOAL AND WHEN THEY RAN THEIR
PRICING NUMBERS THROUGH THE
TITLE SIX ANALYSIS THEY FOUND
THAT THE PRICING WAS UNFAIR TO
COMMUNITIES OF EQUITY.
THESE ARE GNARLY PROBLEMS THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO BALANCE.
IN THE US BE ONE FIFTY REPORT
SAYS.
NPOS ONLY CONTROL 10% OF THE
MONEY THAT THE PROGRAMMING YET
YOU'RE GOING TO HLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE IN THE STRUCTURE FOR
THE INTERESTINGLY THE SP ONE
FIFTY REPORT.
OMITS ANY MENTION OF THE 6% GAP
BETWEEN THE SB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE TARGETS AND THE SCOPING
PLAN GOAL.
THIS IS A A IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF ADDITIONAL
STATE ACTION.
THERE IS NO FOCUSING FIVE TWENTY
SIX ON THIS POINT IT IS ALL
ABOUT THE MOST BEAUTIFUL MILES
TRAVELED IN A REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLANS.
IF WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION FOR THE VERY GOOD
POLICY REASONS THAT ALTHOUGH
SUPPORTERS MENTIONED LET'S HELP
THE WHOLE LIST TO CONVERSATION.
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE.
AND I'LL PUT A CHALLENGE OUT.
ABOUT A POLICY ISSUE THAT'S OUT
THERE THAT YOU COULD TAKE.
CREDIT FOR RIGHT AWAY.
YOU THE STATE COULD REENACT THE
FIFTY FIVE MILE AN HOUR SPEED
LIMIT AND SAVE SO MUCH FUEL THAT
YOU WOULD PROBABLY ACCOUNT 425%
OF THE GAP BETWEEN THE THREE
SEVENTY FIVE TARGETS.
AND THE 25% DIEM THI REDUCTION
GOAL THAT'S IN THE SCOPING PLANT.
INTO THAT CAN BE EFFECTIVE
JANUARY FIRST IN THE CUMULATIVE --
REDUCTIONS WOULD BE THERE THAT'S
A TOUGH POLITICAL CHOICE BEFORE
GOING TO HAVE THESE NORMALLY
PROGRAMS LET'S HAVE AN HONEST
CONVERSATION ABOUT IT INSTEAD OF
SINGLING OUT REGION'S THAT DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE.
THE CONTROL AS IS REPEATED IN
SEVERAL PLACES IN THE SB ONE
FIFTY REPORT. TO MAKE ALL THE
DECISIONS THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTING FOR IN
THERE ARE ON TRACK TO
TERMINATION.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE SENATOR ON THIS WE WORKED
TOGETHER A ONE FIFTY AND I THINK
THAT THERE ARE SOME REAL ISSUES
TO WRESTLE WITH.
GIVE.
NECKS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS WHERE A TOP ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY THE
BOARD TOOK A POSITION -- OF
OPPOSE LAST WEEK AND WE
APOLOGIZE THAT WAS -- AFTER YOUR
DEADLINE SO -- BUT WE HAVE HAD
SOME INITIAL CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR STAFF AND LOOK
FORWARD TO ADDITIONAL ONES I
JUST WOULD LIKE TO MAKE TWO
POINTS IF I COULD -- THE FIRST
AS MISTER HAGENS ALLUDED TO WEAR
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY -- THE
BILL HAS A LOT OF ALL GOAL THAT
WE COMPLETELY APPRECIATE WHICH
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT --
TRANSPORTATION DECISIONS ARE
LINKED TO TO SMART REGIONAL
PLANNING.
BUT WE DO TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
CONTROL.
OVER LAND USE DECISIONS ANY MORE
THAN THE SCHOOL BOARD DOES ABOUT
WHERE SCHOOL IS LOCATED AND YOU
MIGHT BE FRUSTRATED THAT'S GONNA
BE LOCATED IN A IN A SUBURBAN
AREA.
BUT WE AS A TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY
TO SERVE ALL OF THE CONSTITUENTS
WITHIN ORANGE COUNTY.
AND PROVIDE THEM CONGESTION
RELIEF AND MULTI MODAL
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS WHICH WE
THINK WE DO A REALLY GOOD JOB OF
BUT WE JUST DON'T HAVE THE LAND
USE PLANNING AND SO THE TEETH AT
THIS.
BILL -- INCLUDES IS ARE ENTIRELY
DIRECTED AT TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES THAT HAVE NO CONTROL
OVER A LAND USE DECISIONS.
AND THEN SECONDLY -- IN A MORE
TECHNICAL WAY -- I'D LIKE TO
JUST RAISE THE ISSUE OF V. M. T. --
WE DON'T THINK IT'S A GREAT
BAROMETER OF GHG REDUCTIONS --
FOR EXAMPLE WE ARE VERY PROUD OF
A PROJECT IN AN ORANGE COUNTY
CALLED THE OC STREET CARTS JUST
GETTING OFF THE GROUND AS WELL
JUST IN TERMS OF CONSTRUCTION.
IT IS A BRAND NEW TRANSIT SYSTEM
NOBODY ELSE IS BUILDING TRENT
NEW TRANSIT SYSTEMS THIS IS AN
EXPANSION ONE THIS IS A BRAND
NEW ONE IN ORANGE COUNTY TO
SERVE. ONE OF THE DENSEST AREAS
OF I'M NOT ONLY ORANGE COUNTY
BUT THE NATION AND SANTA ANA
WE'RE INCREDIBLY PROUD OF IT
WE'VE COBBLE TOGETHER FUNDS
THROUGHOUT -- LOCAL MEASURE
MONEY STATE DOLLARS AND FEDERAL
DOLLARS.
BUT THIS PROJECT IRONICALLY AT
LEAST IN TERMS OF THE NARROW
DEFINITION OF THE M. T. FROM ANY
AYE OUR PERSPECTIVE.
INCREASES -- VMT.
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO RE ROUTE
TRAFFIC WE HAVE AN WE HAVE A
COMMUTERS THAT -- GO TO THE END
POINTS AND SO ON A VERY NARROW
DEFINITION IT DOES INCREASE THE
M. T. BUT IT ABSOLUTELY REDUCES
GHG AND AND I THINK IT'S THE
EXACT PROJECT TYPE OF PROJECT --
THAT THIS BODY HAS TALKED ABOUT --
REALLY SUPPORTING AND WANTING TO
I EMPHASIZE IN TERMS OF AN
INCREASE TRANSIT SO AGAIN WE'VE
WE'VE WE'VE HAD INITIAL
CONVERSATIONS WE WOULD REALLY
LIKE TO HAVE CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS AS WE DID ALSO ON
SB -- ONE FIFTY IT'S WORK
THROUGH SOME OF THESE THESE
TOUGH ISSUES. TOO BIG TO FAIL NO --
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION OF SB. FIVE
TWENTY SIX RIGHT LET'S CLOSE
PUBLIC HEARING BRING IT BACK.
TO THE DAIS.
WHAT'S THE AUTHOR -- THE
OPPOSITION HAS FOLK FOCUS AND
SAME RESULT I KNOW IF WE CAN GET.
RICHARD NIXON BACK TO SIGN A
FIFTY FIVE MILE PER HOUR.
YEAH ACTUALLY WE STILL HAVE THE
AUTHORITY.
UNDER THE FACT THAT -- TO NARROW
NOT ENOUGH IN.
IN TOO MUCH FOCUS ON VMT.
OUR WELL LOTS AND LOTS OF GREAT
THINGS AND PACK AND I I
UNDERSTAND THAT WE'VE JUST
GOTTEN A MEETING OF THE
CALIPHATE TWO PM -- TODAY -- FOR
FOR FOLKS TO TALK SHOP ABOUT.
THE NOT YOUROKAY WILL BE
SUPPOSEDLY -- WILL WILL WILL
MAKE IT HAPPEN -- TO TO TO START
WORK ON SOME OF THE THINGS I
MEAN I APPRECIATE THE THE THE
COMMENTS AND I THINK IT IT
SOUNDS AS THOUGH WE'RE ALL.
OF MOVING IN THE SAME CONCEPTUAL
DIRECTION THE QUESTION IS HOW DO
WE CRAFT THIS IN A WAY THAT WILL
ACTUALLY.
YOU GIVE SOME TEETH THAT DESERVE
SOME STRENGTH OF THREE SEVENTY
FIVE AND IF IT IF IT TAKES UP
MORE HOLISTIC APPROACH -- TO THE
STATE LOCAL AND REGIONAL
COMPONENTS.
FOR VERY HAPPY TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION SIMILARLY I MEAN
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED AN
IMPORTANT.
FACTOR BUT I OBSOLETE GREED THAT
IT'S NOT.
THE ONLY FACTOR -- WITH
AGGRESSIVE GIGI FOR CERTAIN I
MEAN IT IT DOES HI DID RELEASE A
CONGESTION AND OTHER KIND OF
IMPORTANT GOALS THAT WE'RE ALL
TRYING TO REACH IT IS WE TRY TO
CREATED A LIVABLE PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA -- BUT THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT -- DID BUT IT'S
NOT THE ONLY FACTOR AND IN FACT
AND IN THE OF FOR THE IN THOSE
AREAS THAT HAVE REALLY.
REALLY GOOD TRANSIT -- YEAH V.
M. T. IT CAN TAKES ON A WHOLE
NOTHER.
IT'S IT'S NOT NOT NOT AS BIG A
PROBLEM SO I'M TOLD.
LET LETS THE DAN -- THIS
AFTERNOON AND AND AND AND IN THE
FUTURE AND AND AND TALK ABOUT
HOW WE CAN ACTUALLY MAKE.
SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE AN
ACTUALITY I MEAN THAT'S REALLY
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE IS IS
GONNA GO BEYOND.
THE THE GOALS AND ACTUALLY TRY
TO IMPLEMENT THE GOALS -- AND
AND I I DO I AM I AM HEARTENED
BY THE THE SENSE THAT I'M
GETTING FROM FROM THE FOLKS OF
TESTIFIED THAT.
EITHER THAT DAY THAT WE SHARE
THE GOAL OF OF OF OF AFFECTION
WAITING SB THREE THIRTY FIVE
WHAT ABOUT THIS POINT THAT THE
SERVER.
MERE TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES AND
THEY DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
MAKE LAND USE DECISIONS WHICH
WHICH WAS CONTEMPLATED IN SB
THREE SEVEN FIVE SO THAT THEY'LL
GET THE HAVE LACK OF A
PARTNERSHIP IN THE MANDATE.
I MEAN WHAT YOU KNOW BUT I'D
COVERING SO THERE'S OF OF
CALPERS GOVERNMENTS.
REPRESENTS CITIES AND COUNTIES
AS WELL NO THERE'S NO DOUBT WE
REPRESENT THE REGIONAL AGENCIES
KNOW OUR BOARD MEMBERS ALL
CITIES COUNTY RIGHT THAT'S YEAH.
THE YEAH WE BUT THEY WILL BE
QUICK THE CITIES AND COUNTIES
WILL BE QUICK TO TELL YOU THAT
THEY'RE NOT SITTING THERE ZONING
AUTHORITY TO THE REGIONAL BOARDS.
RIGHT.
SO THE BILL STILL MAKE
INDIVIDUAL LAND USE DECISIONS --
REGARDLESS.
RIGHT BUT THERE'S NOTHING -- I
MEAN THERE'S NOTHING IN THIS
BILL THAT THAT TAKES THAT AWAY.
NO EXCEPT YOU'RE HOLDING THE
REGION'S ACCOUNTABLE.
FOR FOR THINGS OUTSIDE OF THEIR
SCOPE THAT'S A NEW THAT'S IN
THREE SEVENTY FIVE NO THIS THIS
BILL YOU WOULD YOU'RE ON TRACK
TO TO I'M SORRY THE AND I'M
SORRY I SHOULD BE ASKING THE
CHAIRS MISSION TO SPEAK UP PART.
I JUST REALIZED. FOR IT.
THERE'S A TURN YOU'RE ASKING THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD TO MAKE AND
ALL OF A DETERMINATION OF
WHETHER THEY ARE ON TRACK OR NOT
WITHOUT AN ANALYSIS OF WHY THEY
ARE ON OR OFF TRACK.
AND AND THAT COULD BE -- FOR IT
COULD BE FOR WHERE HOUSING IS
LOCATED IT COULD BE BECAUSE THE
ECONOMY WAS DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
WE FORECASTED THERE ARE A
VARIETY OF REASONS AND OUR
LETTER WILL SPELL OUT THE
DIFFERENT QUOTES THAT ARE IN THE
SB ONE FIFTY REPORT.
THAT SPECIFICALLY SAY WHY AM P.
O.'S DON'T HAVE CONTROL OVER
EVERYTHING IN THERE ARE TPS YET.
RIGHT CENTER ON YOUR FOR YOUR
WHAT YOU GUYS I LOVE JUST TO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY IF I MAY
JUST VERY QUICKLY.
WE WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE STATE
HAS A A NUMBER OF GUIDELINES AND
REQUIREMENTS ON STATE DOLLARS
THAT GO TO REGIONS -- THIS IS AN
ATTEMPT. TO AT LEAST FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE TO TO FORTIFY AT THE
STATE GUIDELINES AND AND TO
BEGIN.
TO CONNECT THE STATE GUIDELINE
ABOUT AN ISSUE THAT IS VERY
IMPORTANT -- CLIMATE CHANGE.
I'M.
INTO REGIONAL DOLLARS THAT ARE
THAT WAY INTO STATE DOLLARS THAT
GO TO REGIONS SO WE'RE NOT
ASKING -- FOR NECESSARILY FOR
ADDRESSING ALL OF THOSE BUT IF
IF THE OPPOSITION IS IS
INTERESTED IN A YOU KNOW THING
IS NOT GOING FAR ENOUGH AND IT'S
A YES AND THEN YEAH I THINK THAT
REALLY HELPS THE CONVERSATION.
TO BUT TO TO LOOK AT THIS
RELATIVELY SMALL.
POT OF MONEY ADMITTEDLY HERE --
BY THE BY THE OPPOSITION IN THE
STEP -- 10% OF THE DOLLARS TO
SAY WELL YOU KNOW MAYBE WE START
THERE MAYBE WE START WHERE THE
MAJORITY OF STATE DOLLARS THAT
GO TO EXPANSION OF ROADWAYS.
BECAUSE OTHER DOLLARS FOR THEIR
STATE DOLLARS LIKE SHOP IN OTHER
MAINTENANCE DOLLARS THOSE DON'T
GO TO THE ROADWAY EXPANSIONS ARE
ALMOST NEVER -- BUT THE THE STEP
IS THAT KIND OF THAT TWEAKING
POINT RATE IT'S NOT A LOT OF
MONEY BUT IT DOES.
SET A LEVEL OF GUIDELINES AND IT
COMES WITH STATE GUIDELINES AND
IT COMES WITH A A REQUIREMENT
THAT THAT WE LOOK AT INTER
REGIONAL IMPACTS AND WE LOOK AT
YOU KNOW REGIONAL IMPACTS FROM
STATE DOLLARS.
SO WE FELT THAT THAT WAS A GOOD
STARTING POINT. TO TO USE THE
STEP BECAUSE IT GOES HEAVILY TO
ROAD EXPANSION RIGHT NOW THAT IS
CONTRARY TO OUR STATE GOALS AND
OUR STATE AND OUR INTENTIONS I
THINK AND AND COUNTRY REALLY TO
OVERALL WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
WILL OF CALIFORNIANS IN
ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE.
I AM AS THE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT
IT DOESN'T.
KNOCK YOU OFF THE LIST AND
STEPPED JUST DROPS YOU DOWN SO
THEIR PRECIOUS FUNDS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE IN THE ABILITY. TO TO
COMPLETE A PROJECT.
OPPOSITION YOU HAVE SOMETHING
ELSE TO ADD -- IF YOU COULD
CLARIFY SIR JUST VERY BRIEFLY
YOU ASKED THE QUESTION ABOUT --
THE ITS CONNECTION TO SB THREE
SEVENTY FUND OF IT THREE SEVENTY
FIVE AND AND WHETHER OR NOT THIS
IS SIMPLY -- TAGGING ON TO AND
PUTTING TEETH INTO WHAT WE HAD --
PREVIOUSLY OR WHAT WHAT WHAT IS
THE LAW TODAY.
AND I THINK THE IT'S A HUGE --
DISTINCTION THAT IS WORTHY OF OF
CONVERSATION AND THAT IS.
ON THE WHOLE -- PREMISE OF SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE AND WE
THOUGHT IT WAS VALUABLE IS THAT
YOU GIVE US A GOAL AND I THINK
IT'S A REASONABLE QUESTION ABOUT
HOW HOW WE MET AT AS A REGION.
BUT YOU CAN GIVE US A CALL AND
WE MADE IT NOT ON A PROJECT BY
PROJECT BASIS BUT ON A ON A
STRATEGY BASIS AND THAT WAS
WRONG THAT'S THAT'S WHY IT'S
CALLED A A AN SCS.
A STRATEGY BECAUSE IF YOU START
PICKING APART INDIVIDUAL
PROJECTS YOU'LL END UP WITH THE
VI<c.cyan> WITH THE TRANSIT PROJECT</c>
THAT HAS AN INCREASE IN THE
EMPTY YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
EVERYTHING HOLISTICALLY.
AND SAID THAT THAT THIS BILL
DOES MAKE A HUGE DEPARTURE FROM
SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE THAT WAS
TO LOOK AT THE GLOBAL PICTURE OF
WHAT ALL THESE PROJECTS LOOK
LIKE.
IN COMBINATION.
AND AND THEN AND THEN EVALUATE
THEM AND I THINK IT'S COMPLETELY
UNFAIR TO TALK ABOUT WHAT THE
EVALUATION.
BUT WHEN YOU START THIS BILL
PICKED APART INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS
AND WE THINK THAT'S A BIG
DIFFERENCE.
I THINK -- I WILL MAKE A MOTION
SINCE I'M THE ONLY PERSON HERE
ON THE BILL -- AND I WILL ALLOW
YOU -- SENT AROUND TO CLOSE.
YEAH.
I MEAN THERE ARE SOME.
I I I I YEAH I'VE BLUFF LET LET
LET ME THEM WE'RE WE'RE NOW IT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A CONVERSATION
THIS AFTERNOON -- THAT THERE ARE
SOME -- THIS AGREEMENT THAT I
HAVE ABOUT ABOUT THE OF A WE WE
CAN PARTS APART WHO'S MAKING THE
DECISIONS ABOUT INDIVIDUAL
DEVELOPMENTS AND AND HOW THAT
FITS INTO THE STRATEGY AND AND
WILL BE ALLOWED TO LET LET'S
LET'S HAVE THAT ROBUST
CONVERSATION IS NO QUESTION THAT
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES.
WE HAVE HERE LIKE WE I WAS SO
MANY THINGS WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IN THIS COMMITTEE IT INVOLVES
THE MULTI JURISDICTIONAL WEARING
OF OF REGIONAL ORGANIZATIONS
COUNTY CITIES -- SPECIAL
DISTRICTS AND EVERYBODY ELSE IN
BETWEEN AND IT DOES MAKE IT ALL
VERY CHALLENGING AND I THINK
WE'RE TRYING TO COME UP WITH
SOME SORT OF FEASIBLE WAY OF
ADDRESSING WHAT WE KNOW IS A
REAL PROBLEM BUT BUT LET'S LET'S.
LET'S TRY TO HONE IT IN A WAY
THAT -- WE CAN YOU KNOW FIND
MUTUALLY ACCEPTABLE AND
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION
APPRECIATE THAT THE THE EMPLOYED
AND AND AND WE HAVE CERTAINLY DO
HOPE THAT THIS COMMITTEE WILL
GIVE ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS.
ASSISTANCE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
YES ADAM NUMBER FOURTEEN SB.
FIVE TO SIX THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
ALLEN ALLEN NAY BATES
[inaudible]
PHIL.
SKINNER.
STERN STONE.
BY CASKEY AYE AYE CASKEY I'D PUT
THAT MATTER ON HOLD FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THAT'S MOVED
TO OUR LAST -- ITEM TODAY THIS
IS SB. SIX SIX EIGHTY TWO ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN REGARDING.
RADIATIVE FORCING MANAGEMENT
CLIMATE ACCOUNTING PROTOCOL.
THIS IS A BILL THAT YOU KNOW
ONLY ARCHER EMERITUS COULD LOVE --
YES IT IS THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING EARLIER ABOUT -- CLIMB
IT.
IN A PARTICULAR IT AND A WHAT WE
ALWAYS SEEM TO TALK ABOUT IS
CARBON -- GIGI -- BUT THERE
THERE ARE OTHER WAYS OF LOOKING
AT THE CLIMATE CHALLENGE AND
WHEN ASKED TO DO -- WITH
TEMPERATURE.
IN HEAT.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL SEEKS
TO TO TO ADD TO THE CARB TOOL
KIT -- SO.
SO.
YOU KNOW.
WHEN WHEN WHEN THE I. P. C. C.
THE INTERGOVERNMENTAL PANEL ON
CLIMATE CHANGE I KNOW THAT THE-TERM ARTIST AS WELL?
I NEEDED TALKS ABOUT THE
PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED CLIMATE
CHANGE IT REALLY FOCUSES ON HOW
CRUCIAL IS THAT WE KEEP GLOBAL
AVERAGE TEMPERATURES.
WITHIN ONE POINT FIVE DEGREES
CELSIUS OF WHERE THEY ARE NOW TO
AVOID.
A RUNAWAY WARMING AFFECTS.
AND SO I SO AS PART OF THAT --
IT IT'S REALLY GOTTEN PEOPLE TO
FOCUS IN ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
CLIMATE STABILIZATION AND AND
SPECIFICALLY YOU KNOW -- THOSE
CRITICAL NEAR TERM ACTIONS WE
CAN TAKE TO REDUCE ACCESS HEAT
IN THE ATMOSPHERE.
SO WE WE TALK A LOT ABOUT THE
GASES AND THERE'S AN IN A
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE HEAT.
BUT BUT BUT THE THE QUESTION IF
HE IS A IS A A SEPARATE
STANDALONE IMPORTANT ISSUE FIRST
LOOK AT SO.
WHAT ALL THIS BILL DOES
ULTIMATELY IS GIVE THE A. R. B.?
I. THE NEEDED ANALYTIC TOOLS TO
CONSIDER HEAT IN THE ATMOSPHERE
IS PART OF THE CONVERSATION --
SO.
YOU DID JUST TO KIND OF GOING TO
EXPLAIN THIS A LITTLE BIT OF FOR
THE FOLKS CAN UNDERSTAND WE TALK
ABOUT GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
WE USUALLY USE NUMBERS THAT
CONSIDER THE IMPACTS OF THOSE.
GASES OVER THE NEXT HUNDRED
YEARS THAT'S THAT'S REFERRED TO
AS A GAS IS GLOBAL WARMING
POTENTIAL.
AND WHILE LONG TERM IMPACTS ARE
ESSENTIAL FOR MAKING GOOD PUBLIC
POLICY DECISIONS.
I WILL HAVE TO FACE THE FACT IF
WE DON'T KEEP WARMING AND JACK
WILL CONTINUE TO FACE PROBLEMS
CAUSED BY.
GLOBAL WARMING EVEN NOW.
AND ANSWER THIS QUESTION IS THIS
ISSUE OF RADIATIVE FORCING IT'S
A MEASURE.
OF HOW MUCH HE IS TRAPPED IN A
SPECIFIC AREA AT A SPECIFIC TIME.
AS COMPARED TO GLOBAL WARMING
POTENTIAL A RADIATIVE FORCING
LETS US CAN CONSIDER LOCAL FAX.
OF THINGS LIKE SMOKE LAND USE
CHANGES RESIDUAL MISSIONS.
OUR RADIO FORCING AND GLOBAL
WARMING POTENTIAL.
WILL IDEALLY WORK HAND IN HAND --
IN GIVING US A BETTER PICTURE OF
CHANGES THAT WE CAN -- THEN --
MAKE THAT WILL BOTH AFFECT
GLOBAL GLOBAL CLIMATE NOW BUT
ALSO GLOBAL CLIMATE.
IN THE FUTURE SO THIS BILL HELPS
TO MAINTAIN CALIFORNIA.
I IN ITS LEADERSHIP ROLE IN
UNDERSTANDING CLIMB IMPLY
IMPACTS OF HUMAN ACTIONS BY
MOVING BEYOND JUST THE ISSUE OF
JEWISH SEASON CARBON -- AND AND
LOOKING AT A RADIO FORCING AND
HE AND WITH ME TODAY ARE JO
CAVES IN THE CONSERVATION
STRATEGY GROUP ALSO TAUGHT
DELANEY WAS.
A DOCTOR AT PROFESSOR AND AND
CHAIR OF THE CLIMATE CHANGE
CORNING COMMITTEE AT THE
INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR
STANDARDIZATION AND THEY'RE BOTH
GOING TO TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF THE SUPPORT MEASURE.
A MISTER CHAIRMAN JOE CAVES --
CONSERVATION STRATEGY GROUP --
JUST VERY BRIEFLY SO THIS BILL
IS SMALL IT'S TECHNICAL BUT IT'S
VERY SIGNIFICANT.
IN THAT IT STARTS THE PROCESS OF
ALIGNING CALIFORNIA WITH THE
LATEST SCIENCE AND PARTICULARLY
pWITH REGARD TO THE IPCC'S
WARNING ABOUT THE URGENCY TO
MOVE QUICKLY.
ON HEAT REDUCTION OUR EXISTING
PROGRAM UNDER AB THIRTY TWO IS
DOING WHAT WE NEEDED TO DO LONG
TERM TO REDUCE THIS YEAR TO
BUILD UP.
BUT IT WILL NOT REACH THE GOALS
THE I. P. C. C. IS IDENTIFIED OF
REDUCING RADIATIVE FORCING THAT
HEAT BUILD UP BETWEEN NOW AND
TWENTY THIRTY ESTABLISHING A
STANDARD TO EVALUATE THAT WILL
GIVE CARVE THE TOOLS.
REALLY TO DESIGN THE IMMEDIATE
PROGRAM WE NEED IT'LL HELP DRIVE
GLOBAL PROGRESS IF CALIFORNIA
BEGINS THAT PROCESS AS WELL AS
IDENTIFY THE THINGS WE CAN DO
HERE. TO HELP DEAL WITH THE HEAT
BUILD UP THAT WE'RE SEEING AS A
AFFECT BOTH REGIONALLY AND
GLOBALLY.
AND INCREASED -- WILDFIRES AND
THE WHOLE HOST OF IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE THEIR CURRENT
QUICKLY SO WE URGE AN AYE VOTE.
NEXT CHAIR.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK BEFORE THIS DISTINGUISHED
COMMITTEE.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR ALAN FOR AUTHORING FOR
THIS LEGISLATION.
MY NAME IS TODD DELANEY.
I CHAIR THE INTERNATIONAL
CLIMATE CHANGE COORDINATING
COMMITTEE.
ESTABLISHED BY AYSO THE
INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR
STANDARDIZATION.
WHICH PROVIDES GUIDANCE ON
CLIMATE RELATED STANDARDS AND
HELPS TO ENSURE THE
INTERNATIONAL STANDARDS SUPPORT
A ROBUST RESPONSE TO CLIMATE
CHANGE.
DESPITE THE INTERNATIONAL
EFFORTS TO DATE CLIMATE CHANGE
CONTINUES TO ACCELERATE.
CALIFORNIA IS SUFFERING ITS OWN
SHARE OF CLIMATE RELATED IMPACTS
DROUGHTS FLOODS MUD SLIDES.
IN FIRES WHICH HAVE IMPACTED
MANY OF YOUR DISTRICTS.
BUT THERE'S MORE TO BE DONE A
CRITICAL NEXT STEP.
IS THE ADOPTION OF THE RADIATIVE
FORCING BASED CLIMATE PROTOCOL
TO COMPLEMENT CURRENT CLIMATE
ACCOUNTING EFFORTS.
AYSO RELIES ON IPCC -- REPORTS
AS NORMATIVE RESTAURANT
REFERENCES TO ENSURE THE
INTERNATIONAL STANDARDS ARE
BASED UPON MOST UP TO DATE
SCIENCE.
I AM CONVENING THE ICE SO EFFORT.
TO STANDARDIZE THE RADIATIVE
FORCING ACCOUNTING PROTOCOL
DERIVED FROM IPCC'S FIFTH
ASSESSMENT REPORT.
THIS IS SIMILAR TO HOW THE GW P.
ONE HUNDRED ACCOUNTING PROTOCOL
WAS DEVELOPED FROM THE IPCC'S
SECOND ASSESSMENT REPORT.
IN THE MID NINETEEN NINETIES THE
PROTOCOL HAS ALREADY BEEN
REVIEWED BY LEADING U. S.
SCIENTISTS AND CLIMATE AND CLEAN
AIR COALITION SCIENTIFIC
ADVISORY PANEL.
IS PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
TECHNICAL REVIEW.
ADOPTING A RADIATIVE FORCING
BASED PROTOCOL THROUGH SB SIX
EIGHTY TILL TWO WILL ALLOW.
WILL REINFORCE CALIFORNIA'S
POSITION AS AN INTERNATIONAL
LEADER ON CLIMATE CHANGE.
SETTING THE STAGE TO HELP THE
WORLD AVOID OVERSHOOTING GLOBAL
TEMPERATURE TARGETS.
THIS PROTOCOL BRINGS GREATER
TRANSPARENCY TO THE FACTORS
INFLUENCING OUR CLIENTS.
ARE CLIMATE IMPROVES METRICS IN
NEW INSIGHTS TO PRIORITIZE
MITIGATION ACTIONS THAT MOST
EFFECTIVELY AND COST EFFECTIVELY
CAN.
STABILIZE CLIMATE ESPECIALLY
BELOW BETWEEN NOW IN.
TWENTY THIRTY THE WORLD IS
RUNNING OUT OF TIME IF SB SIX
EIGHTY TWO IS PASSED INTO LAW
THIS YEAR IT WILL LOW CARB. TO
EVALUATE AND IMPLEMENT THE
PROTOCOL WITHIN THE NEXT FEW
YEARS.
THIS WOULD REINFORCE THE
ADOPTION.
OF THIS PROTOCOL BY OTHER
COUNTRIES WHO ARE LOOKING TO
CALIFORNIA'S EXPERTISE AND
LEADERSHIP FOR GUIDANCE.
KNOWING HOW LONG IMPLEMENTATION
OF ANY REGULATORY CHANGES CAN
TAKE.
I BELIEVE SB SIX EIGHTY TWO
COULD SPEED UP GLOBAL ADOPTION
BY AS MUCH AS FIVE YEARS.
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS TIMING
CANNOT BE OVERSTATED THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME ARE YOUR TO YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF SB -- SIX
EIGHT TWO SIX EIGHT TWO GOOD
AFTERNOON AND GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME'S LOVE CARDIO CORTESE AND I
WAS ASKED BY DOCTOR JUSHIN DEL
WHO'S THE ONE OF THE LEAD.
COORDINATING AUTHORS ON THE
FIFTH ANNUAL ASSESSMENT BY ABOUT
THE I. P. C. C. AS WELL AS THE
ONE POINT FIVE REPORT.
AS WELL AS COMMITTEE CHAIR OF
THE SEE SEE A OF SEE SEE A WHICH
IS THE CLIMATE AND AIR RECENT
RESORT INTERNATIONAL CLIMATE
RENEE RESOURCE COMMITTEE -- AND
HE URGES HIS SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HI I'M LINDA BROWN AND I'M HERE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF DOCTOR
MICHAEL MCCRACKEN.
HE IS A CAREER HE WAS A CAREER
CLIMATE RESEARCHER AND LEAD
SCIENTIST FOR AT LAWRENCE
LIVERMORE NATIONAL LABORATORY --
HE WAS ALSO THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE BODY THE%
NATIONAL -- ASSESSMENT
COORDINATION OFFICE WHICH
CREATED THE FIRST NATIONAL
CLIMATE ASSESSMENT REPORT YOU
KNOW THAT THE FOURTH ONE WAS
JUST ISSUED.
AND HE WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
FIRST ONE HE WAS ALSO -- AN
ADVISER TO THE US DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY ON CLIMATE RESEARCH AND
HAS HAD MANY OTHER IMPORTANT
CLIMATE POST INCLUDING HIS IS
VERY -- PROBLEMS PROLIFIC ON
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE IPCC.
AND HE IS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS -- BILL SIR THANK YOU HE
WANTS TO LET YOU KNOW THAT HE'S
STANDING BY TO BE OF ASSISTANCE
IN ANY WAY HE CAN.
MY NAME IS JIM WILSON AND I'M
HERE TODAY FOR DOCTOR ROBERT
HOWARTH OF CORNELL UNIVERSITY IN
IPCC'S SCIENTIST AND RENOWNED.
METHANE EXPERT.
WHO'S ASKED ME TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR SENATE BILL SIX
EIGHTY TWO ON HIS BEHALF.
AND OFFERED TO MAKE HIMSELF
AVAILABLE TO YOU IS NEEDED.
I THANK YOU -- I'VE NEVER HAD SO
MANY AGENTS FOR SINCE RE
RESEARCH SCIENTISTS -- LET'S
HEAR OPPOSITION -- TO A. B. R.
SB. SIX EIGHT TWO IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE OPPOSED
[inaudible]
TO THE MEASURE.
RIGHT LET'S BRING IT BACK CLOSE
THE PUBLIC HEARING BRING BACK TO
DAIS [inaudible]
THERE IS.
ANYBODY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS --
Là AB ONE IN THERE I'M I
APPRECIATE THE THE CREATIVITY
BEHIND.
THE THE MEASURE IN MORE THAN
THAT JUST THE THE BRAIN POWER --
IT'S INTIMIDATING YEAH SO I
DON'T EVEN KNOW.
HOW TO ASK A QUESTION -- THAT
LIVES UP TO THE LEVEL OF
RESEARCH THAT HAS BEEN.
GOING ON WITH IN THIS PROCESS
AND TO ALL BEEN LEADING I JUST.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT.
WHAT BEYOND BEYOND IT BEYOND
SORT OF BETTER TRUTH IN
ACCOUNTING OR OR A BIT YOU KNOW
MORE HONEST NUMBERS?
DO YOU SEE THIS ACTUALLY.
ALLOWING US TO HAVE IS THIS
ABOUT LIKE SORT OF MAKE OUR
STRATEGY MORE ORGANIZED AND
COHERENT AND SORT OF ALIGNMENT
BASIC CROSS SHORT LIVED AND LONG
LIVED -- TYPES OF POLLUTANTS OR
IS THIS ABOUT SORT OF ORGANIZING
AND COHERENCE IN THOSE EFFORTS
OR IS IT ARE WE MISSING THINGS
RIGHT NOW IN OUR ACCOUNTING THAT
WE WE AT WE DON'T EVEN TRULY
UNDERSTAND.
THE THE THE GRAVITY OF THE
PROBLEM WE'RE FACING.
YOUR YOUR CHOICE CENTER ON WHAT
WELLNESS WHICH LIKE THAT.
I THINK I THINK I THINK THAT'S I
THINK THAT'S THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT I LOVE TO
HAVE -- THE TO EXPRESS COMMENT
ON THAT.
I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT ON BOTH
COUNTS -- WE THINK THAT THIS
KIND OF ACCOUNTING WILL WILL RE
PRIORITIZE VERTICALLY IN THE
SHORT LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS
AS WELL AS IDENTIFY OTHER
ACTIONS WE CAN TAKE.
BECAUSE THE URGENCY OF STARTING
TO THAT PROCESS OF FIGURING OUT
HOW TO BRING DOWN HEAT AS WELL
AS PROVIDING CARBS EXPERTISE
THAT CAN THEN BE.
USED BY OTHER COUNTRIES AND SORT
OF THE DRIVE THE MOMENTUM
INTERNATIONALLY BECAUSE WE NEED
THAT TO HAPPEN AS WELL. NINE
IDOLING LIKE TO AGREE -- TO WITH
THAT AND WHAT I'M CURRENTLY
DOING IS WE'RE STARTING UNDER
THE INTERNATIONAL STANDARDS
ORGANIZATION.
IS IN FACT THE WITHIN THE NEXT --
THREE WEEKS WILL BE HAVING OUR
FIRST MEETING ON ABOUT A THIRTY
FIVE PAGE DOCUMENT THE DEAL
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE RADIATIVE
FORCING.
A AND R. PROCESS WILL TAKE US
ABOUT EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO GO
THROUGH SO THAT WE WILL HAVE A
GUIDANCE STANDARD THAT WILL BE.
AVAILABLE FOR THE REST OF THE
WORLD WE'RE PRIMARILY MADE UP OF
COUNTRIES AS OPPOSED TO STATE --
AND SO THIS WILL PROVIDE THE
FOUNDATION.
THAT WHEN IT COMES TO CARVE THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO EIGHT USE THIS
AND IMPLEMENTED IN.
WHATEVER WAY THEY CHOOSE BUT
THEY WILL HAVE ALL OF THE BASES
FOR BEING ABLE TO IMPLEMENT.
I WOULD JUST SAY YOU KNOW.
WE DON'T WANT THE PROBLEM TO BE
ANY WORSE THAN WE THINK IT IS
BECAUSE IT GETS WORSE EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
BUT WE ALSO CAN'T LIGHT OR SELF.
SO.
I JUST WHAT WE WANT THE BEST
POSSIBLE SCIENCE DRIVING STATE
POLICY AYE I KNOW THAT THERE'S
GOING TO THE THE THE NUANCES TO
IMPLEMENTATION AND THERE'S
EXISTING PROGRAMS GOING ON IN
THE SCIENCE.
YOU'RE DRILLING DOWN THERE'S AN
EIGHTEENTH MONTH PROCESS BEIGE
APPRECIATE YOU DRIVING THIS
FORWARD SAID AROUND THIS IS THE
MEDIAN FORCED THE CONVERSATION
NOT RADIATIVE LEE FORCING THE
CONVERSATION MAYBE -- I'M GLAD
WE CAN IS IT THAT WE NEED A
LITTLE LEVITY THESE DAYS IN THIS
IN THIS ARENA OF POLICY BUT I
WANT TO JOIN YOU IF YOU WHEN YOU
TAKEN IF YOU TAKE A MOMENT ON
THE ROAD AS CO AUTHOR AND HELP
YOU ALONG YOUR BECAUSE I THINK.
IT'S A VERY WHERE THE
CONVERSATION THANKS ALMOST THE
BILL INAPPROPRIATE THERE IS A
MOTION WE RECOGNIZE IT CENTER
YOU MAY CLOSE.
WELL I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU
SENATOR -- I SPENT LITERALLY
SEVERAL HOURS LAST NIGHT PORING
OVER THE STUFF AND I THINK YOU
I'M SURE YOU DID SPEND AS MUCH
TIME YET YOU SEEMS TO OF QUICKLY
ZEROED IN OUR TRYING TO GET OUT
HERE.
DO YOU DO IT'S BASICALLY.
WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT THE
QUESTION OF CLIMATE CHANGE THERE
ONE PARTICULAR LANDS IT'S AN
IMPORTANT LINES BUT THERE ARE
OTHER LENSES THROUGH WHICH TO
LOOK AT IT AND AND AND AND AND
WE WE WE KNOW WE'RE MISSING SOME
THINGS AS A RESULT OF THE
APPROACH THAT WE'VE TAKEN -- AND
AND THIS THIS WILL JUST GIVE THE
CARBON NEW ANALYTICAL TOOL TO
HELP US BE MORE HOLISTIC IN OUR
PRECIOUS.
ACCIDENTAL CHALLENGE AND SO WITH
THAT I I RESPECTFULLY ****
COMMITTEE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ASSISTANCE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
IN ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN SB.
SIX EIGHT TWO M. F. THERE.
M..
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WATER COMMITTEE ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE A BAIT [inaudible]
HEALTH [inaudible]
SKINNER.
STERN ALL RIGHT STERN AYE STONE.
WIECKOWSKI HI MY CAL SKI I WILL
KEEP THE MATTER OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS AND I'LL RETURN TO GAVEL
TO THE CHAIR.
OKAY SO THAT COMPLETES OUR
CALENDAR -- LET'S NOW TAKE UP TO
TO OPEN THE LIST TO CALL SO THAT
FOLKS CAN ADD ON AND I CENTER
STERN CAN ADD ON LET'S START OUT
WITH THE START WITH YEAH.
SO ITEM NUMBER ONE A STERN
THIRTY VOTED FOR THAT OKAY SO
WE'RE GOOD ITEM TO THIS IS
GALGIANI SB SIXTY EIGHT CARE IS
AYE FASTER AS I HELLO -- SECOND
HILL SKINNER.
STERN STERN AYE OKAY IT'S A
LITTLE THAT OPEN FOR CENTER
SKINNER TO ADD ON NOW WE'LL GO
TO ITEM NUMBER THREE THAT'S SP
ONE SIXTY SIX IT'S BOTH BY TURN
BY A VICE CHAIR I SKINNER.
STERN STERN AYE A CABLE THAT
OPEN FOR CENTER SKINNER.
LET'S NOW GO [inaudible] TWO
ITEM SEVEN THIS IS SB THREE
THIRTY TWO HERTZBERG SPELL --
TEARS AYE ADVISORS I VOTED
[inaudible]
AND BATES [inaudible]
SKINNER.
STERN STERN AYE.
OKAY WE'LL HOLD IT OPEN FOR
CENTERS BATES AND SKINNER TO ADD
ON I THINK THAT.
WE HAVE ITEM FOURTEEN THIS IS SB --
FIVE TWENTY SIX TEARS I ADVISED
HER NOT VOTING.
IN AN BATES [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
SKINNER.
STERN STERN AYE STONE.
NO.
NO NO.
OKAY.
EARN YESTER IS THERE AND I DON'T
KNOW RIGHT TO HOLD THAT OPEN
FURTHER -- BATES HELEN SKINNER
DOWN ON AND AND NOW LET'S GO.
THAT COMPLETES THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND SINISTER
[inaudible]
DELIVERY.
THE VERY VERY FIRST AND SECOND --
NO YOU HAVEN'T.
IN TERMS OF CONSENT CALENDAR AND
SKINNER.
STERN STERN HI OKAY I THINK
YOU'RE ALL SET THE CENTER STERN
LET'S NOT GO BACK TO THE RULES
OF CENTER STONE CAN ADD ON TO
WHATEVER HE NEEDS TO ADD ON TO
OKAY SERVICE IN THE RIVER FOR
THAT.
I AM.
SIXTEEN I AM SIXTEEN THIS IS SB.
SIX EIGHTY TWO AND THEN ELEVEN
TEN AS WELL I THINK -- THE
LINKEDIN.
I DON'T AND IS A MEMBER SAYS A
FOUR HUNDRED ENGINE.
ITEM TEN SB [inaudible]
FOUR HUNDRED HILL [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
STONE.
YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT VOTING ON A
NUMBER.
OKAY OKAY OKAY SO THEN -- THE
ITEM. SIXTEEN THIS IS A MY SB
SIX EIGHTY TWO THAT WE JUST
HEARD [inaudible]
AB [inaudible]
EIGHT HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER.
STONE STONE NO.
OKAY SO I THINK THAT.
COMPLETES THE WORK OF THE TV
WORLD GOING TO RECESS AND WELL
WE GET THE OTHER MEMBERS COME
.
NUMBER ONE THIS IS A THE FORTY
FIVE THE YEAH TEARS RUNNING I RC.
SHIVERING I BET AND FASTER NOT
VOTING HILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
OKAY. TO THAT IS I AM ONE LET'S
NOW MOVE WE'RE GONNA LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR CENTER STUDENT AT ON
LET'S.
KEEP LOOKING FOR HELLO ITEM SIX
I THINK IS.
A FELONY THAT ON ITS SB.
THREE SEVENTEEN COVER EURO.
AS CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING I
HILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER. 11% OR SKINNER.
ITEM TEN THIS IS -- SP FOUR
HUNDRED DECEMBER JUST BEFORE
HUNDRED A TERRIBLE IDEA. SEVENTY
NINE ADVISED HER NOT VOTING HILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER.
OKAY WE'LL HOLD IT OPEN FOR
CENTER SKINNER.
AND NOW ITEM TWELVE THIS IS
COVER YOUR EYES AS BEFORE
FOURTEEN CHAIR INVESTOR VOTING
AYE.
HILL.
HILL I OKAY -- SEVEN ZERO THAT
IS CLOSED -- WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN OUR AND NOW WE'LLGO TO ITEM
FOURTEEN IS SB.
FIVE TWENTY SIX SIR VOTING I BY
STIRRED THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
OF A FAITH.
HILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER.
HELLO YOU HAVE OPENED FOR CENTER
SKINNER AND CENTER BATES TO ADD
ON AT SEVEN FORTY NINE NEXT --
WE GO TO ITEM SIXTEEN THIS IS --
SB -- SIX EIGHTY TWO ALLEN
FUTURE BY [inaudible]
M. BATES.
HELLO.
HILL I AM.
THANK YOU CENTER [inaudible]
OKAY GREAT.
WILL WILL -- WE'RE WE'VE WAITING
STILL FOR CENTERS -- FOR SEVERAL
OTHER CENTERS GET IN.
STATE SKINNER BATES
[inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY WHAT'S GOOD VIBES
UNDERSTAND OPPORTUNITY OUT ON TO
OUR VARIOUS BILLS.
SO WHEN START WITH.
I WANT THIS IS A SB FORTY FIVE
GREAT -- AT CHAIR VOTING I VICE
YOU'RE NOT VOTING.
FOR ONE THIS GUY SKINNER I CLOSE.
WE WILL.
CLOSE THE WRONG ITEM.
ONE THIS IS NOW ITEM TO SB SIXTY
EIGHTH.
YOUR MASTER BUST BOTH VOTING AYE.
AM SKINNER RIGHT. TO A CLOSE THE
ROLE ON THAT.
THAT BRINGS US TO ITEM THREE IS
SB.
ONE SIXTY SIX CHAIRED BY SIR
BOTH VOTING AYE SKINNER AYE
SKINNER AYE.
OKAY WE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ON
THAT ITEM THAT.
SEVEN ZERO NOW BRINGS NOT ITEM.
WE HAVE SKINNER AND THAT OKAY
SPRING JUST ITEM.
SIX THIS IS THE SB THREE
SEVENTEEN COVER EURO.
SURE VOTING I'VE VICE CHAIR
VOTING I SKINNER.
SKINNER HI.
OKAY LIKE COMPLETE THAT WILL
CALL THE ROLL ON THAT.
ITEM TEN THIS IS THAT'S BEFORE
HUNDRED NUMBER -- IS BEING YOU
NEED EITHER SEVEN SB THREE SORRY
TO HEAR THAT.
I AM OKAY THE ITEM SEVEN SB
THREE THREE TWO CHAIR OF VOTING
I BY STRAHAN'S NOT VOTED SKINNER
HI.
CAN I OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA LEAVE
THAT OPEN FOR CENTER BATES TO
ADD ON HI THIS ITEM TEN SP FOUR
HUNDRED AMBER.
CHAIR VOTING I FACE YOU'RE NOT
VOTING SKINNER.
SKINNER I OKAY WE'RE GONNA A
CLOSE THE ROLE ON THAT AND IT'S
FIVE ZERO OKAY -- AND AND IF YOU
THINK HONOR THAT.
ONE OKAY SO LET'S LOOK AT THE
FOURTEEN YES THE LAST BE.
FIVE TWENTY SIX PROVIDING I'VE
AYE STERN OF VOTING YET.
RIGHT SKINNER HI BATES.
WITH 11% OR BATES [inaudible]
THAT'S LEFT OPEN AND ITEM
SIXTEEN IS SB -- SIX EIGHTY TWO
VISORS NEVER GET THE CHAIR HAS
VOTED FOR IT [inaudible]
M. BATES SKINNER RIGHT SKINNER I
AM.
THEN CONSENT.
IN THE CONSENT CALENDAR FINALLY.
AND FOR THE CAN SECOND THERE --
I THINK YOU'RE THE ONLY ONE WHO
IS NOT YET VOTED FOR IT.
LISTEN WE HAVE WE CAN IN YOURS.
KATE AT YOUR WEDDING I RICE
RIVETING I FIVE ZERO SKINNER.
RIGHT SKINNER AYE OKAY.
SO THAT'S A SEVEN ZERO CALDERON
CONSENT COUNTER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR THANK YOU
SO SURGERY WHAT WHAT ARE THE
BILLS WE STILL HAVE YET WE'RE WE
WILL BE THE RIVER BECAUSE THEY
CENTER BATES.
HE'S ONE OF ACT HOW MANY BILLS
WE HAVE FIRM. FOUR FOUR OKAY.
OKAY WELL WELL.
WELL WAY FOR HIS ANYWAY THANK
YOU CENTER SKINNER
[inaudible]
YEAH.
I'M NOT SURE IN MY CLASS ALSO I
KNOW WHERE I AM ON YES.
I AM.
SEVEN ITEM [inaudible]
NINE AND FOURTEEN AND I DON'T.
SIXTEEN RIGHT CENTER SO YEAH FOR
ITEMS THAT WE NEED TO ADD YOU ON
TO AND WE'LL START WITH ITEM
SEVEN THIS IS SB THREE THIRTY
TWO THIS IS HERTZBERG RECYCLED
WATER BILL YEAH I DON'T RECALL.
THAT'S NO.
OKAY.
IT IS A NOTICEABLE CLOSER ROLE
ON THAT THAT'S A FIVE YES FIVE A
TWO NO.
WE'LL CLOSE AROUND THE THIS ITEM
NINE THIS IS -- ALLEN'S SB THREE
NINETY TWO GREEN CHEMISTRY.
OPENING AYE BATES.
I'M GONNA BE NOT VOTING ON THAT
ONE I NEEDED TO DO A LITTLE
READING ON IT OKAY ADVISORS LANE
ALSO THAT'S GONNA BE A FIVE THE
ONE THAT CLOSE [inaudible]
IS IT.
YEAH WE'RE BECAUSE YOU MADE.
I SPENT HOURS ON IT LAST NIGHT
AND I ON THE OTHER [inaudible]
AGAIN THERE.
THANK YOU SIR APPRECIATE THAT --
THIRTY SO MUCH TO ALL THE STUFF
ON BOTH SIDES THE I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE ALL THE HARD WORK
THAT WENT INTO MAKING THIS A
SUCCESS.
AND WITH THAT WE WILL FORMALLY.
CLOSE THIS HEARING.
OF APRIL THIRD OF THE AMARNA
CALLED COMMITTEE